[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the race to challenge the world champion
is heating up at the feed a candidates
in madrid spain reeling players look to
regroup while the leaders pressed their
advantage a confident ian napomniachi
maintained his hold of the lead deftly
defeating polish prodigy yong christophe
duda however fellow former challenger
american superstar fabiano carawana is
in hot pursuit after decimating a
struggling alareza ferugia round seven
of action-packed chess
coming up next
[Music]
good morning everybody it is time to
finish the first half of the 2022
candidates being held in madrid spain to
determine the challenger to magnus
carlsen to bring you all of the action
of today's round we are in our studio in
st louis i'm grand master alejandro
ramirez with my good friend grandmaster
yasser sarawan alejandro as always a
great pleasure to be here with you and
christian in studio to call all the
action what a needed rest day though
absolutely i think we needed it the
players needed it
but it might already be slightly too
late for some of the players in this
tournament only six rounds have been
played but it is clear that two players
are head and shoulders above everyone
else absolutely that's exactly the way
it is uh there's only been three players
out of the whole eight that have
actually won games hikaru nakamura being
one fabi being the other and nepa being
the third actually it's become a
two-horse race and it's almost a 90
chance that one of those two players are
going to be our new challenger let's
take a look at the current standings
alejandro please do the honors
sitting pretty with a plus three score
four and a half out of six definitely a
commanding lead but there's still one
person that is keeping up pace still on
his heels four points for fabiano carona
after a crushing win against alireza
ferruccia who really sent the frenchman
down and away from any real chances of
winning this tournament absolutely two
players richie and hikaru at fifty
percent and then of course let's take a
look at our schedule our schedule is
quite uh pardon me i meant the fordman
our format first
it's an eight player double round robin
and that's why i said that we're
finishing off our first half it's a 14
round tournament and today is round
number seven we have a classical time
control the most classical of classicals
a very long one 120 minutes for the
first 40 moves 60 minutes for the next
20 and once you reach move 60 you get an
extra 15 minutes and your 30 second
increment starts ticking nice no draws
before uh the 40th move half a million
euros and now let's take a look at our
face this schedule our face is three
rounds and the rest day three rounds and
the rest day we just had one yesterday
which means that we are in store for
three in a row and you see highlighted
there today round seven saturday june
25th our next rest date will be on
tuesday absolutely and christian in
studio with us to drill down and uh
bring us
new info new insights what's going on uh
christian good morning good morning
yasser good morning alejandro and good
morning to every chess fan around the
world watching this spectacular event
but let's take a look first at how the
top players got to where they are today
and we're going to start off with the
all-american that is hikaru nakamura
started off slowly with a defeat in
round number one against his compatriot
fabiano caruana but bounced back
immediately with a crushing victory
against the struggling timur rajabov
after that four draws and right now he
stands at 50
in fourth place and richie rapport the
young hungarian superstar well a
topsy-turvy event for him but no
decisive results whatsoever he had the
chances to take the full point home his
opponents had chances to take the full
point home but six draws up to this
point and one fabiano caruana the young
american superstar sitting in the second
position closely behind the leader right
now well quite a nice little right there
in round number one he started off with
a bang beating hikaru nakamura after
that four draws and a couple of days ago
with the black pieces a big surprise
huge victory against the struggling ali
reza firouza and let's take a look at
his road ahead well today a big
opportunity with the white pieces
against timur rajabov this one we're
definitely going to have our eyes on in
round number eight he will be having the
black pieces against hikaru nakamura and
that big clash between the leaders in
round number nine with the white pieces
against yarn pognash and speaking of jan
nepomnyashi the perfect lineup doesn't
exist well it does in round number one
huge victory with the black pieces
against dingley wren another big victory
in round number four and a couple of
days a crushing defect he inflicted on
jan shishtav duda with the white pieces
and let's take a look at his road ahead
as well
well today
very very difficult game against richie
rapport with the black pieces white
against ding in round number eight and
of course the big clash against fabiano
caruana with the black pieces in round
number nine guys every single day
mouth-watering match-ups thank you
christian that round nine date with
destiny looms large but alejandra set
the table for our viewers today what can
they expect from today's parents as
christian was mentioning a huge game
today between very creative players a
stylistic match made in heaven richard
rapport will be playing as janipomyachi
and richard is under pressure we had a
question from the viewer how can people
recover well this one is where it's at
if richard wins at least the tournament
keeps going for him he loses he's out
absolutely yeah we'll be playing against
hikaru nakamura in a very similar
situation both of these people are
desperate for full points and in the
third match of the day if you ask me
before the tournament started here have
a pencil and circle what will definitely
be the key match-up of round seven no
questions asked number one versus number
two number one versus number two and two
of the surging and favorite players of
the event daily wright is playing
alireza ferruja for not very much uh
avoiding last place pretty much at this
point that's not what we thought from
them no but the huge model would be
between fabiano carrano with the white
pieces a hungry player chasing
nepomiacci he's currently with white
against a weekend rajabu who missed his
chances against rapport who lost to
hikaru i'm sure that team favi has
prepared something spicy for today
opportunity knocking potentially there
for fabi and of course
lots of great fighting what are they all
fighting for
it's a handsome prize pool of 500 000
euros 40 8 000 goes to first 36 to
second at 24 for third you also get nice
it's not bad you get seven thousand
dollars for every point that you score
sorry euros yep but that doesn't really
matter right what everybody is playing
for is this a date with magnus carlsen
at the 2023 world chess championship to
four the crown jewel of chess we're
gonna still don't know where the
tournament will be or when exactly but
we know it will not be this year it'll
be next year very good to be determined
now what you're saying is
of these eight players we're trying to
get a challenger yes
everybody wants to win first
how why is it so hard to win five
players haven't won
out of the eight it's kind of a mystery
at the moment especially when you
consider
some of the players that haven't won
richard
hello
that guy is amazing i mean he's such a
crazy player a great fighter i mean he
doesn't draw he loses he wins but he
doesn't draw and here we have six in a
row it's almost unheard of honestly
i mean what do you think about
yonshishtov duda only having one loss
and five draws no way no way right i
mean just look at his uh tournament
record over
i don't care the last 24 months i mean
it's it's unbelievable how many wins and
losses these guys pile up and
and dinglarin
i mean the precision
that he brings to the chess table his
victories have been scorching wonderful
absolutely how
how does he not win a single game guys
if you would have asked me before the
beginning of the event after six rounds
who's going to make all the draws up to
that point it wouldn't have been richie
rapport no way a million he probably
would have been the last one
because he's such an explosive player
and every single day he brings new ideas
to the table also sharp ideas to the
table especially with the black pieces
his uh essaying this sicilians very
intriguing sicilians allowing his
opponents to get chances but he gets
chances as well and yet he made only
draws up to this point quite spectacular
it it is uh something to behold as the
games are underway again i'm thinking
that for f from fabi's point of view
i don't think so i'm thinking from
fabi's point of view he's white against
teamwork timor has not
won
neither of other players but we're
seeing an open well we're seeing a
sicilian with the early a7 a6 and i
remember
are you kidding me i i mean like this is
just i see
trash i mean this is not i thought that
uh
lots of top players have actually tried
the
on occasion
what is that it's a big surprise really
okay uh what is this
and i even remember some crazy no i i
think it actually went c2 queen c3 queen
a5 okay so what's the best move actually
against okay is it c4 and there's the
o'kelly i think both c4 and c3 are
guaranteed advantages yeah i thought
yeah i mean for me it was c3 i didn't
even realize that c4 is considered c4 is
definitely a move yes yeah because after
c4 knight c6
excuse me knight c6 d4
presumably right
uh isn't this a try for black with e5
with e5 well once the knight is already
on c6 i i thought you're not supposed to
play d4 because of this e5 but with the
knight on c6 perhaps
maybe i can take on c6 at that point
also in fact now that i played c4 i have
the extra square c2 for you
can
jump around because the trick of d5
doesn't work i mean there's d5 you take
bishop takes pawn takes knight d4 it's a
line right but it's not theoretically
sound and i don't even have to
okay i believe you i'm just saying a7 a6
a very very rare bird at the top in
candidates
never seen i mean so that's uh surprises
earliest move too guys exactly
impressive oh kelly sicilian i mean
hello uh richard rapport white against
uh
jan
and a petrov we'll
wait and see how
that one develops
and then we do have this english
dingler in back to the english remember
in round one this catastrophic start
that he had
versus uh nepo
and a bishop c5
d2 d3 okay that's a little a bit subdued
to my taste knight c3 knight
c6
and
knight f3 you know
something that's been played before uh
but only a few times this is not a very
popular position but dingleroon did play
this against wang hao
uh not that long ago i think
okay so
a known position i think for both
players sure sure
that's actually a question
what is this line of the english
christian what is this line of the
english called with bishop c5 this early
bishop c5 in this moment
um according to my database it's called
the king's english variation
say what
english
king's english
according to
i don't know the names
english
the king's english i mean okay uh
wow
did not know
me neither
you know i'd always associated it with
anatoly karpov because he liked to play
the sister system as black i just didn't
realize the kings and english well then
to be confused there is a big game in
this position just played uh in june
last year between wesley and fabiano so
fabiano has tried this idea with bishop
c5 we know that he likes to place the
bishop on c5 in this type of english
situations right played it against
magnus carlsen in the world championship
as well and this is quite an intriguing
way of uh doing it because you don't
have the knight on c6 so we see it very
often this bishop to c5 sortie
with the knight on c6 with the knight on
ba that's completely different situation
and the question is where is that knight
going probably what i'm seeing is a
rerouting of the knight to f8 and then
g6 or e6 try to get to the d4 square or
potentially d5 at one point and then if
we see the exchange of the c pawns then
the knight comes back to c6 let's see
how this game develops and uh yeah we're
definitely going to keep a close eye on
this one
all right well thank you for that i'm
still uh
reeling
no other way to say it right
darn and
whatever the okali variation has done
it's put fabby in to a thing
in fact i'm just wondering have he has
he ever
faced
this line as white i don't know if he's
faced it but we talked about it once
really yeah i mean it was kind of an
offhand conversation we didn't actually
sit down and analyze because who
analyzes this right but but we did talk
about it was if c3 or c4 was more
accurate
against uh a6 and um we both came to the
conclusion that
either one is just strong either one is
strong i mean there are some tries for
black it's not it's not that white
instantly has an advantage but basically
what white is trying to do is play a
sicilian right in which the move a6 is
not very useful and the one thing you
shouldn't do for our viewers is play an
open sicilian yeah that was my question
why
can't i just say well i'm not that
sophisticated right great you got a6 i
go d4 let's transpose yeah this is the
best version of let's say a night or
that you could get because you play
knight f6 in this position specifically
knight f6 you're attacking my pawn i
defend my pawn you take advantage of the
fact that there is no e5 in that last
position because of the trick of queen
a5 yeah e by the way i mean it took me
like maybe three tries i i lost the pawn
three on three different occasions you
know
but boy i really like attacking uh with
a game of tempo that night on f6 and
yeah well that's how you lose a pawn but
that's fine i want to play knight c3 and
now i'm just anticipating you playing
the night off and i'll transpose you
want to play dragon or
i don't know but what's the problem the
problem is to move e5 oh so you're
attacking my knight right knight's gotta
go and i could go back here but i like
to go here and there is where black
setup all comes together
you play the move d5 and the move a6
becomes incredibly useful you don't have
the resource of bishop b5 check which is
normally the main line of this position
when the pawn is exactly on a7 you could
play this position with d7 and d6 and d6
to d5
but you don't do that because of this
and now you're ready to either capture
or capture
i see so
you can't just blindly blunder forwards
with the d4 and get an open sicilian
you've got to yes you've got to be
sophisticated but now that you mention
it
the move c2 c3 intending to get a pawn
duo in the center yes
doesn't that exploit the fact you've
played a6 and not maybe a better move
like knight c6 or so uh that is why the
move c3 is considered to be one of the
more dangerous variations against the
ocala sicilian because
no matter which version of the c3
sicilian you play now to move a6 let's
put it this way it's okay but you would
have rather made another one yeah it's
questionable how useful it might be well
again i still haven't seen a response
from fabi so he's really mulling
things over well guys i have been
looking at the database and i've been
trying to gauge the interest of the top
players in this line and one player that
plays this with the black pieces
consistently
is vladislav artemyev
artemyev has played this game in fact
against fabiano caruana
and fabi decided to go with c3 so right
now and he lost that game by the way
with white pieces maybe this is what
rajab looked at he looked at fabi's
losses with the white pieces he saw this
a loss against the oakley against
vladislav artemis he started to analyze
the position and perhaps got to the
conclusion that it's not as dangerous
for black and that it's a try that needs
to be in this crucial game because if
rajabo wants to have a chance of
catching up with the leaders he probably
needs to start winning some games very
soon and uh specifically in the last
game he had a huge chance with white
pieces against richie rapport i'm pretty
sure he was devastated after seeing the
engines bishop to h2 that would have
killed the game on the spot and right
now he wants uh to get this victory with
the black pieces essaying as uh early on
as uh second move a6 is just an
incredible decision by him and his team
as well and let's take a look at what
happened in this game between uh
vladislav artemyev and fabiano caruana
e5 knight to c6 d4 to be honest i'm
looking at the position and i'm already
seeing a better position for white like
why did you play this move a6 this move
a6 doesn't really help you too much um
bishop to g4 so
it's almost a french with the bishop out
that's pretty nice that's a plus for
black right yeah bishop to e2 e6 knight
to d2 bishop to b4 and then knight to e7
and we get a very complex middle game
which probably timora jabot and his team
have analyzed thoroughly and fabiano
hasn't so that's a plus in my book for
black
uh my my question for you though is the
the c2 c3 alapan white opens yes
let me put this on the board uh pardon
me white opens up e4
c5 and white often plays the move c2 c3
here
with the idea of getting d4 and there
are two main ways for black to counter
one is d7 d5 what you just showed
as a
christian as well as knight f6
if i play c3 and you play a6 and i play
knight f3 i'm really happy i figure as
white i've got in
a very useful move knight f3 which is
always played on the white side of a lap
and then after d7 d5 why don't i just go
into those usual lines of the alapan
and
e5 looks to me
like a terrible move well terribly
strong uh
i'll say it not a terrible move
i've been infected
uh d7 d5 queen takes d5 d4 we're in an
elephant with a very useful knight f3
versus a
less than useful a7 a6
and i don't know why isn't that good for
white christian
that is a good question well
i'm looking at a lot of games and once
again artemiev wins this position with
the black pieces i'm seeing this game
against wesley saw so he's be beating uh
a little level competition now just to
point out that those are all blitzkins
blitz games of course but still yes but
still still he's getting decent
positions against the world's
and let's take a look at how that plays
out generally he leaves the knight on b8
so he doesn't hurt you with a move
knight to c6 this is the usual
difference we see the knight on c6
instead of the pawn on a6 and now that
kind of helps him right now for example
if you do want to uh delay the move
knight to c6 later on you could
potentially get the knight to uh d7 and
control e5 as well as b6 so quite a
multitasking knight let's take a look at
what happened in this one i to d7 as
we see bishop to e7
now the queen on d5 left in the fighter
like this uh could be prone to the
attacks of the knight on c4 knight to e3
nevertheless it does seem like with
careful analysis this position is quite
safe for a black so let's take a look
and wait and see how this game is going
to develop still we have an answer we
have an answer we do have an answer okay
c4 was played
i wanted to ask you since you have the
database and your engine there the the
only move here for an advantage is d4
and d4 played if you don't play d4 here
black replies e5 and that was the end of
theory and this is the main one this is
this is what i think we're going for
right yeah and what is the theoretical
let's say evaluation and follow-up from
here knight to f5 d5 exactly the line
that you guys mentioned at the beginning
of the show take on the uh d5 take on f5
or knight to d4 and we get this position
in which whoever has deeper preparation
it does seem like objectively it is wide
to be preferred right now nevertheless a
very powerful knight on a d4 i'm always
going to be able to corral this pawn on
d5 and most likely i will be able uh to
capture it and
regain the pawn and restore the material
balance in the position but this is the
type of position that we're going to see
and we're going straight into that line
yeah
knight to f5 now i'm wondering whether
he's going to go for something a bit
more tame with the move knight to c2
because you know your opponent has great
preparation in knight to f5 so why not
just tame the game a little bit play a
more quiet approach with the move a
knight to see to a more strategical
approach as well because this knight is
still going to land on d5 after the move
knight to seat why to be honest at this
point if i would be in fabiano's shoes i
would stop think assess knight to f5 and
probably go for knight c2 wow sorry uh
breaking news for me at least yeah i
mean we have to go there yeah exactly it
is the game between richard rapport and
and nepo as both players seem to be
playing what appears to be an incredible
theoretical duel
in a
petrov after c4 c6
queen b3 bishop g4
both players blitzing their move
up to this point bishop e7 knight takes
e4
queen takes d4 and then a question we
all
have to ask ourselves
can't i take the pawn well he did he did
he did but nepal said back can i not
take it or not right and now we have to
take it
and
what the heck are we uh looking at i i
can see your database yasser there
there's um there's two names that i do
not recognize which means it's a
correspondence game okay
uh it ended in a draw which makes me
think that this is a worked out
perpetual because nepo just blitzed out
the move bishop
h3 what a visual move that is
so you have to be made on g2 you have to
take or you get literally made it right
exactly
and then i guess queen g6 queen g6
checking h1 and where's my draw queen d3
actually queen d not queen e4 no queen
to d3 such a strange right strange move
it it even encourages the move knight d2
okay
pardon me queen these seven traps queen
d7 and we get that end game so you're
not actually going for a perpetual right
now oh
d7 try to trap the queen on a8 and get
into this in balance 10 game it's just
where there's uh
the pawn shield has been destroyed but
at the end okay let's say great you you
you trap my queen uh i'll just put some
pieces
on the board you go here i'll take a
rook you'll take i'll put my bishop out
or bring my bishop out
i've got two rooks and a pawn although
my king side's a little
flaky i have to say that
if i took on h3 right now after bishop
e3
oh sorry yeah i just if i apologize at
the end yeah if you took on h3 right now
and i have to play f3 i have to stop
yeah you have to stop this yeah
this is your first instinct that white's
better here
i feel that i have plenty of counter
play as black i can go f5 i can go
bishop d6 oh
yeah no sorry i
i don't think that white's better better
no no i think that because of my
compromised king
the queen can fight
effectively against the two rooks yeah i
i wouldn't say that this was a slam dunk
i've got
i i've out prepared you in the opening
or something like that uh we all went
there very very fast sorry about this uh
christian if i can turn it over to you
tell tell us uh
tell us what the theoretical
there is there's no theory as as you
guys were mentioning this is a game
between two correspondence players uh
but it kind of we were guessing
they are two correspondents uh players
but it comes back uh to the same topic
the fact that nepo is so strong right
now because of the residual knowledge
that he has from the match he played the
petrov in the match he's essaying it
once again and he knows his stuff
because he spent months on analyzing and
trying to gain as much experience before
the world championship match in the
petrov which was more or less a novel
for him so this is exactly what we're
seeing right now in this tournament and
that's why we can never count out a
player such as nepal before the event
not a lot of
people chose him to win this one and
qualify once again for the world
championship match but right now he's
showing that he's one of the best
prepared players on the planet and he
just blitzed out this long variation
which does seem to have surprised right
now richie we have gtx h3 queen to g6
i'm looking at ways in which uh this
could end in a perpetual an immediate
perspective
and i'm not actually finding that well
there's one way
probably king to g1 if you're playing q1
i was about to say rook g1 might
threaten bishop h6 in some circumstance
it will kind of encourage you to make a
perpetual yes rook to g1 is uh
perpetual as well
let's see if richie buys the bullet and
then uh christian i had a question for
you while i have you there we went
through a variation where we won white's
queen and we thought black was doing so
how is it like this queen yeah
and we put the knight on e4 or three
four nights
a six
decisive advantage for black
a decisive advantage for black yeah
minus two right now
so don't go there compete i i thought he
was doing okay i didn't think he was
winning advantage
incredible wow this is ahead also a
little bit of a surprise to me when you
think of richer rapport and yana pogba
she playing each other they have eight
draws and one decisive game right
uh but look at this one win
six straws
and nepo surprising us still uh he
didn't play the move queen d3 he
actually threw in the chuck queen e4
uh sorry uh
when we were badging yeah go back here
take check okay and then immediately
check encouraging f3 which was the first
move i actually
uh gravitated towards later you were
pointing out
uh the queen d3 to d7 so this encourages
f3 and i'm assuming
you're playing queen e4 now
i like this i like this by nipple i like
this
is really powerful preparation why the
inclusion because it invites white to
make a mistake and that is to go for uh
f3 f3 has to be played if you want to
continue the game right obviously queen
to d3 now once again knight to d2 is
going to be met with queen to d7 and it
does seem that imbalance favors black
now you can also go king to g2
check and now the only way to continue
if you don't want to get checkmated
after king to f2 is to go bishop to g5
i wouldn't consider it a nice invitation
by nepo you want to continue the game
let's continue the game like such
nevertheless it does feel like after at
the beginning of the line the computer
was saying that white is slightly better
right now it's already zero zero zero
and we know that nepo uh has used much
stronger computers than this one and we
know that he has a better understanding
and a deeper on understanding of what's
the assessment and what's going to
happen in the next few moves so this is
exactly what we're seeing right now an
invitation go f3 and let's play let's
see whether uh richie decides to go for
it
um
great quite great stuff
but richie does seem surprised right
but okay
like but why right you're asking why
yeah forgive me but if you get to this
position where you went queen
which is a very rare move let's remind
people that this is actually a very rare
move this move queen b3 right we
analyzed it recently i think
there was some dominguez mamedyarov game
where he went queen b3 media normally
you play the rookie one queen c2 knight
c3 cd5 they're all well known moves
exactly queen b3 is a rarity and
you have to be aware of this whole queen
b7 why did you play queen b3 well it's
not because you're threatening to
capture twice on d5 that would only
expose your queen to a discovered check
you you play queen b3 with the purpose
of stopping this bishop from developing
you're going to snag the pawn yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but what happens if the guy challenges
you you you have to be ready for the
move bishop g4 you're going to take the
pawn right away no
it turns out that this is all theory
so none of this should have really been
that
surprising whatsoever to richard
he captures the rook and now bishop h3
seems to have
stopped him yeah
excuse me but i'm confused now
this strikes me as a position that he
should know he should know
yeah especially because he took on b7 so
quickly right i think that you don't
have to take on b7 you could have played
rookie one or knight bc3 i'm sure it's
not required i'm sure it's not required
right i know that we have this
association which you might get kicked
out of but yeah but still but i mean
knight c3 rookie won their moves
right so you don't play queen b7
automatically if you have alternatives
this is what i think that he must have
known the position sure
and then he takes right and then
nepal plays the only move according to
the engines right
that has been seen that has been seen
in all fairness guys yes it does seem
that first of all i think that with
queen b3 he expected that he's going to
surprise his opponent now at the same
time bishop to g4 is not the main move
it's actually the last move in the
database knight way six seems to be the
main line d takes c4 is another way to
continue bishop to g4 has only been seen
at the top level in a game
all the way in 2007 between short and uh
hari krishna so after that the latest
game is the one between jones and
holland to 2300s so definitely not one
of the topical approaches in this line
and i also think that with the move
queen to b3 he expected to surprise nepo
he did not and right now he's facing a
big decision whether he wants to
continue the game with f3 and throw that
bishop to g5 in the position or just
call it a day and make a draw i agree
with what christian is saying he was
trying to surprise his opponent i still
don't find it excusable right
me either
so you're saying that well queen b3 is a
rare bird knight a6 has become
more or less topical and this is where
richard might have made his preparation
i'm sitting there saying
okay but for me the move bishop g4 is by
far and away the most aggressive and it
puts immediate question on you yeah why
did you play queen b3 if not to play
queen b7 and we get this position kind
of by force
very much so
and now
richie's finding himself
facing a very awkward question do you
want to avoid the perpetual if you avoid
if you don't avoid the
if you allow the perpetual everybody
says well
why didn't you play fitzgerald
right that forces your opponent to make
a draw against you uh i wasn't prepared
for you you had the rest there
another point christian we just had the
entire rest day to prepare this right
it's not one day to another yeah okay uh
i think he's gonna take the draw lots of
confusion going on let's just jump to
the game of hikaru for a second where
are you hi
look at that a normal position yes
[Laughter]
boy a normal position okay here we go
normal position yay
let's see how they got here
a normal position uh and nimzo indian
with e3 uh
rubenstein uh names of indian by the way
making your comeback
yeah
yeah
yeah
nice
c5 d5 i remember one time
in the 90s this was really considered
the great heavy theoretical battles this
is where all of the players focus i
don't even know how many
thousands of out of hours were spent you
know trying to
figure out these uh isolated queen pond
positions uh
but okay
well great high waisted jeans and the
rubenstein nymphs are in the 90s are
back right i haven't i also analyzed
this like early 2000s or something like
that it's been a while since i saw this
position exactly queen queen d3 setting
up for this battery sometimes the screen
actually also slides over to h3 bishop
to d7 and again this is a great
theoretical battle going on here
it's still early days and we'll see
who is the better prepared player
again it
we talked about this at the opening of
the show
coming into the tournament the number
one ranked player was dingleroon uh he's
playing the number two ranked player you
would have circled this
on your scoresheet and said this is a
this is a key key round it's
extraordinary to us
that
this uh
game doesn't have an an impact on our
standings in fact they're trying to
avoid last place
yeah
it really is a surprise when when when
gary goes up on stage
and says that
out of the players in this tournament
already
favi are two of his headliners right and
you think yeah that makes a lot of sense
sure the way that alirez has plummeted
in this tournament is is really
surprising especially the way that he
lost to fabi
when round six round sex you really do
think that at some point that was a
nothing position that he kept misplaying
and misplaying and misplaying until it
really became untenable right
with the white pieces the white pieces
right yeah and
also what we're seeing so far i mean
this has not been a great tournament so
i mean not to jump on uh flog a dead
horse but his time management has also
been less
than impressive as he's finding himself
in awkward situations with little time
on the clock absolutely and i think that
is something that actually helped him a
lot in his road to the candidates when
he was qualifying qualifying when he won
that grand swiss one of the great things
that he did was time management he
actually saved a completely lost
position against dario schwiertz in that
tournament because he had the better
usage of the clock when when it came
down to pure calculation objectively
white was winning but ferugia had the
time and darius didn't right and now we
see completely the opposite yeah it
really uh
it
well what to say that is not that the
wheels
fell off in this event for ali reza they
just never really
you know
and and this was a big question mark
that we had about ali reza we didn't
know how he reacts against the best
chess players on the planet because he
has very limited experience against them
he only played tata still then super bad
romania and entered the grand chess tour
but before that he hasn't faced this
type of elite competition and in that
tournament that you were mentioning
alejandro the grand swiss yes he did
have a great time spencer against the
low rated players but against fabiano he
lost that game because of his time
spencer and because the fact that he got
in time trouble huge time trouble that
was was unable to save an objectively
equal position so this is what we're
seeing right now it seems like whenever
he's facing top level uh preparation and
then top level competition all
throughout the game he does fall behind
on the clock this is a trend that might
hurt him okay you have his position of
danger and uh there christian well
actually before i have a different game
and this is the game between wesley so
and fabiano caruana
it's from this position the only game in
this position and let's take a look at
how this one they've transposed to the
game yes yes yes so let's see after be
one we still don't have a move
rookie eight no no rookie was played in
the game between um wesley and fabiano
so fabiano played this move rook to e8
and then at this point after bishop to
g4
by the way great move f3 he made this
mistake bishop to h5 bishop to c8 would
actually already give black
an advantage so i really like this idea
of bishop to g4 to try to create some
weaknesses prepare
in anticipation to attack the pawn on e3
by placing the rook on e8 i like this
plan but it does seem that
ali reza right now is not familiar with
the position and let's see how he reacts
because ding definitely knows what he's
doing he's analyzed this he did spend 20
minutes
of his time up to this point alireza
with 1 hour and 47 minutes and counting
right now thinking about his next
decision and how to develop the game
what is his plan queen to a5 is one of
the moves available rook 28 immediately
is another move available let's see how
this one develops
all right we will indeed uh we'll we'll
wait and uh
by the way it does seem like fabiano has
decided to go for knight to five so
perhaps we can go back to that one all
right just a second i was seeing that
that richard uh by the way was still
thinking
uh uh how to deal with that move queen e
forecheck to allow the perpet so when we
left it here in this o cali variation it
was the knight f5
a d5 and funnily enough uh they've taken
some time
to get to this position that we had
actually bobby's taken some time
he spent two minutes so that's pretty
much walking around so yeah so so
fabby's the guilty version obviously the
guilty one today in terms of uh slow
play yeah and then we're probably going
to rush into that position i don't know
if knight c3 is forced but no the rest
does kind of seem forced because we
already took on f5 pawn takes f5 is
the only logical move i can think of
right and then knight d4 yeah
um
after the move
knight c3 let's say all right
you go knight f6 right
i developed my bishop most people seem
to play bishop d3 from the database that
you have okay uh defending the pawn
makes perfect sense
of e7 or taking
most people take but i don't know what
objectively okay correct the new castle
now i've got
ideas
if we just stop and think about this
position
isn't white just obviously better he's
got the two bishops he's got a better
lead in development and for the moment
he has the initiative in terms of
getting quickly uh attacking the pawn on
e5
the problem might be
that these positions
might give black some way
of being forcing you know you get forced
into some type of an ending that may or
may not be great because of the knights
right some way for the knights to
yeah
i mean the knight on d4 is still there
but what you said just made perfect
sense in the sense that uh why isn't
white better i mean
he's the one who's been developing his
game
concretely you know made
opening moves and he's the one who's
saying like i've still
got to show you that your your your
early a7a6 was a wasted tempo
and i'm better
uh but again what's the theoretical
percentages
does black
score
decently christian yes black scores
quite well actually in fact i was
looking at this position by the way
knight xd5 uh does seem to uh be the
main move nevertheless i do think that
bishop d7 is probably objectively the
better decision right now so just wait
and take later on d5 there is no way
that white can improve the defense of
the pawn on d5 so bishop b7 castle
castle this is at the stand position
rook to e1 and by the way out of four
games right now three draws
and artemyev beating wesley so with the
black pieces so this is the position
that we're going to see and i have to
say in italian
but guys i'm really surprised by the
fact that fabiano decided to go knight
to f5 you you come to this position and
you start looking at it you know that
knight f5 has been prepared in and out
by your opponent you don't know exactly
with precision what the right moves are
right unless you've studied the o'kelly
which nobody does
[Laughter]
but
you look at the position and then you
have the choice of playing knight to c
to tame the game play a more strategical
game why wouldn't you go for that why
wouldn't you go knight to c2 you know
you're playing against a struggling
opponent right now why enter his
preparation i don't think this is the
right practical decision by fabiano even
though knight f5 maybe objectively is
the better move in the position
nevertheless knight c2 offers white an
advantage as well um
well i think fabia is a very principled
player i think that he is the type of
player that doesn't shy away from
complications just because complications
are coming his way right he is out of
all players in this tournament one of
the ones that will definitely
call your bluff right you bluff him
he'll say i don't believe you yeah and i
think that's what he's doing today
well one of the things about anatoly
karpov in the
1975-85 period was he was mr informator
you know this encyclopedia of chess
openings knowledge this eco and you know
he went directly down the fairway if
this was the main line you could count
on him playing the main line through and
through
and knight f5 might be one of those
moves but christian you're making an
awfully good point
one of the problems when you're playing
somebody who is doing a specialty
opening
like the o'kelly
they have their
script and it's really rather long right
and you go no i'm going to play knight
c2 and let's just play a game that may
be even
but i'm not going to give you your
opportunity of playing your 25 moves of
script but it's not even that's the
thing it's not even and you know that
it's not even you allow me to get the
knight on c2 that knight is going to
land on a d5 i am going to have a
strategical bind in the position as why
long term and the difference between
knight to f5 which you know probably
that is uh the most critical move in the
position and you know that it probably
creates the biggest problems for a black
nevertheless as you mentioned
he has the script he knows exactly what
he's going to do knight to c to avoid
theoretical discussions and just play a
game i think this was the practical
decision that fabiano had to take
nevertheless i mean fabiano is fabiano
uh he is the candidate right now and he
made his decision let's see whether he's
going to get rewarded for his courage
all right um
a quick question for you christian i
noticed that richie is really struggling
with this decision of whether or not
to allow a perpetual check
could i ask you what the engine thinks
his best decision should be at this
moment
well actually the engine right now is uh
saying that yeah take the draw
take the whole king
h1 king g1 queen g6 king h1 now
still the big question is at this
position right
bishop takes g5 now the engine is saying
that white has an advantage uh
at this point zero zero after bishop g5
it seems like white has an advantage
nevertheless i'm not 100 sure because
after king to h1 plus seven plus zero
seven and now after queen d3 the engine
is saying minus 0.2 so it always changes
it always flips the switch the engine
that is knight to c3 queen to d7 and
this queen is going to get trapped in
the next few moves you can attack the
queen rook to d1 i'll side uh side away
from you and then knight to a6 is coming
no matter what you do 20 minute thing
for a richard report right now
definitely struggling well look at list
you're thinking about okay do i finish
the game in five minutes or do i spend
half an hour and pretend that i'm
actually thinking about taking the draw
or not at least make a better impression
the interviewer uh asked me okay it
lasted an hour at least right right five
minutes i think this is what he's
looking at right now but i have to say
the practical decision right now is to
take the draw
yeah i mean that's the type of thing
you're at the board and you're thinking
to yourself
they're going to interview me after
their game and i desperately didn't want
to make a draw i was struggling i looked
at everything
but i'm very very yeah you know a
reluctant hero yeah you know what can i
say okay that would be
um confusing and
if the game was to finish
so very quickly
the game of icaro
we left it just around these points as
far as i'm concerned this is all still
theory but then again i haven't been
up to date on the latest and greatest f7
f5
one of those moves that just absolutely
absolutely shuts down
this diagonal does the move f7 f5 so
this move
uh really for me is a very sensible move
the bishop no longer so good on
b1
uh h7 will why not pop out to a much
more friendly diagonal uh a2 to g8 uh
and what is the theoretical
um results from these positions uh
christian well actually there's only one
game that has played yes only one game
in this position after bishop uh to b3
and this is a game going on today from
2010
two players that i don't recognize their
names it seems like perhaps ice landing
players uh nordic players that is queen
to b6 was played in that one they did
follow the computer recommendations so
perhaps this was a correspondence game
as uh well
it does seem like young sister of duda
is well prepared is well aware of where
he has to place his pieces right now and
let's wait and see whether hikaru has
the same amount of knowledge about the
position now the battle revolves around
the weaknesses the structural weaknesses
that black created with this move f5
sure you close this long diagonal there
is no checkmates that you have to worry
in the future but you are leaving this
backwards pawn on e6 that will be a
problem later on in the game and with
the rook on e1 already eyeing
that weakness this is what the
discussion is going to be this knight on
d5 is not moving anytime soon you're
going to have uh to keep the plug there
on d5 because if this diagonal opens up
you're going to have huge problems on
the pawn e6 the weakness in the position
i see white's position as easier to play
this is why i'm concerned about hikaru's
chances right now because queen to b6 i
understand that's a good move but later
on with that queen on uh b6 knight to a4
might become an idea for white right
nightway four get the knight to c5
re-maneuver and try to refurbish the
knight uh on c3 that right now it's not
doing anything the big question also is
what is the knight on e2 doing at the
moment i would love to put it on f4
right
but you cannot do that right now so you
will have to find different spot for it
it's going to be an interesting one i
have a strategical question for your
question while we have you there you
mentioned the move queen b6
queen to b6 and my understanding as a
player is that one of the reasons you
don't want to play the move f5 is that
in the cases that i take twice on d5
like i could do it right now sure
and then i go bishop f4
your dark
squares are suffering yes and i've
always thought of these positions as an
advantage white they all stopped yeah
yeah but the question is whether you
will be able to get the knight to e5 or
not right one day let's say
one little you can do about it
we'll see i will try to create my own
counter chances okay with the move uh f4
f4 i will hint at the fact that i want
to play f3 and weaken the light squares
around your king and then you will
probably have to respond with f3 which
in fact will give me some weaknesses uh
that i can uh try to take advantage of
as well especially this square e3 so
what do you do right now
no that answered a lot of questions yeah
i don't know
just the question of bishop f4 and it
does seem like the best move if we do
get to this position is to go g3 and
once again try to stop f4 but also get
ready to jump with knight to f4 and uh
transition that knight to e5
wow
g3 is one of those uh i'd be very
reluctant to light squares around the
king right yeah
but but for me the position that hikaru
currently has
i'm thinking that as black i might
beside the move queen b6 i always
thought of this as a fight for the
control over the d5 square and therefore
the move bishop c6 would strike me as
kind of an optimal move
that's the problem the pawn on e6 okay
okay but can you exploit it
i'm going to go bishop to g5 first and
by the way bishop to cc and this creates
an immediate threat right take on d5 and
take advantage of this pin so you have
to deal with that quickly so bishop g5
queen d7 queen to d7 probably the best
move and now i take on e7
simple simple chess you cannot take
with uh the knight because knight to f4
is coming for and you're going to have
some problems knight f4 and i have to
take with the bishop and then
it we're we're right you actually have
to take with the queen with the queen
yes if you do take with the bishop after
knight takes d5 uh
you're most likely going to get very
similar opposition to what we discussed
with the light square bishop but my
knight is coming to f4 there's no g3 in
the position your light squares are just
in shambles gotcha yeah
wow all right well keep an eye on that
by the way uh richie
first repetition we're still not there
very reluctantly has agreed to a
repetition this could be our shortest
game not only of the round or the
tournament i mean uh
it uh
it it never got off the ground it really
didn't it seems that jan came in just to
show his prep it's like hey richie this
is what my book says thank you for the
half point see you guys tomorrow yeah
boy against a dangerous opponent like
ritchie
great success for nepotism his world
championship preparation right right
there great great great prep from that
but i have to there's no other way to
put it the hat tip of the hat to nepal
but kind of like the alireza
prep against duda yeah it does leave
questions to be asked all kinds of
questions this is the candidates guys
exactly and to throw ronda white
if he were to if you were to ask him
right now you want to draw your way to
the end of the tournament i think it'd
be yes yeah baby pretty solid yes a plus
three plus three i think it's a
comfortable score and still uh these two
rounds coming at round eight in round
nine we've been talking about round nine
a date with destiny yeah uh but round
eight tomorrow against dingler in
fortunately for nepo fans he's going to
be actually with the white pieces
against the number one seed and let's
talk about the number one seed we
haven't had
so much uh to talk about with dingler in
uh when we left it
where just got to this point uh d4 takes
knight takes a4 rookbee won a very
standard move in these old indian type
of positions oftentimes you aspire for
b2b4
and you want to be able to meet the
ampisol ab3 with ab3
queen a5
tickling the knight on
c3 so that
b3 doesn't come too soon
and now we caught up with the players
after knight c2
normally speaking that move knight c2
runs into an issue here doesn't it
how how is white dealing with bishop
to e6
you can't play b3 or am i is my queen
trapped maybe my queen's trapped no no
you have e5
well
yeah so
hold on
we got the yeah
exactly
we have the technology uh bishop e6
what am i missing help me
i'm sinking
christian
i'm done there we go there we go yes uh
bishop to d2
bishop
bishop to d2 you cannot take on c4
because of b4 or b3 and you're actually
losing a piece
so indirectly with the move bishop to d
defending
b4 forking your queen
and your [ __ ] three works also okay and
then you go amphison happily saying ha
ha ha there's no double attack against
my queen
but now you take and you hit the bishop
at the tempo
and you do win a piece
next
line that is very pretty uh
yeah because unless you see that
my gosh we just came to us a full
screeching halt and alireza played
bishop f5 which does seem to be the
better move in fact well an indication
at least he knows what he's doing yeah
that's a very good thing
well i'm actually wondering if you if
you force e4 which is a natural move i
think right bishop f5 e4
and then you go back to e6
i was about to say bishop gg4 but okay
go on you you've got to be curious where
are you going well the line doesn't work
anymore for white right because your
rook on f1
is now hanging
oh nice so after b4 a b a b
you get to capture rook because the pawn
is no longer
on e2
clever
perhaps that's the idea
it got me convinced it looks very nice
and i if you don't if you don't meet
bishop f5 with e4
well still that move bishop d2 may be
discombobulating right or disconcerting
i am threatening to uh
uh leap
jump
uh somewhere where the gain of a tempo
against the queen bishop to d2 will
tickle the queen
uh this is a very strange looking uh
position for us we don't really have the
zen of it yeah ourselves christian could
you just tell us what the theoretical
conclusion oh we're out of uh
theoretical knowledge oh we are yes yes
yes we are for quite a while that was
the game wesley saw versus caruana right
with the move rook to e8 queen to a5
does seem to be the novel move in the
position now it all ties together
because after r28 in that game as well
fabiano did play the move queen to a5
next
he started off alireza that is with the
move queen to a5 and that invited knight
to c2 bishop to f5 this is the position
we currently have on the board we're
expecting bishop to d2 right e4 as you
uh mentioned alejandro very nicely
pointing out the fact that now the pawn
on c4 is actually a weakness because it
comes with an attack on the roof so
bishop to e6 has to be met by queen to
d3 which looks a bit awkward especially
this queen on d3 with a potential knight
coming to e5
you have to take some chances as white
and unfortunately doesn't seem like
you're in time if this king would be on
h1 after queen to d397 and f4 that would
look quite well promising right for uh
white yeah unfortunately because if your
king is an
ig4
then you have different problems
knight to g4 queen to e2 and then we
discussed that position right right so
quite promising right now start i have
to say for ali rezab but the position
remains very complex and there's a lot
of pieces still left on the board
they're sure nothing being changed a
couple of pawns that is but it's a very
different story than the game that we
have between richie rapport and jan
right because uh well everything got
chopped off the board and now we got a
perpetual in that one he's still
thinking by the way it seems like richie
is still pondering his last moment to
potentially play f3 and continue the
game
i don't think he should do it
he he should not know if i want to lose
this early with
one game that's still theoretically uh
still popping right is the game between
fabi and timor because when we left it
we left it after takes knight d4 bishop
d3
and we were expecting the move knight
well f6 we actually we were actually bam
we were actually considering knight c3
first instead of bishop to d3 that is
true
knight c3 knight f6 and only in that
case bishop d3
and thabbe just said okay
i'm going to play bishop to d3 right
away
queen takes d5
and
uh once again sorry christian just help
us out because this is a 193 plate
this is not exactly my most topical uh
book
uh so it was um it was knight c3 first
instead of bishop to d3 which was the
main line
now he allowed taking on d5 directly
with the move bishop to d3 which
according at least to the theory as well
as the engine doesn't give um white too
much of an edge in the position knight
to c3 queen to d7 this is what we're
expecting to see
in the position and i was seeing moves
such as long castle no
proposed by the energy
we're gonna get some spicy chests but i
don't believe in this long castle what
long castle yeah yeah this is the top uh
engine move at least this engine uh that
we have right now
who knows what timor is preparing these
positions with right so long castle
still a potential in this position i
don't see timor going for it because
it leads to some spiciness right in the
position and i'm not sure he wants that
uh queen to d7 and by the way this
hasn't been played so perhaps this uh
move bishop to d3 allowing teamwork to
take on d5 surprised
the young azeri right knight to c3 maybe
can you take on g2 likely after bishop
before you might regret
that decision in fact yes you do regret
that decision white is complete it took
a while but yeah it took a while for the
computer to agree that uh queen g2 was
taboo yeah
is not possible but could i look i mean
because you really rocked our boat i
mean it's early morning here in st louis
i get that with the castle right the
castle i mean uh i've seen that in
scandinavian kind of games where you
castle long
but in this case you have a pawn on c7
gone there's like pawn on the sea fire
right look ma no hands no protection
yeah i'm just going to run away and now
we get some wild stuff you know i
understand the long castle you are
developing the rook on the best square
in the position you are hiding the king
for the moment
you do have a beautiful knight on d4
that i will have to address soon right
but you're also lacking the light square
bishop as blacks okay that might such a
big creature in my view but but sorry
just this position i take the knight on
d4 i can't you count countenance okay
that night and then i put my knight on
e4
i wasn't even going to put it on a4
actually on a4 okay let's let me take
this pawn you let me munch on that yeah
i don't know yeah i don't know
queen b3 but but alejandro is inspired
he woke up today feeling v
vim and vigor he went knight a4 b5
get out of here
well maybe he didn't wake up so early
get out of here b
b5 b4 i mean 85 take that
if you go to b6 you're going to lose
that knight and actually you are going
to lose that night no matter what you do
it seems like i'm going to lose that
knight and i have the the eye side to
see that it says minus 0.2 right right
so that position
is complicated yes
wow wow
and if i if you had gone knight e4 and
i'm very curious to see what it does
seem like quinton d7 is not within his
preparation within okay keemur's
preparation perhaps he did not consider
this move bishop to d3 as much
that's 35 instantly he did he didn't
think about it by the way he did play
finally he played the move queen to d7
okay so
let's see if he goes for long castle
after castle because castle we think is
going to come pretty much naturally
right that's a very natural looking do
you want is is there any point of
considering bishop to e3 first
still long castle
remarkable yeah and again coming into
today's game
looking on paper the matchups you have
to say okay fabi
is looking at this he says i gotta get
close to to nepo
i i'm white against the lowest rated
player in the field who hasn't been
playing that great not that bad not that
bad
but uh opportunity
maybe
castles long that will be quite the
remarkable game ikaro nakamura once
again the only other player
in the field who
has managed to
i want to say when a game has played
queen b6
after some thought that was the expected
move by christian and now well
listen to the commentary he took on d5
very very quickly exactly i don't think
you have a choice you have to take with
a knight exactly you do you
your game
would not be a positional it'd be a
positional house of cards uh bishop
takes d5 i like what you were suggesting
uh their
uh um
with the move bishop f4 alejandro i like
the idea of playing against the light
squared bishop and to try to maneuver
uh the the pieces around uh that's still
a heavy strategic game we're going to
keep an eye on that
richie has it already finished that was
my question nope nope not yet
and who's doing all the thinking yeah
still richie what's going on through
your mindset what do you play do you go
on what am i going to say in the press
conference which second do i fire
right you know
yeah do we still get snacks in case
we do we get kicked out of the playing
hall do i have my you know
uh
three or three o'clock t
um
nepo's
winning chances
at the moment
they're pretty good these are our
percentages based on just by the numbers
shout out to this work that they're
doing it's a statistical model based on
ratings colors etc
and i think they're actually going to be
joining us will be on the show that's
wonderful yeah yeah uh jane pogbachie is
a 54.1
wow
so yan versus the field
you should get some money yeah
and wow and five is really the only one
that's keeping this alive i mean you
take a look at the rest i mean the
statistical model doesn't give them
he carries at 2.9
seems a bit low
yeah because yeah they're drawing their
way out but what's remarkable about this
is both fabi
and yon did win game
their games in game six right yan won
with the white pieces fabi fabby
black pieces yes that's why uh
yeah
a little bit and you can and the odds of
winning the magic of television there it
is really surging players here
but nepo
wow there's nepal putting a master class
in the tournament so far today is no
exception i'm sure his odds will go up a
little bit further if the results don't
change we have four more draws that
favors him no question about it i mean
with the black pieces too
wow it's all
we i mean
we've been saying this for some time
already pinch me this tournament's going
so superbly well i mean oftentimes you
prepare yourselves for success
but i don't think even in his wildest
dreams
in his mind
anyway as we prepare for our first
commercial break you have a special
commercial for us from cute boutique
absolutely we have an athletic jacket
from the world chess hall of famers
sister organization across the street
that we love very dearly
it's a track style zip up jacket and it
features the world chess hall of fame
logo it's available in both men's and
women's styles and it is sold
exclusively at
qboutiquestl.com so help us out and look
good while you do it nice we are going
to leave you with a special uh you and
maurice oh yeah we went to the park
together some time ago that's right
we're gonna keep our eye on the games it
is possible that one of them finishes
while we are on break that would be gone
against a rockport but that would just
mean that it's a draw we'll see you on
the other side of this small break
[Music]
hey man
well i tell you maurice i got really
strong feelings
about the topic
of
how chess
the generation of today
versus our generation old school versus
new school years old school versus new
york
these youngins don't know anything about
the old school stuff
but you know this is it this is where i
got the strong strong feelings but mixed
feelings
like
i love
the fact
that i had a germans i learned so much
through analysis and studying
and doing myself chess was a mystery
right it was a mystery it was great
a lot of times we didn't know what was
really going on we didn't we didn't we
had to press ourselves and really dig
deep into the position
and
i missed having an opponent i really did
i was like i was 12 13 when i got
started nobody wanted to beat up on me
but nobody wanted to lose either so i
was like always sitting watching
because from afar because i couldn't get
a game right
now you got an opponent 24 hours a day
anytime you not just an opponent
somebody's strong 3 600 opponent you
know you got to play
time you want
man
getting the games the data you know like
the bulletins of the soviet championship
that was like
gold three months later three weeks
later you bought some games right that
was played somewhere in moscow or nick
sich or some place in the world right
and nowadays it's automatic it's it's
it's live when you get it six million
database of games i you made six million
it's like eight nine million now yeah
where are you
it's unbelievable so i'm in
insanely jealous of
the kids of today the generations today
all the tools they have the internet
chess was different maurice chess was
different gary kasparov said it well the
other day blitz chess was five zip
threes it if you were a maniac you know
you had three dreaming no increments no
time was the time the hands were like
this shaking you're right banging clocks
yeah
wait a minute fix the pieces right what
are you doing on your time and you
didn't know how much time you had left
today
[Laughter]
and then you made the time control you
made the time control
and the flag never fell like one minute
two three minutes you had been bashing
the clock like nothing and like you had
more time than you thought no nowadays
they know to the
tenth of a second right how much time
they had left and the thing is even just
the idea of studying books right books
books what are books taro doesn't look
at books you look at books wow they got
the databases they got the engines
that's it you just ask the engine what's
the right move here exactly you don't
need somebody to tell you that the
principle in this position is to control
the center
a break in the middle no the computer
says screw your break in the middle bam
it's mating six right this wins that's
it you're you're talking nonsense that's
what levon had said in an interview he
says
i don't want to spend
20 hours studying and open
i want to hit
my space bar this is facebook and just
give me the answer
like you know people spent i want to say
lives but that's like a look studying
you know what i'm talking about the
sicilian dragon that was their pet if
you they couldn't play the sicilian
dragon they weren't interested in
playing nope and they put
everything their heart and soul into an
opening and today they dropped those
openings like nothing man i got no
commitment to you if you're not
producing the result go and back in the
day you stuck to like three or four very
fearful openings that was a lot that was
a lot like this is a lot this is what
you play
you know if you play the carrot con
that's right the french that's what you
do that's it now you see these guys play
six or seven different things and know
them well like this is like i could put
the sicilian i could play the camera i
could play the french i might throw
modern at you right you never know i
toss out an alicon to do something crazy
he said how are these guys playing all
these things and they know the theory
they they only quote the game even if
the game was played a week ago right got
it yeah this was just played
it's incredible just a touch of a button
and the thing though that's got to scare
you
or maybe it frustrates me is when they
start looking at the classics and saying
the classics like why
those guys didn't know what they
they were doing it like they made all of
these mistakes the engine shows
alekhine's combination was unsound
even though
even though it took years for people to
really analyze the combination was it
sound was it unsound quick story quick
story two guys victor korchner tigran
petrosian hated each other i mean
intense this was like the rivalry to end
rivalries and i was victor korchnoy's
coach
and they got together for a candidate
match
a couple of draws couple draws an
adjournment
and they got to this crazy position
coachnoy thought he was winning and i
said victor you got to play g4 no no no
no no ain't playing g4 ain't happening
no no no g4 is terrible we look good
petrosian took a timeout we spent 24
hours seriously
michael steen myself victor we worked
hard intensely on this adjourned
position he said
victor you've got to play chief
i caught him in a moment of deletion
horrible move rook c8
you lose
okay he played the right move h6 h4 he
made the wrong move bang bang bang you
lose
finally he plays all the right moves and
it's a draw he says see it's a draw
i go yeah but i think the positions are
dry it was a queen versus two bishops
and a protected passport on c3
we go to the playing hall and said
victor you're going to play g4
i go sit down in the audience back back
playing hall dark
and
victor gets to the position instantly
plays g4
hits the clock i want to stand up and
cheer yeah that's my move everybody you
know applaud me that's what i did what i
did
sit down
petrosian
writes down a move 10 minutes passes
trosian doesn't make a move another 10
minutes pass petrossian doesn't make a
move
35 minutes pass before petrossian makes
a move
and during that 35 minutes
i went through
hell
torment
stone cold absolute fear what
if i had made a mistake in my analysis
and korchnoy loses
to his most hated
rival this would be terrible right
so i'm in like
after 35 minutes i'm in a trembling
panic
petrosdian plays rook c8 the first move
that victor played against me bang bang
bang bang bang
victor
i was won relieved
today
that movement no mystery consistently
yeah instantly would have been the best
move or the worst move or the right
answer that's why adjournments had to
get booted out right just because of
engines now and you look at openings
that used to be garbage back in the day
right
rehab for sure all of a sudden
white had all these advantages back in
the day
evaporating in smoke right how do you
think that that
has taken something away from modern
chess has it made it less rich less
interesting
or
or do the players just simply have to be
more creative
yes and yes that's the crazy part it
seems to me that chess evolves with
these new tools whatever they are the
internet increment just evolves
yeah for me i love the mystery of chess
okay that's taken away but look what has
come in its place
these guys play chess more accurately
today than ever that's the truth the
quality of the games are remarkable
incredible they are you know what let's
play
like the old school days yeah baby move
it come on get it i'm gonna follow y'all
sir juan's advice oh yeah you know
you're scared of this in english you
this is what you get yeah yeah yeah okay
you remember them days playing carp off
oh it was so much fun it was sweet it
was sweet he's building a fortress i
haven't even come over here
let me do one of your favorite moves
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are here round
number seven of the candidates and what
an hour of chess we've had because it
has been very unpredictable and this is
our current standings
at the top he is currently playing his
richard report let's jump straight into
that game got it for you as after an
hour of thought richard say you know
what let me try this f3 move first
before i just
concede a draw
well i have my pride i'm white i don't
want to make a draw that soon and after
f3 by the way napo has been playing
allah tempo queen d3 on the board forget
about pride pride is what kills you in
this position
i mean go king g2 queen g6 bishop g5 are
you going to
play that move no i think what he's
doing right now is just prolonging the
game one more move uh king g2 queen g6
king h1 he can still take the repetition
and pride will not kill him if he does
indeed go for bishop g5 i think he's
going to be in a world of trouble does
he get invited to a lot of parties not
really not really
why
would white be in a lot of trouble
christian in that not objectively no no
objectively it's fine the position is
more or less balanced but
you're facing youn's preparation so why
would you want to do that why would you
go for bishop to g5 just repeat the
position go home save some energy i get
it
you're a proud man young hungarian and
you want to get a fight but this is not
happening in this game just accept it
go home get some rest and that's it call
it the day yeah one of the things i must
say that for myself uh especially at the
board
i
oftentimes i got this very strong
impression that i was falling into my
opponent's preparation
and whenever i got that feeling of
unease
no no
i i pulled the parachute i said you know
like i'm not going to you know just let
my opponent you know display his
homework and kill me now yes sir was
there a point that you would consider
uh i know that it happened to me on my
earlier years as a grandmaster and
trying to get to the title that i
wouldn't be afraid of trying to refute
something over the board yeah that
engines were already existent but they
weren't the engines that we have today
and then i did feel that if i had enough
concept of a position that there would
be some positions where i'll be
comfortable saying you know what
your preparation is trash
no no no no absolutely especially in my
day where engines weren't strong
uh and i
i enjoyed uh
those moments where my opponent would
come and say okay i've got a trap for
you i go really in my favorite variation
you think you're going to you're going
to trap me well show me
right
so yeah i mean especially
in those variations where i had a great
deal of confidence
then it's sort of like yeah no no i
don't believe that you've got something
that was going to throw me off and i'll
try to refute it at the board and
oftentimes i did
today i must have i must say though
i'm intimidated i see somebody
sacrificing a pawn and one of my
favorite variations of a super sharp
karo khan and a guy
i back down or a knight
yeah i mean hello i back down i'm like
oh boy you know i
i'm i'm facing
rip car stock fashion
[Music]
that's not much fun it's not much fun
and this is kind of what's going through
richard's mind right that
what are you refuting here you're
refuting
a super engine i know
right
what's uh what's up with that now in the
mov in the position on the board
uh in case of king g2 the move queen g6
check has been played
more or less routinely why is it
that black
should not be playing the move queen d7
trapping the white queen and prepping
knight a6 are you trapping the queen
here that's my question if i go bishop
e3 specific that might be the problem is
that you get to go bishop e3
and then suddenly the queen
emerges
uh on the a7 square which is
why
we've been
focused on the move queen g6 check
and again king h1 that's a repetition
and bishop g5 keeps the game alive but
maybe
uh
maybe too dangerous can we just take a
look at this by the way
right okay what happens
you take with the bishops i think i take
with the bishop fair it seems a little
more logical to me but okay i can't
explain to you right now why
okay i have a couple of direct threats
right bishop c1 is just winning so you
got to do something
okay i will let's say sidestep the
discover check oops excuse me yeah
sidestepping the discover check and now
we have to think because queen d3 is
still on top and the difference is that
now that you no longer have this bishop
i assume i get to play knight c3 without
two three uh any queen d7 move is it
probably going to get hit by rook t1 and
i think it's okay
queen d7 anyway okay knight c3 uh queen
d7 you go one of the rooks to d1 i kind
of assume the a-work okay
and i think i just put my queen on c7
and i still
okay and now you're threatening to move
your knight but now
that your queen doesn't cover e7 i could
for example play rookie one
and block
the attack to my queen that's a very
good point
with the move rook e8 now in this
variation however i am not down as much
right an exchange i'm exchanged instead
of a run um
no it's even on the pawns three
and a pawn yeah set up one so after the
move queen c7 rookie one maybe since
your queen's not getting out anytime
exactly it's i'm not threatening b5 or
something right to liberate maybe my
queen maybe this is the time to find
something right whether it's something
like queen f4 and you start attacking
the pawn on f3 actually maybe this well
yeah it looks like a very decent move to
me
okay um still i mean the desirable queen
b7 is being met by queen f3 uh queen
takes a7
not completely
ridiculous
no but i will play king g2 just because
i i love a good bond shield
everybody does everybody should love a
good pawn shield yeah perhaps i'm over
playing my hand a little bit i should
keep my queen on c7 just to keep the
queen on a and snare yes fair
that is fair and i will go for rook f1
to e1 well uh
certainly something uh for both players
to
you can actually continue that uh right
so you can continue trying to trap the
queen with bishop to e7 so the problem
is whenever you go knight a6 rook to e8
so why don't we just like plug that file
well because
i would think that the moment i played
knight a6 here i'm gonna get hit with
rook takes e7 yeah he's distracting the
queen from the defense of c6 and
allowing my queen which is an exit which
is super annoying and how is that
position right okay so we make a pass
we make a pass we go a2 a3 we say go
ahead and
do your work execute your threat and the
problem what alejandro just mentioned is
the move knight a6 attacking the queen
so let's go knight d7 we go
munch so let's go knight d7 ah so let's
go knight d7 and now
if we go
number that's not good
i keep my rook that's right
you keep your rook oh dear
and
by the way i've lost a bishop too yeah
either with the knight we already lost
the bishop in the process right true so
you actually don't have enough material
for the queen here you have to do
something crazy like knight d5 or
whatever but at that point
black is playing for the advantage yeah
with the two pieces just to be clear
we're we're
we're uh rejecting
this line where it looks nice that we
have two rooks on the seventh rank but
your key is still so weak that's a big
problem our king is weak and uh let's
move queen f4 and if he ends and if i
take with the other rook
sorry uh you go rook takes eight and i
go rook e takes d7 i guess it's a little
ugly but just putting the queen on the
eighth rank as sufficient just to stop
just to stop rogue d8 right yeah because
quick queen b6 actually loses but queen
a5 also is a move queen a5
b4 and g3 g5 yeah i like it let's go on
the other side
okay but don't forget that in this case
i i do have a pawn that's a rook
and a knife by the way he played knight
d2
no draw guys
but now he's worse actually after knight
d2 queen d7 which came
instantaneously on the board by now g5
which we were considering let's go ahead
he's going to kill richie guys that's
the thing
that is crazy i have never done that in
the sense of
purposefully taking a worse position
uh to keep again i think he knows it's
worse
he doesn't know that it's worse
i'll pick up this queen pretty soon
okay night day six right and then we
have to evaluate this and richie spent a
lot of time evaluating came to the
conclusion that
he's not worse
and he's wrong if nepal wins
with the black pieces
again
against ding with the blue we've already
seen the odds are 90 percent he's
winning against richie i mean two people
you know that he's still within his
preparation right now
he is still within his preparation and
reaches down to his last what
47 minutes against one hour and 50. we
do have 94 on the weekends on the board
christian i wanted to ask you because we
actually saw this but slightly different
we saw this with the pattern f2 when we
asked you last there was some it's like
an hour ago yes what is the
numerical evaluation
for the engine minus 1.2 that's a lot
actually that's a lot that is a lot
and you know that once again maybe a
better engine gives more of an advantage
to black
nebo is in cloud nine right now he knows
he's better he knows he has a
devastating time advantage right an hour
an hour on the clock to the good he
knows what he's doing in the position
and his opponent seems to be not
objectively lost but borderline in a
losing situation
and
again the line is very very forcing
knight to e4
knight to
queen takes bishop takes you got to
develop and get your rooks into the game
so maybe i don't even have take with a
bishop i can take with the king as well
but let's say bishop takes sure okay uh
bishop are you going to try to preserve
the pawn on h3 probably not right
no i was i was trying to get the pieces
out as fast as i possibly could bishop
to e3
and i just wanted to ask you why the one
plus for black it's just a long-term
advantage i just have the better
structure and in general when we see
these type of imbalances uh two rooks
versus queen it's very important that
for the side with the queen that they
have targets and this is exactly what
the queen has in this position a weak
king
targets all over the place on uh the
king side as well as on the queen side
this pawn on c4 a bit too advanced i'm
going to be able to target it with queen
to e6 later on if you do defend it with
b3 well sure that's okay i'm going to go
jump with the knight to b4 and then the
target on a2 as well i'm going to be
able to combine my forces to create
weaknesses in the position not only that
but okay you have a beautiful outpost
for the knight on e4 nevertheless i can
target that knight with f5 as well later
on so queen to e6 in fact if you do
place the bishop on e3 queen to e6 is
going to come with two threats that is
queen take c4 as well as f5 later on and
taking advantage of the fact that you
have too many pieces on the e file so
i have targets
with for the queen and this is extremely
extremely important when we do assess
this type of imbalances
i've been told that a very concerned
fabi has been kind of circulating that
table and going
he should be let me reach in there make
a draw
it's funny that the players always do
that in the previous round nepo had
already
got into this destruction position
against duda he went to circle around
the fobby game against alireza yeah he
actually went to the board and saw that
fabi was up in exchange and just went
like
oh
sorry to say that sorry to see that uh
not surprising for me at least uh timor
did not castle long
against uh fabi instead what he did
after white castle short
timor said you know what my king might
be best served on the king's side played
knight f6
yeah right i mean where where it's nice
and safe uh
tidy things up over there
um on the other hand two bishops but i'm
looking at this knight on d4
and i've got to say that night on d4
just feels
great i
i think timor is looking back and he's
saying why didn't i play the o'kelly
well i'm going to ask you a question
that i i've been looking at this for a
little bit and i couldn't find a
concrete answer what do you do against
your key one
rook e1
okay uh
long castle no i'm joking
well the point is of course uh it it
it's excuse me uh
i understand the the joke uh
very very funny the idea is that the
rook is uh desired
on this uh file i guess uh you get to
know three to to do things like this and
maybe it's nasty maybe not bishop
here
where am i driving the rook what am i
doing well that's the question i mean
the rook's fine on like h3 or whatever
yeah right it's not like it's going to
be tickled off the the three e3 also
maybe i can take on f6 and go rogue d5
in that position is that an option
so here yeah worst case scenario right
maybe we have a number of bailouts you
can take only five also so we we do have
to consider that knight takes c5 bishop
takes e5 queen takes d3
uh the king is kind of stuck on the c
file so maybe queen c1 might be a bit
problematic but see
g4 queen g4 queen c1 they look pretty
dangerous all of them yeah yeah with a
missing c7 pawn things could happen um
rook e1 okay i
i haven't found
that easy an answer if i hit hit you
with h6
that's you could
take an f4 i got this i don't want to
take on f4 i couldn't go knight e4
take a knight e4 you can also go bishop
h4 right you could also just go back and
ask you how did h6 really help you right
i don't know
i
i don't know
uh that's why we have christian
christian what is the answer to rookie
one or we're not fine there's no
immediate answer actually uh after e1
you're just supposed to give up the pawn
rook 21 either to d8 or just simply
castle but it does seem like rook to d8
rook takes e5 and just castle and try to
find some sort of um compensation in
this position knight to c6 is a threat
more or less so you do have to kind of
uh engage with that
uh move around how do you play this
straight white has a pair of bishops
right and it's up upon mesut and you
have a thread that realistically can
take one piece that is kind of unclear
of how to deal with okay queen f4 queen
queen to f1 let's go
don't i have some no i don't have knight
f3 right now e7 because the e7 bishop is
hanging out yeah and if you go to knight
c6 and we drop back with the rook i mean
yes i'm getting some
ideas some trickies in the position
queen
then you have to go f4
okay you should be seven tricky i guess
yeah it does seem like in fact this
position is more or less equal
what because you're going to take only
seven i'm going back and then i'm going
to recapture on f1 i would have always
thought that white retains something at
least something right yeah not not in
that case f1 i think allowed me this
knight to c6 and 95 ideas
you do have better ways of trying to
keep the pawn on the board so routine c5
castle maybe queen to e1
is uh the computer's recommendation
knight to c6 rook to e3 but the queen on
e1 right now is uh much better placed so
this is the discussion that we're going
to uh see between these two players
right now but it does seem at least
there's a positive force
not only that he has a slightly better
position but also timor has started
thinking so that's definitely an
encouragement encouraging sign for
fabiano that final position
has me absolutely tasered some somebody
yelled something in my ear and i have no
idea what it was because i cannot
believe that you have the pair of
bishops equal development you're up a
pawn and we're just going to play just
play chess after rook d8 and you're
saying
look i'm a chess coach for
the world champions and i don't get why
white isn't better you've got the two
bishops as you've been mentioning that's
pretty nice
i like that it's true
i've got an extra pawn i don't have
issues with my king so it's not like
this obvious compensation and the engine
is saying we play by the way let's
invite you
our audience to join with us
in studio ask us questions and we do
have social media absolutely join us on
twitch join us on twitter join us on our
live chat we are scouring the internet
for the best questions and we already
have one let's take a look from twitter
whoa the old rapport is back but is that
a wise choice against nepo
well
that's the million-dollar question right
and we think um
before before the fall goes the pride
and this was not a good choice by
uh by um
richard i mean he's really uh pushing
the envelope we think let's try to
understand what's going on through his
mind right i feel
that
pressure yeah the pressure to score
today right a lot of people were asking
when are games going to be decisive and
i think one of the points i made a
couple of rounds ago is that the more
the tournament goes on the more the
players that are not at the top right
will feel this need to win yeah the
anxiety factor just grows and grows for
richie
six draws in a row it's like some anish
talcum power doctor right is
around and this man
is used to these really double edged
uh fights where both sides can slip and
fall and to to draw six in a row that's
not who he's about and he's
challenging he's taking the risk i would
have thought that richard by this point
in the tournament either would be
surging
or would have fallen apart exactly i
would never have thought he's there i'm
50 in the middle of the pack and i feel
that right now he looks at the numbers
i'm sure that he is not completely
oblivious to the percentages that are
being given to him qualifying for the
world championship match right now and
and they're dismal
well again if you told me he was fifty
percent i would say yeah he won
he won two he lost two you know
i mean you know he gave up somewhere
something but
yeah and what he's done
is he eschewed
this uh repetition
and he we're catching up with the
players now he did capture the queen and
this is the position we've gotten and we
think that after a move like bishop e3
it's one of those queen
versus two rooks imbalances
where for the queen to be effective
the opponent's king needs to be at risk
and or
there's targets well black has both yeah
the queen takes h3 the white king is at
risk it's a permanent weakness yeah it's
a real permanent weakness he played
bishop f4 actually he played bishop f4
yeah bishop f4 instead of bishop e3 and
then
okay this is the current position we
have on the board and i know what yasser
wants to play i know what yes or wants
to
the reason i didn't
like this bishop f4 in in some ways
it incur
but then that would be walking into a
pin right so it encourages black to want
to take that knight and teleport it to
the three square where the where the
bishop will be attacked
um
i don't know bishop f4 versus bishop e3
bishop f4 looks a little loose but i
don't see it at the moment
i don't see a tactical issue with it but
i also don't see why you can't
take on h3 and then figure it out yeah
true true
queen takes h3 and we're thinking
uh like the viewer's question
that black is actually the one who's
having more fun than white not to say
that the tables can't be turned but
again i i'm with christian on this one
this still feels like we're in nepo's
prep
i don't know if bishop f4
i studied it it might be ending it's
it's a natural point to end right and i
like this i like this we play on right
this is where we stop
and
it's landed him in such a great position
because i am confident that nepo knows
he's better and the reason that i'm
saying that is because he must have
analyzed this with an engine the engine
told him white has to take the draw
otherwise he's worse and what happened
richard didn't take the draw ergo
he's worse
let's jump
for a moment to the game of hikaru
because
we've seen uh a number of themes that
you and christian were talking about you
like this idea of bishop f4
and uh rook to e8 it was played
g2 g3 and i was saying you know
golly but that would be a move that i
would be so reluctant to play i mean
my opponent has a light squared bishop
and i'm making
uh squares around my king the light
square is a little bit weak
uh takes takes rook e4
and we've caught up uh with the players
presuming
that the move knight takes d
d5 is taboo you're opening up
the light squares around your king
something that maybe uh duda doesn't
want to do but
should we look at it is this a
uh shall we fight knight takes d5 i
would just take on d4 i guess oh you're
not i can always thinking
all the way
and d4 is hanging what's wrong with you
today
good morning st louis i don't know
what's happening queen takes d4 sorry
yeah that's a very good answer and i
think that's just that's just it
so rook e4 also can i take on b2
i'm sorry what did christian say he want
to take on b
maybe black can be more ambitious and
take on b2 he's saying
just to be more ambitious but
i mean queen takes d4 looks like
an easy equality for black queen takes
me to maybe a
wow
get to try it makes a sense right d4
still hanging why not and the more you
open up this position the more this
bishop on d7
yummy yummy yeah there's some nice
diagonals there for that but how good
are these players guys because we were
looking at the position with the engines
right and all the way after this move
bishop to b3 which seemed like it
surprised hikaru it was a novel position
for him as well and then he spent a lot
of time and he found the best by far the
best path forward we were looking at
moves such as bishop to c6 and if i
would be playing this position probably
i would try to reinforce knight on d5
play bishop to c6 and then be worse
right but they find somehow they find
directionally the best path forward and
this is exactly what we're seeing queen
to b6 great move by hikaru and after
that
bishop to f4 rook 88 instantaneously
played by the way which was the best
move once again by the engine
g3 bishop takes the f4 knight takes the
f4 rook to e4 again the best move by the
engine they're just so good all of them
that's why they're candidates
and it brings me the question of ding
laren because in the game of ding loren
after this middle bishop f5
uh tickling this knight on c2 bishop d2
uh
black said hey look man let me just
develop the pieces
and i thought that white's whole setup
was based on the idea that he wanted to
play b3 which means that you can play b3
now you yeah set yourself up for it
right i mean i've got this uh pawn on c4
kind of sits out there like a sore thumb
a weakness that i can easily cover no
doubt but i should do it now and play
the move b2b3
and suddenly i saw this move rook c1 and
i got completely confused
uh in other words what you were just
saying i'm with you 100 christian the
accuracy of the players is marvelous
something to behold then i see this move
rook c1 and i'm saying
is that accurate
why did i play with v1 well yes sir i'll
tell you this
it's clear that there's two players in
this tournament that are playing
outside out of their minds they're
fantastic
2 900 tprs by the way on these guys from
the others
yeah
nobody's standing out only he carved in
one
i think hikaru has played the best out
of everybody else he doesn't he hasn't
gone in the opening positions that he
really wanted it felt that in some cases
he was just solving problems with the
exception of his game with nepo he comes
out of that opening with something to
work on
but i think he played very well against
alireza i'm still really impressed by
that game where he got out prepared and
is able to just calculate his way out of
trouble
but from the other candidates
they're not impressive but guys if
fabiano wins this
nepal wins this today and everybody else
draws this tournament is pretty much
over for everybody but fabiano and young
we
i mean a miracle would have to intervene
for some other player to win this one
it's true it's true
i mean
also those guys at the top are beating
those guys in the midway the halfway and
in the bottom so they're just pushing
them down further down and down and down
right
it would be hikaru if he draws this game
and he would be a point and a half away
from fabiano from the second place a
point and a half
two points behind yon
seven games left seven games left we
will only have one la one round left
if
nepal wins we think magic numbers could
be eight and a half and nine eight and a
half or nine we think wins the
candidates right uh it might at least
force a a playoff
if he wins he would go to five and a
half yeah
this is not the this is not the current
the current score is four and a half we
were jumping the gun a little bit our
production team is very excited about
their position yeah about the position
here
right
i would be excited about his position as
well because the computer is giving him
already a decisive advantage what what a
decisive advantage minus 2.3
in the position right now after rook 81
queen takes h3 came on the board right
gift me the pawn yep rook 81 and right
now after the move h5 which to my eyes
is not a very natural move yeah he
played
which i was much more sad a little bit
more natural much more sense absolutely
it seems like hey
he was trying to get actually the pawn
all the way to h3 and try to create some
problems that way for the white king
that was the computer's estimation about
the position h6 was played much more of
a human's approach yes of course the
position still remains extremely
difficult for a white from a practical
perspective but also from an objective
point of view wow
could you put h5 on the on the board
once more because if you played h5
you're saying the computer is
anticipating getting that h5 pawn to h3
yeah that's not intuitive later on later
on in the game so how it gets there it
does feel like you're going to try to
use all of your pieces so reroute this
knight from a6 c7 to e6 get the queen
back to f5 and then push the pawn and
try to uh squeeze black white's king
like that let me put a move out there i
understand your plans i see the knight
currently crowled on a6 let me go a3 a3
yes that's that's okay i'll go knight c7
or knight
knight c7 i will be very happy
i'm always looking at the position with
the bishop e3 this bishop f4 just didn't
yeah
[Music]
yes and this is a decisive advantage for
black sea i would never guess that yeah
decisive with that
h4 h3 is coming so how do you stop that
i understand i would guess that black is
better if you if you gave me as a human
it's minus three almost that's crazy
yeah that i would have guessed if if you
had said
minus 0.7 i would be there yeah i would
i would reject going to this position if
i had a draw in hand right just
but not feeling nothing
he's down yeah i think it's your pieces
or at least one of your most important
pieces the rook on f1 is pretty much
paralyzed that is a good you have to
keep the rook on f1 to defend the pawn
on f3 and you cannot play this position
with only one rook and the bishop the
bishops kind of cancel
each other and you cannot play the
position with a rook versus the queen
you're not going to be able to create
any sort of
chances any sort of targets in my
position with only one rook and this is
the idea whenever we see this type of
imbalances both sides need targets as
white you don't have any targets and you
cannot run the the rooks need to stay
connected so that they defend each other
but the problem is the rook on f1 is
tasked with the defense of the pawn on
f3 when you look at
when you make that compelling argument
that you're making that the rook on f1
is is tethered uh to the rook on d1 you
play a move like b4 and i play bishop d4
then it's just you kind of go oh yep
oh
i was trying to chase your bishop into
or square a war square and i have
actually made it even worse by the way
we do have after the move h7 h6 we do
have the move bishop on f4
drop back
to g3 minus three
minus three it's it's the same idea
right you're just saying the knight c5
i like that move knight c5 the spirit of
the position really never changes
the rook on f1 can't move can't move
how lost is this position right now
and how bad was rich's decision to keep
going keep playing this position right
well join the conversation
and
let's pile up on richie today um
again
i i
i can't stop saying this uh richie's six
draws is really confounding it's not
what mate because because he does this
yes
yes because he does this right
but then because he can be uh a farouza
too right yeah and i'll play
uh in anybody in the field uh i'm
playing knight c5 minus three holy
cow i mean that
didn't expect um in the game of by the
way once again his line score
six consecutive draw
just can't win again
those tournaments where you just feel
like everything you try
you're you're minus three you're plus
three you're minus three you're plus
three and you're drawing all your games
and you just can't figure out what's
going on yeah it's very frustrating it
truly really is somehow it's even more
frustrating than winning
they're having the wave right right yeah
yeah it feels that roller coaster the
roller coasters but you think it's part
of chess i played a strong player i was
black and then i took my chances with
white or like i had a miracle with black
you're happy because you feel like
you're playing a tournament sometimes
you feel like you show up
there's nothing you can do it's
pre-ordained all the games are drawn
can't get out of it that's it go away go
away all right why are you even in the
tournament but i i have felt like that a
lot exactly in some events
well conversely too you get on the
roller coaster ride and you say oh my
god this is driving me nuts i'm going to
make a safe solid draw not even close
you get even a worse uh
emotional ride
by the way uh duda after some time he
after the route moved rook e4 he kind of
backed down he said you know what you
guys are right
pawn on d4 is hanging
let me just deal with that
probably you don't want to touch my pawn
on b2 that will invite the rook dropping
and then you play the other rook or the
other rook
because d4 oh d4 is hanging nevermind
somehow it trapped your queen in my
in my lines okay so
actually can i throw in f3
yes
that might be uh
right
well well it's not over wait a minute is
that completely true queen b1
oh
give me one is next
sweet
okay that's styling okay very good uh
uh still uh something's going on here
but i agree taking on b2 i don't think
is in many people's agenda no no no no i
was more curious i assume that the
reason that he plays the e-rook
instead of the a-rook yeah amongst
defending b-2 is that i can meet bishop
a4 with rook d2 and i can't in the other
variation bishop a4 tickling the rook
rook d2
meets an issue
whereas in the game variation what
you're mentioning
is bishop a4 can be met by rook d2
without
hanging
something on e1 even though
even though once i said all of this i'm
still not very quick
what's my rook take on
i worked so hard to put my rook on on d2
why am i doing this um
i was thinking that this bishop might
actually go to b5 yeah uh parkinson's
itself on c4 well i wanted to park it on
b3
fair
i mean
you achieved the wondrous odor
i achieved the wonder for
bishop b3
defending the pawn on d5 and going for
the e file we'll keep an eye on this one
because hikaru
again with the black pieces one of the
only three players to win a game
okay that is keeping this one alive yes
dingler in once again
is this move i i didn't get my question
answered is this move rook c1 accurate
christian christian seems to be yeah it
is just a fine move it's pretty good i
think there are options at this point is
not like your course to do anything like
massive right you can play e3 if you
want like we saw
b4 is a move as well to change the
character of the position but rook to c1
just maintains the character of the
position as it is also free up frees up
the knight on c2 from this pin so knight
to e3 now is starting to uh become an
alternative for a white so
rook to c1 makes a lot of sense to me
but doesn't knight e5
force b3 in some ways um or no well
first of all you have to get off this
diagonal right because knight e4 is
going to capture the bishop on c5 you
don't want to lose no bishops uh-huh
that is true so if i waste for example
it's indeed uh at least an immediate
threat knight to e4 potentially even
knight to d5 in certain cases you have
to be careful so what do you do now
okay i can see that the computer wants
to play rook e8 which is a fine move
anyway
yes but this allows me to go knight to
e4 right how do we assess this position
after i capture on c5 say queen c7 just
for a moment queen c7 i take take what
do you think the knight with the knight
okay with the knight yeah and then
bishop c3
bishop to f4
i don't feel black has any problems here
yeah the position remains complicated
yeah yeah that's true that is very true
so very good but ali reza on a huge
thing right now it's
been about 30. that's what he does it's
been about 35 minutes i think it's not a
critical position it's not the time to
spend all of your uh all of your clock
allowance right right i think that's a
very fair point christian it's not the
moment right this is not that critical
no what happened a couple of days ago he
spent 40 minutes on that decision of
playing knight to d2 or knight to c3
which was a very natural move and then
he had to please
whenever he was lost yeah yeah the in
the first dozen moves he had yeah it was
the knight c392 and i think there was
even a third choice and he just spent an
enormous amount of time played knight d2
against fabiano then knight f3 he didn't
even go to e4 right and
then it was even and with no time he
started making mistakes and by the way
guys speaking of a long thing right
jan did play the move knight to c5
this is turning into a no contest at
this point i mean knight to c5 the moves
are easy easy that's the thing the moves
are easy for black right i don't have to
worry about anything you're not creating
any threats
that's another important uh part of
playing chess
is this idea that
um
your move
it's like your hand is guided i mean you
you slot this piece in over here you're
like i mean everything flows it's easy
you're having an easy decision
queen versus the two rooks you've got to
coordinate the rooks whether you know
you get the rooks on the eighth rank the
seventh rank and the open file it's
incumbent upon you to coordinate the
rooks when you're playing with the queen
the queen inherently is powerful
wherever she is
so it's just easier
as
uh black and
you know
especially when you have this vulnerable
king
um
volunteering going into this
type of position on his own accord a
bad bad decision bad judgment by
richie i don't think he really feels or
understands the position the difficulty
yeah difficult
i have to agree with you because
risk management in chess it's a very
real thing you show up you show up to
the game you get surprised
and oops you have to make a choice uh
you you sometimes as a chess player are
capable of taking a worse position and
saying you know what it's complicated i
cannot play my opponent the complication
i like it i like it let's go right but
the more you look at the particular
position that richie has and he did
spend an hour on this decision right man
the more i look at this position
why would you embrace this embrace this
for white right we do by the way
richie is suddenly waking up to the idea
that this rook on f1 is really misplaced
it's intolerable
that this queen constantly attacks the
rook it stops you from playing the
desirable
rook d8 and he has played the move
rookie one and i'm looking at that move
i i i was the first move that comes to
my mind sorry this one was 996 of course
i want to stop the rook from coming in
and furthermore because white's king
is vulnerable i want to keep the pieces
on the board i want it
now i like queen f5 h5 right now that's
all starting to percolate with me i get
to play h5 h4
drive this bishop on g3 which well let's
face it is a pretty good defensive piece
of
of white's king right
suddenly the idea of h4
uh takes on a new
uh
desire that you want to do it
the the if you could drive the knight
pardon me if you could drive the bishop
away drop a knight in on f4 oh my god it
would be positional over here it all
comes together so easily for white for
black for for black
and again white's positions are awkward
difficult making them
trying to coordinate the rooks isn't
easy
uh jan is just having a stellar a
stellar first half hard to believe
so much has gone
so well for for for for netbo the first
half again i remember vessel and topolof
in san luis argentina where the first
half
was unbelievable is like six out of
seven something
ridiculous guys but since that time
napo breaking news though
rajabov after a very long thing
he played long castle
whoa we have a game wait wait wait wait
wait we have a game after you won he
played long he developed all his king
sides
and then he
so he could have castle along
immediately exactly
exactly but first and then put the
bishop on scene
right long castle now do not allow this
bishop to come to g5 attack the knight
on f6 right this is the worst version of
course
i explained it in like two seconds why
did you put the vision about e7 no no
comes with almost a tempo right so how
do you continue in this position because
you don't even you still have to lose
some tempest to hide your king away
because if the king gets stuck on c8
you're going to have huge problems
this is starting to look really good for
fabiano and once again fabiano both him
and jan are in prime positions right now
to win today
that's going to create an immense
separation between them and the rest of
the field
it just becomes accentuated that much
more so and 1.3 i was seeing in in
1.3 it's a lot
and again coming into today's round
these two players have separated
themselves from the rest of the field
they both win again
that's crazy that is crazy that would
really really be
amazing which again
yes it's a double round robin yes
they're going to face each other in
round nine
that's the date of destiny that at that
game unmissable day could clearly define
the challenger
i mean because everything because what
they're doing to the rest of the field
is just so bad
i mean uh they might be lapping uh
last pro last place
i think he already is right
well the rest was on two and nipples on
four and a half they're lapping last
perks
and this is the round nine pairings that
we are talking about because check out i
mean nobody cares about the other games
check out this match between fabiano
caruana and yeah
that's it that's that's the tournament
wow
wow
the winner the winner of that game that
that that
yeah that's it guys with several hours
to go
the third position will be
two and a half points behind the leader
if they want to win out right
if we want to point out right they want
to force a tie break
only to force a tie break two points
away with seven games unless he carol
wins today unless the car wins unless
he can you can disturb the geometry
geometry a little bit there right
because he would still have chances
especially an important win against duda
with black i think puts him back in
somewhat of the conversation but at
least after this point we don't really
see that happening
right he's not in any sort of like
imbalanced position
i'm not 100 sure whether he's better now
on the other hand guys i have to say
that i really do like these um
candidate tournaments and sink field cup
tournaments where you have
you know two horse race
and it's thrilling right right i mean uh
instead of just fabi going 7-0 at the
start of a tournament and putting it to
rest right but
uh
to see
these two players
who coincidentally happen to be the last
two challengers i mean as well it's nice
it really is nice and they're they're
they're showing they're showing their
stuff it feels
that the rest the rest of the field
doesn't show the prep i would have
expected for a candidate
i don't see
the opening ideas alireza here and there
but his play hasn't been wait what about
leo kelly alejandro
yeah i mean that's great preparation
but i don't i don't understand rajabov
is the one that proposes this variation
takes on d5 right immediately right
right so he knew up to queen takes d5
and you're telling me that four moves
later the the position is 1.3 yeah it's
right so one of the things to
really bring our audience into what
we're struggling with so we've got this
situation right here after white
has made his 11th move castles and we
all kind of pooh-poohed the idea of
castling long now should black play the
move castles long then we can start to
understand that well maybe this bishop
would
would drop to c5 the king would go to b8
maybe on a good day this knight would
even go to e7 and maybe to c6
reinforcing his colleague protecting the
king et cetera et cetera
what confuses us is if you're going to
castle long you do it now you do not
delay it
with the moves knight f6 and bishop e7
where the bishop is passively placed on
e7 and now
you make the decision to castle when
maybe these two moves that you've played
are not the most incisive and you're
given
in this case fabi a chance to really get
a sizeable advantage
well said thank you very much
i prepared it all day
before i came
all right we are going to take a small
break to gather our
strengths
it has been a very confusing round so
far everything to play for still the
games are not over no don't count the
players out just yet anything can happen
in chess we're gonna be right back in a
few minutes after this short commercial
break what around guys true true see on
the other side
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Music]
that's our show now go start yourself
this is
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are an
important round seven of the candidates
and why is it important take a look at
those standings jana pogbachie with four
and a half points is followed closely
only by fabiano caruana and we think
they both have
between
this position fabulous position between
great and decisive advantages both wow
and that's what it's all about uh
winning a tournament and becoming the
challenger and here are the pairings for
today richard rapper playing against
janna in which we think jan has already
a crushing initiative uh yanshi of duda
is currently playing a more or less
quiet name zoe indian against hikaru
nakamura king loren is still in the
midst of the middle game against alireza
ferrugia and fabiano caruana we also
think is just up upon against uh timor
jabo and cruising
and in this game of our tournament
leader
easy for me to say richie
we saw the move knight to e6 and we
really thought holy smokes uh things are
going great for nepo and after the move
a2 a3 guess what this move h5 coming
back to the idea of playing h4
moving the queen
going h3 and this king
is going to really really suffer with
this pawn on h3 rook to d3 and then for
me this move is a surprise queen f5
it's a good move nothing's wrong with
this move but you just played a
h5 so you could play b which is h4
why on earth don't you play h4 uh you
can't give up control of the f-score
square knight f4 is just going to kill
you you can't play bishop f2 right
because it must not is knight f4 right
but what do you do against knight f2
knight f2 is the question ah
okay so there was no i had this
blindness because i'm sitting there
saying i i so want to play h4
knight f2 which he did yes sir queen to
f5 b4 and now h4
the b came on the board a came first now
the b is on the board
good
that's what it's all about right and
just playing in a much better version
because right now if you do take on h4 i
follow it up with knight to f4 where do
you put the rook it doesn't matter queen
h4 is going h3 is one thing queen h5 is
another one yeah
if i something like rogue d2 you'll just
get hit with queen's five or queen h3
greenish five species
yeah bishop g3 happens to be a defense
but there's no difference i mean after
h4 i think you're borderline just in
resigning i i totally agree i mean i
i've been
you can go bishop to f2 but once again i
mean i just take my knight on f4 right
now
i think you actually have to go all the
way down the board and just
i i can't live with the knight on that
f4 yeah i i agree with you the officer
actually bishop on b8 is hard to hit
right just get it out get it out of the
way but i'm not saying no no no no i'm
not happy at all as white here i think
it's
yeah losing actually uh
but it's just one of those
i i had missed knight f2 so thanks for
thank you for clearing the cobwebs uh
the current position h4
it's all day in napo this is really
great now why is
fabi doing so well
well one two three four five
very good the training the training uh
castles long
and thabbe said i don't know
but in my world that e5 pawn is a very
good pawn let me take it
rook takes e5 on the board knight drop
back to c6
now i don't think there was anything
particularly wrong with rookie three he
just he just shows
bishop takes f6 as a better way
i think of
of handling upon hiring an extra pawn
right well the fact that you had some
initiative hitting the bishop on d3 uh
what was the uh
was it a knight d no knight d5
there's knight b6
yeah at the end of the variation you
don't
you don't get to hassle me
because knight b6
hurts your feelings
uh rookie i guess it's bishop c5
maybe it's just bishop c5 and perhaps
your rook is a little uncomfortable on
that side of the border i don't know
maybe uh in any case uh bishop f6 bishop
f6 rook d5 and queen e7
we're up to date with the players
assuming queen b3
looks very logical you defend the root
you don't give up the d file
you uh
prepare to bring the rook into the game
and maybe really discourage king b
because if a bishop takes a6 as well so
what if i after queen to b3 what if i
take on c3
how does this line go i'll take with the
pawn i think right
i don't see any reason to give up the
file so if you take with the pawn i take
on d5 follow it up with rook to d8
okay
oh where'd i put my queen this is an
issue yeah so you probably want to go to
c4 right i can go to c4 because you're
pinned
correct yeah we're tickling up okay i
really want to drop my bishop back
but that's the thing like once you drop
the bishop right it's a pawn right
so after bishop takes e3 maybe you can
start with
rook takes d8
right rotation a rook takes the eighth
queen takes c3 okay okay keep the
structure intact true actually yeah that
keeps the structure
nicely and and but the question is how
is the end game or are you going for the
endgame after queen to e5 is that such
an easy end game
i understand you're a pawn up but i do
have some activity true that
queen takes e5 knight takes e5
the computer says that white is doing
really well but from a practical
perspective i'm wondering whether this
is that easy or not i think i'd need to
be accurate for a couple of moves like
my evaluation of this end game would
depend
on the next couple of moves can black
really establish the rook on the seventh
for a while can i kick it out and by the
way you don't you're not forced to enter
the same game no no no no no we're just
uh
we're just having fun with it i like i
always like the bishop
against the knight with
uh flank with pawns on both flanks a
light being a pawn up just looking at
moves like rook c1 shack and or f4
with the idea of challenging the rook on
the second rank without getting mated on
the back rank
knight d3
i'm sorry which move knight d3 knight
david three yeah
and uh
once again the question is
how much better we we know it's better
it's clear i mean
giving up the bishop is not that great
i just wanted to see
this is not a this is a very funny end
game right end game uh d5
uh sorry which move d5 rook david five
it feels like it helps me with just fine
so
h5 let's vacuum a couple rookie five
also rookie five king d6 and i wasn't
sure about this end game
king d6 rook takes d5 king takes d5 uh
my first feeling is i should be winning
yeah
completely awesome so i i go f6
you can go
okay
that's okay
let's just say king c4 for the tempo but
in any case it's it's two result game
for sure
uh queen e7
i i'm not forced to play queen b3 the
other thing i was thinking about is in
the current position you kind of go to
yourself well
what i really want to do is i i want to
activate this light square bishop
somehow and what's the best diagonal
that i could get on is maybe the long
diagonal you want to play bishop before
immediately
or bishop c4 sorry
yeah
yeah one of those two but the idea was
to
any we've been looking at variations
where you trade on d5 maybe i should be
trying to recapture with the bishop
not necessarily the queen
that's also compelling did i hear
crickets
usually everybody can't wait to get in
there with a shout right like hey man
look at
your king is hanging you can't do that
everybody went
so bishop takes c3 bishop takes c3 i
feel like i need to get rid of that
knight yeah just like c3 but now
yeah now this is so if i take on d5 you
take with a queen right or do you take
with a bishop i'm not even sure but the
queen does run in the pawn yeah
i i did want to take with the bishop but
you go c4 next right
yeah
and then get on with my business of
queen g4 queen h5 or whatever so let's
see that let's let's go with it i was
trying to get my bishop which is
currently on d3 by the way
by the way fabi please uh has to listen
to you
no
once a one well one per broadcast we get
it in but these guys are good yeah yeah
if they're good did he play bishop c4 he
played yeah
yeah i mean you want to get that bishop
again strategical play
are my pieces are effective the problem
with the bishop on d3 as we
we've seen just a moment ago is actually
vulnerable there
on the other hand put the bishop on this
long diagonal and suddenly it's turned
into an aggressor and it's really
taking over the initiative so i like the
move bishop c4 i like the fact that fabi
is a pawn up i like the fact he's in
clear second and he's undefeated i mean
uh you know things have gone well for
nepo but uh things have gone very well
for fabi2 and we were mentioning that
the only player that could potentially
catch these two if they do go on to win
is hikaru okay but right now i'm looking
at hikari's position against judah i'm
getting worried uh-oh because check this
out so knight takes f4 rook to e4 to uh
d1 i think this is basically where we
left it after d1 bishop to c6 but we
were looking at something else
to defend this pawn on a d5 from a more
active position right right that is
bishop to a4 followed by bishop to b3
also hinting at bishop c4 ideas i have a
lot of uh
intriguing ideas and after that i can
develop my own counter play via the e
file he played the move bishop to c6
which strikes me a bit as a passive
decision
h4k rook to e8 queen to c3 and now g6
you have to make a decision by the way
how are you going to create more space
for your king left with h6 or luftwaf g6
the problem is both of them visually
don't look very compelling if you know
h6 i can uh play the movie h5 and then
this knight coming to g6 at all times
looks quite threatening right so he
decided to go g6 but now
it just feels like
it's a game for two results i don't see
the activity for black and i see that
white can improve their position quite
easily knight d3 at some point if you uh
if you don't pay too much attention and
this is exactly why the engine wants to
play a4 kick out the queen and take the
queen away and then go knight d395 right
if i managed to get knight to e5 i think
strategically your borderline lost right
so you have to stop me at at all costs
you have to go a5
but now that's another weakness for my
queen to look at i can go b3 reinforce
the structure on this side
and then go rook c1 queen c5 at some
point maybe just develop my position and
what are you going to do as black where
is your counter plate where is it are
you the counter chances i i'm ready to
jump in with some answers uh and for me
i really don't like the move g6 i don't
like the move g6 he spent a lot of time
on it and it's a very strange move and i
can
get in why it's because
when taught as master level players i
think yeah that you have a bishop
you don't put
all of your pawns on the same square
because then your bishop looks
ridiculous that's point number one point
number two is the very very desirable
move is rook takes f4 g takes f4 now if
your queen wears on d8 you get no
no rewards for wanting to play uh queen
takes h4 the other thing is
when you have such a position you're
thinking about a rover you put your pawn
on g6 you're denying yourself
this opportunity of uh potentially
sacrificing an exchange
and
you know it's a real pity that this
bishop by the way is on c6 and not
anywhere you know like close
to making um a kingside
entrance if you will
rook takes g4 g takes f4 is this
terrible what i'm doing i mean just help
me out here how bad would have been this
actually i'm assuming queen g3 yeah i
don't know if i would start with 28 i'm
assuming
i feel i feel here you're over playing
your hand because okay as long as i have
something like h5 and i stop you but i
think that if i like to remove rookie
for first okay i really like that idea
of targeting the pawn and then figuring
it out
going there after right
because who defends this
it's got to be the queen
it's not going to be the rook but from
where d2
g3 once you've got queen d2 yeah i'll go
your beloved
queen d8 so i queen d-a i dragged your
queen to a worse square right and now
i'm munching on h4
okay so
here here's the way i go about in my
mind organizing attacks okay
the queen is the last person i worry
about the queen gets there it just it
just gets there right the piece i worry
about is the bishop
okay i gotta get that guy
to f3 i don't know how i'm gonna get the
guy to f3 you know but i gotta get the
the queen
might go to d8 it might go to g6 it
might go to h6 i'm i i'm open i'm i'm
opening a lot to this position i like
this
sacrifice exactly
but
any exchange sacrifice where you played
the move g6
it becomes
less attractive to my eyes the move g6
doesn't fit right with these attacking
ideas he didn't do it he did play the
move g6 let's see where this is taking
him
uh g6 on the board b4
and we've caught up with the players
okay isn't it knight d3 knight e5
christmas time
most likely that's going to come and
we're going to
come back to this before it keeps
hanging sorry guys a lot of things are
happening please the nepo game oh let's
do it
a lot of changes b4 was played h4 bishop
to b8 this was the move that we were
discussing it made the most sense you
have to keep control of the f4 square
knight to g5 came on the board and now
look at d to e3 but now we're entering a
straight line of calculation which just
simply allows black to get a decisive
advantage and i think this is why nepal
played the move knight to g5
anticipating this trade you have to take
back with the f pawn because you think
with the rule queen takes f3 that's game
over and now queen to f2
if you drop with this rook i'm going to
get the check and then put the pawn on
h3 that's going to paralyze your
position
so f
h3 forever you're you're done
i'm going to go bishop e7 bishop to h4
next and the game should be
clear yeah you cannot kick my queen away
with this rook because that's a
checkmate in one move
so how do you get to my queen i am
threatening to go h3 right yes you have
to play h3 bishop takes a7 sure but once
again i go h3 rook to g1 you have to
defend against checkmate bishop to d6
threatening mate threat after threat
after threat and after e5 take on e5 you
actually cannot take on e5
because you get checkmated again right
queen to f3 i'm not taking your bishop
that's a lovely variation
queen to f3 so we're entering this
straight line and it does seem like
after uh queen to f2 maybe h3 is the
only way out but
what if i start threatening your rook
now development you should show three
seven followed by bishop to
g5 you cannot take on a7 because
european after bishop g5 is resignation
time
so what do you do next it just seems
like right now we're entering a straight
line very easy play for nepo and once my
bishop lands on g5 that's going to come
with more and more threats that you're
just simply not going to be able to
parry this is what i'm seeing right now
if you have to drop to it to allow me to
go queen to f3 and get another pawn the
one on a3 start picking up those pawns
on the queen side this is just too easy
that the king is unsafe you're not able
to create any counter chances as white
it just feels over one of the
gentlemen of the world who could
answer all of our questions is actually
going to join us with us we have a super
grandmaster former world blitz champion
lenier dominguez perez welcome to the
show linear
it has been a confusing round for us we
need you to help us out what is going on
today
yeah well i mean i was a bit surprised
with the game of uh rapport again
against nepo yeah because i think if you
go for this line with white i mean you
understand that it's uh this is a draw
and uh
um
it was a bit uh surprising to me that he
went for this position with 92 and did
you know it did you know it before the
game happened you are yeah
expert
i actually played this line once this
queen be free in a rapid game which
didn't go so well for me but i i was
aware that this is the best line for for
black or at least one of the best lines
and but it's of course if you don't know
that you have to play like this with
black
then it's it's very difficult but uh
clearly nepo knew the line well he
played all these moves uh very quickly
uh he knew bishop h3 of course
and then yeah i think it's of course
white has to repeat moves
but uh yeah to go for this position um
i i i didn't really understand uh why
richard went for this
because it looks i mean not only
uh
the computer gives of course a big
advantage to black but also if you look
from from the human point of view i mean
with such a king
it's uh it's clearly going to be very
easy for black to play and
um
i mean clearly white is going to be
suffering here
lanier first of all good to see you my
friend um is it as surprising for you as
it is for ourselves that we're seeing a
two-horse race exclusively
everybody else is very very very slowly
drifting away
and it's all about the nepo and fabi
show
surprising for you that dingler in or
alireza farouzia a number of other
players haven't won a single game
yeah a bit i mean i was of course i was
thinking before the tournament that uh
fabiano and ding are the the favorites
i was actually thinking that dean might
do well because he's he's been very
consistent of the last few years and
um he he didn't have a great tournament
the last candidates but i thought that
maybe this is the one
where he is
going to play well
and he certainly has the level to to to
win the tournament
so and fabian of course is very
experienced uh he's he's very very
strong so
i thought that uh those two players are
are going to be
the main uh the main favorites which is
not like a super revelation or something
uh but i think yeah from the rest i i i
kind of uh knew that nepo
i mean
from the rest i if i had to beat one to
let's say uh win the tournaments i
thought that nepal could be
maybe maybe one of them because first of
all already he he won once which shows
that he
he has what it takes to to win this
tournament and he's you know when he's
in shape and things are going well for
him he plays very quickly he
he can beat anyone easily and and and
and he can win tournaments so
not really surprising for me but i think
what we have seen in in the candidates
uh
traditionally is that uh the second uh
half of
uh brings some surprises uh normally so
players who are
let's say on the lower part of the table
uh start to win some games against
the people who are at the top and then
the tournament becomes more
interesting so let's hope that uh
there are still some excitement lanier
uh good to see you my friend first of
all uh what do you feel separates these
two players right now jan and fabiano
from the rest of the pack
uh well i think nepo clearly is is in
good shape
and as i was saying when he's in i feel
that when he's in good shape when things
are going
his way he can just be very very strong
as he was already as he showed already
in the last candidate
uh so
this seems to be one of his tournaments
so it's going to be hard to to
um to to fight with him
uh but i think yeah obviously fabiano
because also first of all he's scoring
pretty well in the tournament he seems
to be
playing well he's super well prepared
and very experienced so
um
so far i think those two obviously have
been the most consistent and
um
they seem to be uh
in shape so
uh the rest yeah they all seem to be a
bit uh
off uh of shape for example of erusia is
clearly not uh not playing us at his uh
best level
and uh and the same for for example dude
on rapport you see games like uh the one
today or i think richard was also losing
against uh brett javoff at some point
we chose that he's uh yeah probably not
in in his best shape
um
um yeah uh it's about similar story i
think with the rest of the players it
seems to be the consistency that you
mentioned of these two players now as we
enter the second half of the event the
big question remains how is nepo going
to play in the second half of the event
what is your prediction
yeah i think he'll he'll continue to do
well i mean he might uh might lose some
game of course uh
it can happen to anyone there but uh but
uh i i think that i mean if i had to
predict something i would say that he he
will do well so it
it will be tough to
keep pace with him for fabiano and other
players who might get close
so
um
let's see
okay before we let you go a couple of
things first of all give us your
insights on the current position of fabi
and timor and then you got to tell us
what's next on your schedule uh i i know
you're going to the olympiad right
fabi's just played the move queen d3 how
do you how do you like uh the situation
is extra pawn for white yeah it doesn't
look so easy of course because um
opposite color bishops and black can
hope for some um some simplification and
and some draw which end game but
yeah clearly clearly white is
calling the shots here
so it's winning percentages do you see
it as a two result game
yeah i don't know it's i mean yeah it
seems seems to me that white should be
of course
um
the only the only player pushing here
but uh
but at the same time it doesn't i mean
it doesn't look so so easy to me
it feels like black can just be fine um
if if if white doesn't play
like uh super precise here super please
if i go
uh i don't know i can play knight b4
knight to d4 b4 knight to b4 i apologize
for your take on d8 and um
i check first right
maybe queen g freo queen g3 check first
and i i'm guessing they can't
king
get out of the way
get out of the way uh yeah well
the trader
d8
yes max mac
maybe a3 or something right to play
knight d5 to play knight d5
uh good stuff and again back to you uh
lanier uh tell us what's uh
what's coming up for you
uh so i'm going to play the olympiad as
you mentioned but first
i'm going to play
an online event
part of the
magnus tour
starting on july 10
and then um and then after that i'll
play the the granches tour in sagra the
wrapping plates
and then i'll go from there to to india
to
to play the olympia so
three tournaments in a row now nice so
you've got a busy summer coming up now
linear before we let you uh go now talk
to us about this decision of richie to
continue the game at that point in which
he got surprised in the opening he knew
that but he spent an hour and decided to
shy away from the repetition have you
ever been in in those type of situations
and what is usually your thought process
yeah i mean i don't know it
in fact i would be curious to see what
was his uh thinking because i i don't
think he was surprised i mean he played
all these moves quickly and when you
when you do that it's clear that you
looked at this position
and you know what's the what's the
objective evaluation so
um i don't know if if he let's say just
didn't want to make it wrong
or if he thought that the position with
the with the two rooks for the queen
although he knew that the computer
estimates uh the position to be better
for black maybe he thought that
practically is is
is interesting for white maybe it's not
that easy
um that white can play it simply with
the two rooks
but uh but i don't think he was
surprised i mean i think he knew all
this because if you play this line with
white uh um you you're supposed to know
and i think he knew and he played all
those moves quickly
so yeah i don't know i think he just
thought that the position it's it's any
way interesting for white that he might
be worse objectively but he maybe liked
his chances or something with with the
two rooks
but yeah again for me it's uh it's not
so so easy to to understand why he
do you feel maybe it was a bit of a
frustration that he drew all his games
up to this point he's not used to
drawing so many games
any of that
it could be yeah it could could be but
uh but again if you let's say if you
feel the need to just
play and and not make it raw then you
might choose a different line
because if you choose this it's clearly
very uh concrete line just move per move
uh either you
are better or it's it's
or or you have to to make a draw so
if you go for this line then it seemed
to me that the the strategy was just to
test nabo if he if he plays the correct
uh line the correct moves
uh but yeah just to to go to go like
this it seems to me that uh the only uh
justification is that he he
he somehow
uh thought that the position is still
still interesting for white after after
this queen takes a freight and stuff
linear we just want to say thank you so
very much for taking time out of your
day uh and joining us it was delight to
have you on the show and uh get your
insights
very very good luck in the future
thank you great to see you guys thank
you lanier great to have you on board
and of course he's going to be joining
the grand chester in zagreb and that
airplane from zagreb to india
it's gonna have a couple grand masters
in it yeah you're gonna have to look if
somebody goes down
he's the new number one uh i wanted to
say that the position that richard and
jan have
achieved
is a fantastic indication
of
how the two rooks are suffering oh yes
so the two rooks tied to one another but
they're not on an open file
in fact
these rooks are really really clumsy
they they're they're stuck together
uh they can hardly move and in the
meanwhile as soon as black plays the
move bishop g5 you can see it's white
king that is going to come under you
know a very very serious assault
uh we'll just make a move on the board
uh we actually received this position
achieved this position actually earlier
and christian was the first one to point
out god bless him
that you know you could just take a pawn
you could just take a pawn but and ask
white what the heck are you doing but
you could you could also even i think
take the h3 pawn by force right can you
i think you play bishop f4 you can oh
that's nasty
bishop f4 as well pick up the action you
pick up the h-bomb by force and then you
start rolling
well what a majority that would be check
uh if you're trying to avoid or what
have you there's no way
you don't even have root g2
because
the rook on e1 is uh
is hanging you do have rook g2 in that
instance but then you give me another
check this one is completely over brutal
uh yeah i would take the a pawn i like
it i like the fact that i have the
bishop sorry i take the h-pawn and the
a-pawn by force you do
you you take on h3 with check and then
you and then you take a3 this is over
yeah yes yeah
wow
again uh lanier well i mean he was
yeah fabie's better but it's a hard slog
it's not easy that we were perhaps
either exaggerating his advantage or
perhaps he missed a chance with the last
couple of moves hard to say the
variations we were looking at with the
move knight before and knight before to
me looks very logical you want to get
this active rook of yeah five out of ten
yeah well exactly right right and i i
think this line is more or less forced
you take on d8 either before or after
queen g3 check yeah and here was my
question should i take or should i draw
back
should i stare should i go should i stay
or should i go right i was thinking if i
dropped back i mean i'm not developing
your rook i mean i'm inviting you to
develop my rope before
how do we feel about our chances after
developing rook h e8 for example
to give some loft yes i
i was desperately you know reaching for
some kind of a lift but yes
h2h3
and let's let's hop around a bit maybe
actually you know the roof rookie maybe
wasn't that good but i wanted to play
something like knight c2 yes knight d4
yes
hoppery hop attack some stuff but okay
your knight was here
some time ago if you had wanted a
hippity hop you could have got i could
have gotten there but i did get rid of
your rook on d5 it's now behind the
knight which is very nice for me because
i now the d5 square is the idle
square that's very for for mine i do
understand of course the highly
desirable rook d
knight d5 will be
awkward for me to meet but
uh one day i will prep uh knight to d5
whether it's uh by moving my queen but
all right i do like
fabi's chances i think they're
very good in fact
um and we did see the move queen before
by timor interesting queen d3 queen b4
on the board well it immediately puts a
question right queen takes b2 actually
is a winning threat so you need to
defend from this somehow
b3 i guess bishop b3
logical move um i was also
you know i don't get that about myself
but uh i'm this i'm so provocative but
sometimes you know it's like
the moment you make your threat i go i
don't believe you not one single bit you
know go ahead execute your threat i'm
going to play knight e4 if you go queen
b 2 ha ha ha
i'm gonna kill you you shouldn't have
done
and then
i missed something and it's like oh i'm
sorry well you gotta show what you
missed night before
uh no no night before here but i think
earlier 95 was winning for black unless
i'm missing something oh probably uh
missing a question
so queen b4 has a dual purpose action
yeah right and that's that's serious
that's pretty serious so my 94 would be
uh embarrassed the work on d8 is
currently defended by the bishop yes six
yes it is and you're pinned so you
cannot take on e5 it's also
this
defended
everything is wrong yeah yeah so bishop
bishop b3 bishop b3 looks as we would
say box or
forced
and um
knight a5s you know this bishop on f6 is
actually pretty
good yeah all things considered
let's let's call that an all-star bishop
it does defend d8 it does hit c3
maybe knight a5 is the way
i'd like to take that big definitely
yeah it's like it's a good bishop if i
could
okay maybe lanier was right that uh we
didn't
look at this mcqueen before i actually
liked this move queen before a lot yeah
we're warming up so i'm really warming
up to this move it finally creates a
threat and the moment that you put white
on the back foot the pawn doesn't matter
that much just yet it's something that's
a very long-term pawn yeah it's not a
pawn that's really crushing any of
black's pieces yep
i get it i get it um i just want to
christian
please the sadness of white's position
the sadness of ritchie rapport's place
h3 bishop e7 was played and now he had
to play the move bishop to h2 followed
by bishop to g1
it's just such a sad position queen d2
is going to come he's completely busted
at this point quintessence
pick up
queen to c2 to pick up the pawn on c4
that's one way
to queen to d3 that's another way
this is just completely over but it's
just such a sad situation in which you
simply don't have any moves and you know
what's coming there's going to be a
threat on the third rank your rook is
going to get kicked off the third rank
and then it's just going to be game over
resignation time so
this is what we're seeing right now
queen to d2 by the way is on the board
rook 2 e2 is what the computer is saying
but after queen to d4 you still have to
move this look i'm still picking up the
c4 pawn
with
it's just a set it's funny that you
allow rick g3 right but it's
embarrassing that g2 oh c4 saying um
winning you know winning with black in
first place
gosh i mean
cruising in the petrol it's in a petrov
that you know you got in your prep and
you're forcing the draw
wow awesome you're in first place black
against rapport you force the draw
everything's going swimmingly until the
rapper refuses that rockport's like no
no how about a full point yeah yeah yeah
much better
isn't it uh queen
the queen is dominating uh
nepo is just like
he's gonna come to the press conference
and he's gonna say
i apologize but everybody's giving me
points i mean i feel like it's christmas
and uh
i'm i'm getting every everything on my
wish list in some ways right because i i
a couple of games that i can think of
they forced nepo to do his business like
here richard's like
show me your prep okay says here's my
prep and then richard says uh i don't
believe it very strange stuff similarly
with alireza laressa brings his prep to
nepal says this is my sharperation of
the night
but doesn't understand the position
right
king b1
very useful move
and i i looked i looked back at the at
that opening
after the game was over and i saw that
qb1 is actually not in the top engine
moves
and it might have discombobulated
alireza but then that's where your
understanding has to kick in right right
like understanding of the position but
nepo clearly knew where the ball was
rolling well and and that's one of those
cases where the engine can be a fiend
[Music]
because i think a lot of players would
say okay
uh king b1 is not the engine's top
choice but as a human being
you oftentimes want to
cut
tuck your king away on the queen side
when you're castled long so
a poor
poor prep in that case but everything
everything is gone uh in nepal's way we
do have rook on d3
to e2 we're expecting to move queen ef
queen queen to d3
hitting this one with check how do you
not play this one
and if richie were to resign
it would not be a surprise uh this
position is simply
gone
how gone is it like bishop to e3 what
what do you do i was thinking about
bishop e3 and you know you know what was
funny i was actually wondering if you're
an actual zugzwang after just moving my
bishop away it's because if you move
your bishop you lose your h3 pawn
if you move your over if you move for
your rook i go queen e4 and then bishop
c3 right
i mean how bad is it well it's so bad
that i don't even want to take a pawn
with check yeah
i think i think that's how bad i mean
you could take on e4 i just don't know
why yeah with check i just don't know if
i want to yeah i picked that the engine
is minus
5.2 did you say
our producer tom was so excited the
moment you told him a word that he's
familiar with yeah no we said
zwishenzuk
[Laughter]
it's the language of chat but we still
got those and if you're not familiar
with some of them well loft flight
squared the check and we got our
i'm really surprised that tom hasn't
uh understood the term checkmate
the term checkmate so i as a sports fan
love the fact that there are touchdowns
and home runs and goals
in international sports so here i am
this chess grand master i travel the
world people ask me what do you try to
do in your life and i say give
checkmate
that's just lame thing if i said
i score touchdowns that i would be
hailed i give checkmate where does it
come from where does the term
checkmate come from well from the game
of chaturunga
the game went to persia
modern-day iran
and in iran they have the king who is a
shah
and when the persians played chess with
one another and they put the
the king the shah under the attack they
would say
shah like hey dude watch out shah you're
and
when the king was destroyed it was
shah mat
the king is dead shah mat
and from the word shah we get check
check to the king
and shah mat became checkmate so there's
the history
of
the word checkmate because i always felt
robbed give me a touchdown
what the heck is a checkmate and then i
kind of appreciated shah mat
did you like it more i liked it more
when i learned the the root of the word
how it evolved
well yeah i mean you never see a chick
tom makes a compelling point last time
we saw an actual trackmate on this it's
been a while
right
those grand masters they're so fast they
resign before they get checkmated we do
have bishop e3 on the board and we do
have bishop f6
which uh that's really rubbing salt into
the wound right
richie go ahead to make a move he he has
two minutes to make his last move
it's not it's not a pretty sight because
there's no moves in the position or you
can see three or you can resign that's
also yeah that's also legal bishop c3 is
being threatened you've mentioned
well what's wrong with grabbing pawns
queenie for check is on queen c4 the
only problem with grabbing pawns is that
you almost have to choose and as i was
saying that i realized not really you
can pick all of them
one
and the other yeah
it's so bad it's so bad uh what's
happening in the other games uh
christian
we kind of
lost sight not
number one versus number two not as much
so uh the one between dingley wren and
ali rezab
this one has fizzled out a lot of things
have been exchanged and it does seem
like it's headed towards the draw not
much is happening in this one no problem
on on on the time for either player
hikaru versus uh yanshi staff duda a lot
of things have changed also after b4
bishop to a4 came on the board quite a
precise move making sure that these
pawns are not going anywhere because if
you do allow the move a4 for white then
you're probably going to get uh in big
trouble so you have to play the move
bishop to a4 rook to d2 and now queen to
c6 inviting the queen trade which will
ease some tension regarding your king's
position of course if we get the queens
off the board h5 or anything of that
nature doesn't come with as much impact
against the black king so i like this
move queen to c6 if you try to avoid it
i don't actually see how you can do that
right so you can go queen to b2 the
problem is that right now at least i
have control of the c file and i can
redirect my bishop to the uh square c4 a
much better square from c4 not only that
i will be defending the pawn on d5 but
also i'm controlling the knight quite
well any sort of knight jumps knight to
d3 knight to e5 which once again if ma
if white manages to get there the game
is pretty much over from a strategical
point of view so you have to stop white
at all costs from going 93 95 bishop to
b5 makes a lot of sense get a bishop to
c4 it does seem like black managed to
stabilize the position with the last few
moves this move b4 allowing bishop to a4
and queen to c6 was perhaps not the most
precise way forward for white and what
about queen c5 25 is a move as well yes
four white uh then queen b2 25 is a
little bit passive
i agree i completely agree and now the
same thing is most likely going to
happen i don't think you can take on a7
i know no no no no no no that's too
dangerous
but in that position after queen c5
bishop b5 could i play a move like
i don't know f3 or f3 really or king g2
rook to e1 we trade
and then c1 right oh you've got queen e8
c1 is a nice one yes okay i also have
rook f1 yeah
guys let's just do the nipple game
because it does seem like he's just
simply he's about to win this is pretty
much over he took on a7 on the 40th move
allowing queen h3 king g1 queen g3 the h
pawn is still coming he's going to be
joined by the bishop as well i think
this is just over i think i can also
just pick up the one of the rooks right
yeah
so here the king is one king one right i
was thinking king f1
bishop c3 i actually don't think it
matters right i go bishop c3 anyway so
again you're getting with a check you
can go bishop c3 bishop c3
disrupting the coordination of the rooks
where am i going so bishop c3 maybe
rookie three might be uh okay
right and just pick up e1
that's convincing absolutely convincing
bishop c3 makes a lot of sense as well
and if i have to move my rook then i'm
walking into queen f3 and i hear you
have to choose between giving me queen
h1
or immediately giving me the rook on
hopson choice and it's not a goodie yeah
i have to drop my bishop back but no
this is terrible this is absolutely
absolutely terrible
and
i have to say for richard
you know the six draws yeah it's pretty
sad that you know i haven't been able to
win a game but on the other hand i
haven't lost a loss for richie and
that's what we're predicting
uh that ends his tournament
he's not
yeah he's made next week
we even thought that before today's
round he already had drawn his way out
of the tournament and a loss here just
really really seals the deal exactly we
think that this game coupled with a
potential win by fabiano will actually
end the tournament for everybody else by
the two of them
two favorites
somehow something it's a win it all
event and if you're like two and a half
points away or like two points away from
tying with the first place with only
seven games left that's pretty much
impossible at this level
right
and i'm looking at this position too by
the way uh
h3 i know you're bishop c3 that's really
really good
too much about it
he's coming dang
i mean
that's awesome that is really a powerful
move and once again it's just the
sadness of this whole position for white
there's nothing you can touch you you
have to go bishop it's so dominating g1
is is that the only move it's the only
one
so you've got to stop being h2
and maybe now i play bishop c3 with
stronger
with a stronger feel right yeah
evil intentions yes i mean it's so bad
uh and now you don't after bishop c3 you
don't even have uh
ideas three three because of queen to g2
mate oh yeah
yeah
that's a visual
oh my goodness oh my gosh
yeah once again this is just cut the
suffering get out yeah yeah the this is
the vulture scenario if this game is
played on the first second third board
in a major open like everybody
collectively stands up and then they
come to your board you're like go away
everybody as bishop to g1 uh it's not a
move chicks are getting flush exactly
exactly
[Laughter]
run out of there get out of here get out
of here uh and for napo oh my gosh it
just
man the birds are singing
it's a warm summer's day outside it's
all good for nepal fans as he is just in
cruise control
hikaru uh
queen c6 and this is where
uh duda who
by the way is
in the same shoes as richard minus one
no wins minus one wins out of the
tournament exactly and he's looking at
this game and he's thinking to himself
i
i've got to win i've got to win uh
if
is queen c5 uh could
we we mentioned how how did our line go
i was trying to get f3 queen c5 bishop
b5
f3 rookie one rook e one check came yeah
and then we stopped like white
specifically we stopped liking white's
position and maybe
that was unfair of us or
was it king g2
i mean i could go queen eight and give
up d5 you give up on with chuck i
understand but
you are
the king is a little slow oh yeah yeah
right true true i just wish i had a good
square foot i put a knight whatever h8
yeah for now okay uh i don't know if i'm
afraid of queen e3
and or not
i just want to get
out of uh
the way of your bishop coming to c6 i
want to go d5 i feel i already have
immediately a draw immediately a draw
with rook g1
oh man
i think where's the worst case scenario
oh maybe it's better that means more
than a drop
yeah yeah just like one of my
evaluations it keeps climbing right
our resignation is imminent let's go
back and go back bishop to g1 was indeed
played and not bishop to c
but bishop to h4
now the threat is obvious check queen to
f3 check followed by bishop takes f2e if
you put the rook in front of it queen to
g to the game is over clear what do you
do if rook to f2 comes on the two queen
d3
h2 h2
you have two rooks that you cannot
defend at the same time if you take with
the rook queen takes you one if you take
with the bishop queen takes f2
mate it's
i
i think you can feel the frustration of
richard just by looking at the moves and
that he hasn't resigned
yes
that's a good point
this is this is so dead lost and been so
dead lost that i think in a normal
tournament on a normal day he just kind
of shakes off his head and said okay
let's get out of here yeah
this is beating himself right now
he's thinking not about the current
position in front of him he's thinking
and we do have officially a result and
our congratulations
currently
he is a point and a half we said at the
start of the tournament dude you want to
win this tournament get plus four
plus three we've said
that's at least a tie and another fight
but if you want you know straight up yes
just give me the first guys look at the
time look at nepal's time
he's he has two hours
he finished
this game with more than two hours on
his clock
what how does he do that there's no
increment 40 40 moves and he added
another extra hour oh of course
and he only said
40 already of course he spent less than
an hour he played this entire game in 60
minutes wow
it was most of it was prep but
look at these magic numbers he's getting
close the magic number of course is what
we think
we thought before nine
nine would win
the tournament eight and a half clinch
has a tie if not clear first
and he's got five and a half with an
entire half
in front of him he's going to need just
to score three points out of the
remaining seven rounds which is
a terrible minus one
to get to his magic number and for fabi
fabi's got to be the one who's gonna
give him that big fat zero it's the only
one and remember that they face each
other in round nine this is the current
standings with fabiano still playing so
the tournament's not yet over because
otherwise i mean it's just done that's
the current standings uh richard rapport
and janet poncho of course have already
finished their game uh jan on
scintillating five and a half points
out of
seven outstanding outstanding i mean it
really is half a point out of top of six
and at that point when toppolo did it we
were just saying why why are you
bothering with the second half right it
was what a shock uh result that was for
vessel and as he went on to become world
champs champion um i'm having this in
interesting feelings of deja vu it was a
u.s championship where
two players were type first and fabi
scored two and a half out of three in
the remaining games and he thought well
you know somebody give me check for
first
one sam shanklin went three out of three
and said no i'll take clear first
fabby sitting there patting him on
himself on the back
saying i've had a great tournament i
remember that fabi congratulations on
your clear second
score plus five in that tournament he
thought
that should be good enough
not that year and
uh let's jump to the social media and
invite you to join our conversation all
right from youtube user
smwg i guess right do you think that
napa potentially winning the tournament
makes it more likely for magnus to
withdraw from the match
i'll put it succinctly yes
yes if if there was one person
that i think
magnus says i don't really have to play
him again it was such a crushing
performance this is where i give it up
yeah and on the other hand should fabby
win he might say like okay i won against
you but yeah i did it in a tie break
you were
a hell of a competitor
you get a rematch i'll give you a
rematch right i can imagine that but
nepo well i mean
i can
[Music]
it was such destruction yeah magnus
isn't then they're gonna say do i need
to do this again
but on the other hand
you know
what's wrong two million dollar two
million euros
let's uh let let's go
christian join in on the fray no
absolutely i do think uh that if nepal
wins it there's just simply not going to
be a huge incentive for magnus to play
this one and nobody will question the
fact that if they do play magnus will
have a huge advantage and huge potential
to win that match against fabiano
there's some questions right there's
some questions still remaining he hasn't
won a single classical game against him
in their 2018 match so there's still
some unanswered questions dilemmas right
against nepo not so much and that's
where i think
his idea of just quitting uh this match
and giving it away giving uh his title
away will come into play love those
questions from the social media we're on
a roll we got another one let's see
aleandro let's take a look this one is
from youtube user kevin
why is e4 so much more popular than d4
in the candidates and why is e45 more
popular than e4 c5
d4 and sicilian player in shambles
well that's an excellent question it
sure is and the vagaries of fashion uh
yeah but i do think that we haven't seen
we have seen more e-force there's no
doubt about that right we do have a few
sicilians we have seen richard
specifically fabi's game today favi's
game today i can think of a couple of d4
games we have duda today we have dingler
and i understand that we have had more
e4s right and currently there is this
fashion sense of the berlin stash
italian
permeating in the top levels of the
chess field true but i don't feel maybe
i'm wrong i need to look at the numbers
but i don't feel it's so lopsided do you
it seems to me that over the course of
the last 10 years e4 e5 became far more
popular than e4 c5 if you go back in the
1990s everybody played sicilians and e5
was and i remember the eco books okay
the encyclopedia of chess opening so you
have this five volume set
volume
and they kept repeating so like now i
got like 15 volumes or something and i
remember the e4 e5 eco code
was thick
wow there was so much uh that had been
codified of e4 e5 e5 was the go-to
defense
if you go back in the world championship
matches from ages and ages ago everybody
thought you got to neutralize one e4
with e5 and that was where everybody
went and karpa for example when he was
black
always played for the rui lopez or the
um petrov as well the russian defense
and that e4 e5 uh and i will also say
that fashion plays an enormous role i
mean it does berlin take a look at the
2018 world championship right and that
one it was the sicilian that magnus
brought to the fray so this fishnet this
fashion curve no problems there he said
and no problems did he have in the match
right he got tested on this new cool
knight d5 that we ended up preparing
right the a4s and b4
and it was crazy and it was fun right
but magnus himself just out of fashion
perhaps based on who he was playing
returned to e4 e5 in the next match
exactly which he did play with great
success
against nepo also in that match what was
intriguing about
the match
with fabi
is
magnus obviously done a great deal of
work in this fashion of cough and
fabi couldn't crack him
but
magnus continued to play this fashion of
cough and win
game after game after game and you just
suddenly fought yourself oh my god baby
did really well by drawing things i
remember i remember a game that he
played very shortly after the match he
played against sergey karjakin with the
black pieces yes the game finishes with
sergey having an extra pawn right and a
completely
maybe it's king
it's true it's true
yeah don't don't don't be afraid of
playing your openings uh you you'll see
more of them it just happens sometimes
but
you'll see more d4s you'll see more
sicilians i don't think that
i don't think they're currently as
represented as you would have thought
but not that underrepresented either
christian jump right in uh
i think you guys covered it all also uh
by it seems like uh e4 just uh is uh
more engaging because the berlin is
beaten at least in this tournament
there's no berlin to worry about so
that's they put it that way
that's a good starting point uh for the
e4 lovers now let's talk about these end
game a little bit because this is the
most consequential game of the rock
remaining the one between fabiano and
timur rajabov because we have this
position right now this end game was
reached quite quickly bishop to d3
knight to c6 and now we have a bishop
coming to e4 now we see the presence of
the opposite color bishops
how easy and how big of an advantage
does white have
with the extra pawn on f5 is it as big
as we think it is or does black have
good chances to equalize and draw this
game um
i'm still uh it was funny because when
we left it we've played we've seen favi
play the move bishop to d3 to c4 and
the next thing i'm looking and thinking
to myself how did the bishop get to e4
and
there's a little bit of a dance going on
um
i feels
better but it's not not easy
no i'm with playing here on this one
play for two results but you do feel as
black that
you if you play well enough you should
be able to draw this one yeah this rook
on cda very very nicely positioned
there's no targets
really to speak about as far in black's
positions concerned well d7 might be a
problem next move right if you don't do
anything because 95 doesn't work that
uh-huh we see the bish pony for what it
was what his job is exactly so maybe
rook to
e8 uh tickling the bishop maybe and uh
angling for a bishop c3 and now f3
right and now you have to defend the
bishop for somehow
and now maybe
do we defend
the seventh rank or do we go knight t5
try to redirect that knight to c4
i kind of like that i like i like 95
knights e4s i mean this dark square
bishop again it's it's a real hero it's
keeping
uh black's position glued together it
feels good
what white needs to do right now is
stabilize the position somehow how do we
stabilize the position well you did well
with the f2 f3 you stabilize the bishop
is coming that's the problem so how do
you defend against a knight c4 without
losing a pawn rook to b1 is that you're
going to have to subscribe to the saint
louis chess club service
christian and then our operators are
standing by
it's 199 a minute
and we will answer
i don't know i don't know how you're
gonna get an advantage against knight c4
or that's a that's a nasty point i think
that rajabov has chances we are going to
take a short break
wait what is this this is not live
what's going on
it's a it was a good dance we
we got one right it happens once once
every broadcast exactly we get one right
we're gonna take a short break we'll be
uh looking out for these games we are
arriving in time pressure for some of
these players as for example fabiano's
only on move 24. and we've just we're
just we're gonna give the laurels to
napo i mean it's just been a
two-horse show on horsham maybe maybe
maybe we'll see on the other side of a
break don't go anywhere
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are in round
seven of the candidates in madrid and
you can see one man is very happy about
this results no question about it is uh
jan has won
the game uh three games pending but
richie
loses his first game of the tournament
in
really horrible style richie was white
played some preparation that jan had all
the answers for and it should have been
a perpetual check but no richie forced
the action alejandro and regrets it and
we were talking to about this to linear
dominguez who joined this on air super
grandmaster and we were all confused and
he was no exception he knew linear that
is that this was a draw he had already
played it before he analyzed the
variation
he had a good idea he had jan
had his preparation and it's like it's
one of those things that lanier said hey
look i play this line
and if you don't know the line you lose
if you know the line it's a draw
and i get that so uh we you you test uh
nepo
nepo uh passed the test
and then richie for reasons we just
cannot fathom
forced the game to continue and
well he he lost badly badly and
in
whatever confusion that he hurt himself
in nepal takes full advantage he
certainly does and you saw the standings
yep and it's really up to favi to
determine whether this tournament
keeps having some intrigue
or not
and speaking of fabi's game we do have a
this position with timor when we left it
we actually left it at this point rookie
8 tickling the bishop on e4 fortifying
the bishop with the move f2 f3 here we
sort of said well do you play 95 with
the idea of knight c4 or do you just
cover the second
seventh rank pardon me with the move
rookie seven timor chose the latter and
after rook d1 h7 h6 again nothing really
has changed
the extra pawn for white is firmly in
his pocket
um but black is basically saying hey
look uh a lot of things have changed oh
well please a lot of things have changed
because uh timor actually missed a bit
and unfortunately for him right now is
in tremendous danger
so after in this position he played the
move rook to e7 this is the bit that he
missed he was supposed to go knight to
e5 the line that we discussed right
tonight as soon as possible to c4 put
some pressure on the pawn structure on
the queen side specifically this
stabilizing pawn on b2 because without
the pawn on b2 the knight on c3 is going
to be very feeble so now after knight to
e5 unfortunately it doesn't seem like
white has to play something like rook to
b1 or rook to e1 but this allows black
to gain quite a nice initiative on the
queen side knight to c4 rook to d7 i
always defend that with rook to e7
and not only that my knight gets in a
better position but also the bishop gets
in a much better position right now
forcing the king almost to go to h1 if
you don't want to allow any sort of
checks it does feel like black is
getting some sort of counter chances
right right and this is exactly what he
wants unfortunately for him he played
the move rook to e7 and this allowed
white to go rook d1
and knight to e5 at this point is no
longer possible because if you do go
knight to e5 i have this extra option
rook to d8 creating some serious danger
in your position not only because we
exchanged uh this a pair of rooks but
also because i'm vacating the d5 square
and my knight is ready to jump there
knight to d5 is going to come huge
difference compared to what we could
have had with the move knight to e5 this
is exactly what we're seeing right now
h6 he had to play
now just simply king to f2
slowly but surely i'm going to improve
all of my pieces and
get an attack going with my pawns try to
destabilize position g4 king g3 h4 king
f4 g5 that's the plan in the position it
doesn't seem like black has
a lot of things to do but wait so right
now it does seem like fabiano is in
prime position to potentially keep pace
with jan nepal
well thank you
for clarifying it hadn't been
intuitively obvious to me that those
last few moves were so much in white's
favor but they clearly are they clearly
are this knight is not getting to the c4
square and causing issues
then the problem is white really does
stabilize and one day he will be able to
use his king side majority so
uh a big advantage actually absolutely
and speaking of clarification i think
that we are going to clarify one of the
games very quickly okay
and hikaru nakamura have liquidated into
an end game they've been blitzing
and this looks like a dead draw to me i
think you were gonna exchange some pawns
and three versus three we left it
somewhere around these parts queen c5
and there was a trade of rooks
right here is actually a big issue he
ended up capturing with the b-pawn
capturing with the d-pawn you're
eyeballing knight takes d5 i understand
that with my king on g2 bishop on c6 is
not play on one goal
he took
bishop and right about here i thought
that actually icaru
because hikaru's taking the base pawn on
d4
was for choice but we were discussing it
and you were pointing out that rook e7
should just be a draw
and they went right down that
alleyway
of liquidating and we're up to date with
the players now and that means the
closest competitor outside of fabiano
caruana is two points away from young
exactly no matter what happens
he's clear third
yes yeah i would never have guessed that
either right that that's shocking to me
but it just goes to show that
so many play points have been given up
to the top two sorry christians the top
two are stealing all the points yes
yeah and they you know have you ever
seen those easter egg hunt kind of
cartoons where like two kids have their
basket full and like six kids are crying
like we
don't have any easter eggs in our basket
that's what this looks like as two
players are just running away with the
tournament and rook takes c6 rook takes
a3
again this massive kind of liquidation
and it doesn't seem like dingley ran
versus ali reza is going anywhere let's
uh check in on that one
um
it's like two people can win in madrid
and that's it right nobody else that's
it uh the tournament is almost over for
everybody else
wow
and we're in a four versus four or rook
and knight versus rook at night these
two players who have things so much
difficulties against the field suddenly
put together the most solid game
against one another when both of them
need a win so desperately need a win
and they play super solid chess and how
is this going to impact
the performers of everybody else
because this is a 14 round event very
long right very gruesome event right
right you have to keep your preparation
going and sharp every single day yeah if
you know that you have no chance of
catching up with leaders do you still
prepare four five six hours uh the day
before do you still ask your seconds to
spend that amount of time what's the
strategy right i think you do and i
think that some players you will
actually see an increase in their
quality of play and if i had to think of
one of them they're relief they're
relieved yeah who won the second half of
the candidates
2021 ding ding
yes he had such a bad start he actually
had a decent finish he had a very good
finish here he was the only one that i
think no no on a plus two score in the
speed
beating nepo to finish the tournament
right right why because it didn't matter
anymore right he was out of it he was
out and he could just play easily
without the fear and scare of losing
hikaru has officially drawn his game
against john shisht of duda we did
expect the vacuum cleaner to come and
that's what happened that's what
happened all the pawns were vacuumed so
that was the end of the game
spells disaster for john schuster's
duda's chances of winning this
tournament hikaru's i mean when you're
in third you don't think that you're far
away but right you are yeah we're two
two points
well
i mean again hindsight is 2020 but
hikaru did have a chance
against nepo
uh if he had
uh taken advantage of the opportunity
that he had coming out of the opening he
could have it would be a different
tournament it would have been wide open
uh but a draw nonetheless for hikaru
keeps him at 50 and let's just take
another look at our standings with two
games in the history books alejandro
that's right uh with this draw between
yasiris of duda and hikaru nakamura you
can see that hikaru is now clearly in
third place
uh that's not gonna change unless
dingler and somehow manages a miracle
from that drawn end game
and
it's just too many points the tournament
is long yes it's 14 rounds yes but we
already played half of it and nobody's
making points except for the top two
guys
victories it really it really would be a
total collapse for one of the field to
to win this right yeah
it's not only that it it's not about
nepo losing two games but also whoever
catches him has to win a lot of games
right five that's the problem and wins
don't come easily no in this tournament
unless you're young or fabio
right but guys uh something changed in
the position okay
king 2f2 was played rook c7
and now instead of rook to d3
he played the move rook to d2 and he
allowed bishop takes c3 followed by
knight to e5
how do we think about this trade and how
do we think about black's chances to
potentially equalize the position you
know because now it's visually at least
to my eyes it looks better for black
than it used to be well the split pause
something to look forward to on the
other hand i'm not worried anymore about
the opposite color bishops
true
but uh wait a minute uh there's bishop
on e4 versus the knight
whoa f7 f6 that's a little moves are
coming fast because the players are
actually in some sort of a weird time
trouble situation six minutes for a
timura job of 7 minutes and 30 seconds
for
fabiano but still 11 moves to go
so they do have some moves to go they're
trying to speed things up
but i don't think they're doing the uh
they're doing that uh with precision i
have f6 i have decent eyesight but i
have no understanding why did it jump
from 0.5 that's a very good question
plus 2.2 that is a very very good one
i didn't realize that i was just looking
at i was trying to calculate
you know the position after knight c4
and knight g4 it seems like knight g4
actually was a good move and putting the
knight on the knight to f6 right
create some tension against the bishop
on e4 after the f6 it seems like this
bishop on e4
is going to live there forever and
that's how you have knight again there
was no knight knight f6 no more knight
f6 but put the pawn on f6 for just a
moment and
the other thing that i really didn't
like about the move f6 is i get to play
king g6 one day that's very true right
like what
why are you giving the weakness exactly
yeah and uh not that f3 f4 in the
current situation any trade of the rules
right now seems to be detrimental to
black's position because of this idea of
f4 and get the king quick to get right
yeah so fabi's chances just took a
huge boost
with the move f7 f6 absolutely i didn't
expect it to be that bad but you guys
are making very compelling points on why
the move f6 is a strong inaccuracy yeah
it's it's uh
an easy easy point to miss but this
uh captures on c3 splitting the pawns
and if
timor had brought his knight back to f6
as um
christian was saying making tension
against the bishop then it's kind of
easy for black black's moves of
rook c5 and
rook on e7 to c7 rather easy to play the
counter play kind of plays itself the
monster split you attack the pawns that
are weak exactly and it's this bishop on
e4 that
it keeps white's position together right
it cuts out the rooks in many ways it
forces the rook to passivity because of
the pawn on b7 right once you
destabilize the bishop it becomes easier
for the rooks exactly the rooks on e1
especially
its vistas are open but after f6 king g3
king a7
we reckon
that
white can white can
get a free hand
maybe uh squeezing his uh king up to h5
rook to d4 okay
that's an indication that i might be
trying to get my pawn to c5 he's putting
some pressure on
him it's also a good move right then
rook sits very pretty on d4 true that
but okay i
i
i'm not going to be watching you just
build up build up build up rook c5 and
that's
played
quickly and he has to play quickly right
yeah he has only four minutes left for
nine moves still that's a lot of moves
yeah but there's also down on time he's
six minutes and 30 seconds at the moment
so both players feeling
feeling the pressure the ticking clock
rook c5 on the board go ahead alejandro
when do we start when do we start saying
about my pawns on that side i'm just
going to go try to queen mine right
king h4 let's do it let's have a
look-see king h4
now again played by the way
i mean f4 is coming
king a4 and rookie c7 played and i think
the question is what if you just go
keep going up yeah at the moment it
seems a little bit uh weird that we're
uh but
no tricks no tricks and
on white's agenda can i go g6
the thing about g6 is that i'm not i'm
not actually forced to take this pawn
you can take on h6 i can take on h6 and
i think my song is pretty safe f5 you
take back i would assume
right yeah and it looks a bit scary but
don't i have knight f7 wait a minute
natasha king g6 knight h8
christian
i've been doing
[Laughter]
oh the tactics
see chess is a young man's game i i
gotta tell you um
okay rook c7
king h5 okay but you guys scared me a
little bit right right h5 on the board
so favi sees more than us let's try to
understand king h5 on the board if g6
why couldn't i take this pawn first of
all you guys you guys like well we we
were we weren't trying to trick you yeah
we never have rook d5 is the problem
that jeeps came over right have a g-spot
jesus i didn't
[Laughter]
with knight d3 though right so go back
one move
go knight to d3 instead of knight to f3
wow
i take
now you're right that's a whole rook
that this pawn has got an escort a role
i i might even consider trading the
rooks can i do that instead of taking
directly on h6 code rogue d5 just the
same performance
simplify the position when you have a
pass pawn and you want to get uh rid of
the uh
the defenders that's his deadlock and by
the way b5 is on the board
so he's fine he's going to create his
own counter chances on the queen side
king b6 probably is going to be followed
but how do we break right now do we go
f4
well is it finally time to go f4 that's
the standard thing you got to get rid of
this knight so we can plant the king and
if you say when i would think this is
the time
so
f4 played
f4 was played now knight to d7 i think
you have to go knight d7 so that on king
g6 you have knight affinity
and just uh kicking me back
but if i attack the knight
exactly
why don't i start with rook to d1 yeah
rig d1 is where i would start
and the knight has no but then
you have some problems and you're
getting made it
yeah i was going to play rook c8 but
yeah i understand i understand um
the knight is just actually running out
of squares yeah that's the problem b6
but then i mean you're not holding the
king's side together uh
okay if i go in the other direction
i am allowing you to cozy up to my g
pawn
king g6 and i don't know where your
knight is going it's
a very pretty night but it's in the way
it's in the way of my rooks right you
want to play b4 and take advantage of
the pin you want to take on c3 directly
and the the knights you can even start
with rook d1 try to go rook d7 right
whether you play king g6 or rook d1 well
rook t1 might actually encourage you
three i think ah knight beat two and
knight a4 okay i was trying to take this
guy with the tempo
but still rook d2 knight a4 rook d7
followed by king
it's still not easy for black no no no i
think just the move knight d7 how much
time two minutes
left only for timor right now with a
very difficult position to go okay this
is this is a huge moment in our
standings i mean fabi and he's playing
97.
move we kind of rejected i'm not too
happy with him with this move
yeah rook d1 knight b6 perhaps he's
strong
to play yeah and going back to our point
of simplifying the position here i
thought you play rook d3 just so that i
get a couple of rooks off the board so
rook t3 rook takes i think i'll be happy
to take and then
king and just let's look
is it a race or not i mean
let's go g4 why or why g4 take this pawn
rope d8
i want to go g4 h4g
i'm so
proud and you're right
you because the bishop is going to do a
great job at stopping blacks but what
about knight majority let's keep going
let's start going knight c8 knight c8 i
think it's the only crowd
[Laughter]
but i don't think it's good okay yeah
i feel like i feel uh
boldly stating the obvious yeah we have
something better uh to do we do have by
the way everyone is on the board
on the board
and we
yeah
so knight b6 looks
now how many moves to go uh we still
have five moves to go for
rook to d3 was played they're following
our next thing i mean you know your guy
i've spent some time with my
dude
knight to a4 on the board by the way one
spending
time
with top flight grand masters whether it
be vichy and magnus
and and
this
2800 crowd
what stands out in your mind that makes
baby at 2 800 and
lanier
fantastic grand master
uh a mayor mortal or 2750. uh his
ability to get himself out of trouble
through calculation
that there are so many
gains that he saves
from bad positions where he just
calculates out a draw example the game
that he drew against levon aronian
and then
the american cup here sorry he drew
against
was it ironic or dominguez yes against
iranian iranian right in the italian i
wanted yes to point out
which was a crazy game but five is
busted really for most of the game right
and he at some point calculates out
a weird draw
and it happens on the board and you're
like
okay he's confused but he was right it
was a draw
calculation well we're getting the race
guys okay we knight takes a2 followed by
rook to d7 most likely will come on the
board and who's faster that's not the
item a2 rook d7
i think rook d7 followed by king takes
g7 king takes
whichever pawn you allow me to take
let's imagine we got get here and
it's pushing baby right yep okay let's
do it persian baby
king takes g7
go push him
take on f6 take that as well take that
one as well let's go oh my goodness all
right that's a lot of pawns maybe he's
not
i'm getting scared
[Laughter]
all i did was push the ones that were
closest to
my clock
so you take on these on c7 and you go
bishop d5 but then knight c3 comes on
right and i mean
i feel like this it's a game it starts
to become real problem like you have to
find
some really precise moves for both sides
last
okay couple of moves right now
right and down to his last 50 seconds
and by the way timor did not
go with his plane
i think this is a very useful move uh
don't get me wrong i think that this is
a move that
you often will see return because the
knight on c3 will kind of
stop the bishop from
dealing with the pawns and then you can
decide which pawn is going to be the
rabbit it's going to be the b or the a
sorry do you take with the rook or with
the king i wasn't sure actually
it feels
i don't know
i don't instinctively see the difference
well f5 is
no it's not
let me perhaps let me self-correct
he's taken on g7
b4 and that's mu40
wow
and boy this is the moment you get up
from the board and you kind of think to
yourself
it's time to it's time to start yeah
like like
okay
this is the rabbit
this is what you straight up calculation
it's straight up calculation at this
point and we know who's really good at
calculation computers christian
what's it say
no no come on let's try to solve this
i'm going to try and have a break here
i'm a lazy guy
i'm seeing an easy way out guys what so
you take on c7
let's keep looking on on your board okay
king takes g7 on the board b5 b4 take on
c7 okay
take on c take on f6 okay
let's go and now rook d8
rook d a yes don't i catch it very
easily rook a rook b8 do you have any
defense against that well i have to drop
back to stop
the check
but now i will always have bishop e4
later on
in the game and i will chase your [ __ ]
it'll chase my bishop right it's not
that he's gonna make a draw let's start
with bishop to e4
now yes
i will chase your
your bishop your bishop can go to d3
um how do you sorry um i'm pausing
if i play b2 you play rook d2 rook d2
yes that's the plan
you're scaring me out of that kind of
easily what i still have knight c3 there
b2 rugby 293 and then rook b7
b2
rook d2
knight c3 and rook to b7 i assume that
bishop has to steal yeah diagonal i
assume so i also don't know why they
didn't take the bishop like bishop d3
and promote
step by step
[Laughter]
it's all a part of the master plan
uh yeah maybe not that easy yeah maybe
not that easy and and to be fair even at
the end of that variation even if you
capture the bishop all right you might
be lost so that's a lot of pawns as you
guys were mentioning uh probably it's
time to look at
the uh now suddenly he's ready to bail
out and say okay plus i just wore it
enlightened no way king takes f6
right e3 and now just simply rook to d2
oh when you put it like that am i not on
time chess is simple something a5
a5 right and now we get the race
a4
correct
dang
we get the race this is scary a3
we're both going to get queens most
likely
no me too i queen with check i can't you
clear that check but i am i'm mating you
and you're nominating me that's okay
i'll go all right cover with f5 most
likely yeah
i'm gonna actually get checkmate wow
because the rook on c7 is not moving
yeah it's in a pin and this pawn
is crucial if i don't have this pawn i'm
the one getting made right that's a
beautiful variation
why why are you getting made i can take
one h6
uh you can indeed but imagine no i like
the hyperbole
keep us on our edge of our seats right
yeah without f5 i would have to play
king h6 which would win the game
forget about it
guys you gotta play ball you know that's
why
hey i love it i mean christian no man
gosh i mean i got five stars for you i
like the move rook d3 to d2
because the crazy part is
that's like a strangely hidden move i
mean you're looking at
moving your king and
capturing the rook and as christian was
showing us get getting your rook behind
yeah
but this move rook d2 really just says
you're stopped you're stopped and that's
the thing about this move right the
beauty about it that it causes black
uh to lose so many tempi because now the
only way to push the pawn
involves pushing the other one which is
the still on the side yeah way up the
board
okay uh
that was a heck of a variation but now
having said that we've got b4 king takes
f6 but what else can black do or white
for that matter well i'm thinking okay
so this is the current position let me
just get the current this is the current
position with white to play we're
expecting king f6
and if i
let's see this other race a5
no this is not even as much fun i'm not
queening with check this is no race at
all no you just lost this is just lost
and well you're not actually winning any
tempe's because g3 was forcing me to go
to work to deal with these two right
exactly
now you just push the pawn and i push my
pawn so yeah no b3
rook to d2
and the problem is that you can also
never take on d7 because that allows me
to get the behind on the b file yeah
that is killer so you cannot change the
character of the position
the only thing you can do is push the
pawn
i feel like yeah it's in a very strange
way you're right the rooks are frozen
and uh you can't do anything yesterday i
hope he doesn't disappoint me because
i'm about to to it his horn but
fabi
when you were asking me what does he do
so well
he calculates this is what he does well
yeah so i think he's going to sit down
he's going to spend 20 minutes
on whatever
he needs to look at let's move 40. right
i think he already saw it
i don't think he's well
i think he calculated this
from afar yeah that's why he went for it
so so quickly um
calculations king takes off six played
within six minutes it's a six minute
thing
he doesn't play that quickly unless he's
really confident he's very confident i
think he thinks he's just one yeah
i mean he might be right the knight is
just dominated by the bishop yeah so
there's no moves that you could consider
with the knight
and i am going king g6 followed by f6
followed by f7 followed by f8 queen and
there's nothing you can do there's not
that many choices on it that's the thing
it's very well very once you understand
clearly the position then it becomes
easy
one more look guys just a second so i'll
go a5 you'll go king g6 now i'll trade
rooks okay okay
okay so like in this case i don't have
to put my king on b6 where i just get
killed i can go king a6 okay so and i
i'll meet
a move like rook b7 with knight b5 and
so let's go rogue d2
so you will go back rook d2 so i
resolved
a5 you're just still lost at the end
right oh man just
f7 okay okay
oh i like this move
that's a big difference actually you get
to stop my pawn and the two passers on
the sixth rank
they're about ready to do their little
uh joke
yeah
oh that's interesting okay let's not
hurry with with what we did i feel i had
better options
um king to a6 let's start this is where
we should start right exactly
so if i go rook to b7 what do you play
i was thinking i was dropping the knight
uh back to interfere with your ability
to play rook takes b
three or b two okay that makes sense so
what if i go f6 now
f
six okay well this is a check that's
okay bishop e4 your rook is hanging
that's okay
[Laughter]
show some fear
i demand that you show fear it's not my
pieces
okay
so
uh the desirable b1 equals queen
uh bishop takes king takes he's saying
i'm gonna get my rook back do we trust
him yeah i don't see how you defend okay
we trust you okay
let's keep going though wait uh so now
wait wait wait wait why why why why are
we trusting you so keep going he's a
very trustworthy person no no make the
queen i want to see this first you make
the queen let's make the queen first
okay make the queen
by the way we always look at forcing
verse variations that anything that
begins with check we look first
and now i'm going to go knight d
and now i go f5
just a second knight it pause here just
remember because we can get a
construction
with the knight on c3 where his bishop
cannot
capture our pawn so you want to oh a4
i'm just thinking that a4
and knight c3 but
but we had this idea an f5 of 96
and it's your night that feels like it's
the end of the road for us here just
let's go back here for just a moment
if we
if we start with a4 let's go f8
f8 equals queen
smack smack
and i understand
now you bishop c2 f bishop b3
this has to be lost it has to be
positive too many pawns
well the funny part is if we go knight
e2 right now f5 would walk in front of
knight b3 yeah but you still have a
chuck
oh it's check
uh guys this is uh
i mean this is really really impressive
calculation if if he goes down this path
and it produces a victory
and by the way rook takes d7 is indeed
the best move according to the engine
i'm just peeking at it right now
what did he say what did we say is the
best
rook takes d7 so the trade of the rooks
that we discussed
after b3 now i'm wondering whether
a4 is just that easy straightforward
variation and it is
a3 f7 b2
f8 there's nothing better b1 and then f5
just finishes the game so okay
we're up to this point b3 is on the
board right
king g6
never mind rook to d2 first yes yes we
have to stop the b bar a5 a5 king g6 and
now we say take take and king a6 right
now the best move
is rook to d8
oh man that's what well it's the same
idea before right right it's the same
idea from before you don't have a way to
cover
wow
okay so this force is almost the rook to
go here and now
i can just simply trade off the rooks
and go is that
wait a minute i'm getting confused here
so b2
f's
no
no you allow the
you allow the queen to get on the board
with a check
but it's actually completely losing
you're kidding me
this position is
winning for white because if you move
your rook i have rook v8 shadow
capture the queen on b1 that's amazing
take a look let's take a look so so we
can get here pretty much by force right
right up to here up to rook d-a but the
rook to d8 does seem to allow these
variations so
what was our idea rugby seven i think we
tried seven two three or nine
knight b5 yeah
it's a draw yeah yeah that was that's
what we thought because of knight b5
maybe rook v5 is even better even a
better choice
knight b5 completely winning because of
some of the same stuff yeah rook b8 yes
crazy so rook to b5 now this is a draw
okay crazy
does rook to d2 work
nope
and if you don't go rook to d2 or rook
to b7
then you have to go rook d8 or you lose
the advantage even so rook d8
allowing black to promote with check
is the only way to win the game it seems
like it
welcome to the 23rd century i mean
that's
remarkable and we have lots of people
who want to join the conversation
alejandro
join us
we're on social media we're on youtube
we are on twitch we are on twitter and
this one is from twitch how do players
fund their preparation do they usually
pay for seconds out of pocket or are
they sponsored and that is a great
question and the correct answer is both
i'm a little bit out here a little bit
some people are indeed sponsors
sponsored magnus carlson i think vessel
and topalov and vichy anand were
three people that
most especially when i think about the
history had sponsorships gary did too
but uh they are sponsored and the
sponsors pay but
most of the players are actually paying
their sponsors it's paying their second
from their winnings yeah yeah i think
that richard is doing that from their
own earnings from their own earnings now
it might be and uh christian jump in
that uh richard
has changed the federations to romania
uh did he get some sponsors from romania
i don't think that uh switch has been
finalized so i cannot talk too much
about it
but i do know that there was a
substantial offer from superb super beth
foundation um i see the company
sponsoring actually the grand chester as
well
so they've been very helpful uh but it
does seem like that could potentially
help uh reach it tremendously because at
the top
from the top ten
i don't think there's anybody else that
doesn't have a sponsor and richard was
the last one i i know i'm pretty aware
that sergey
um oh he has an energy of sponsors
says nepo
oh yes yes
nepo had uh
i think a big contract with
well i don't know exactly the specifics
but i know he was sponsored by chess.com
going into the um
world championship match
so he was their brand ambassador um now
i know that he's sporting some logos on
his jacket even at the candidates right
there's definitely some sponsors and
there are some people
who um they're sponsored by their
federation or their country exactly uh i
mean i know that chesapeal also
sponsors um
the indian master hari krishna
chesapeal sponsors him but you're
actually
right absolutely right
for example when i played in my
candidates and a big
grateful grateful thanks to my
federation the united states chess
federation and they did support
me and
gave me a stipend
to actually do some preparation and it
was
it was it meant everything i meant my
ability to study versus not right and it
was that simple
traditionally but not anymore for
example aronian when he was playing for
armenia for a very very long time he had
armenia in seconds exactly
uh more social media
here he comes um from a twitchy user
the important question that must still
be answered does alejandra still have
that hat from his feed
yes all right
that is a really funny photo by the way
i think we're going to put that hat up
for auction so that we can sponsor our
whole scholastics
chess program here in the greater st
louis area i'm sure millions
are going to be raised
i really hate it as soon as we get this
and this is the photo coming up i don't
know if the the production team has it
it's a very pixelated photo and i know
exactly where it's from it looks almost
art like well it was i don't know why
it's still there because vita has
specifically taken pictures of me okay
to update my feed a profile right
in multiple occasions it's not been once
in real life locations affiliate officer
has flagged me during a tournament and
be like we need to update your feeder
photo because in this photo i'm 15.
wow it was 20 years ago
it's still there it's still there
is that
uh it looks like i have a mullet
yeah it does
it's just very pixelated that's actually
somebody behind me
it's somebody's shoulder
what yeah this is not part of my hair
like if you go to feed it and look me up
right yasser is looking at the picture
right now yeah it looks like i have a
mullet right i don't have a mullet no it
was just somebody in the background some
random guys
this is wrong on so many so many levels
yeah so many levels
that is pretty funny um
but uh no the the one that i really like
was uh the story of alejandro he's
wearing the beret
in um the uh aeroflot tournament that's
right
and he was one of the last players to
finish a particular round and victor
korchnoy victor lovovich the
victor korchnoy the guy who played for
two world championships maybe three
if you count 1974
came and watched
alejandro's game
and alejandro is like just amazed that
this legend of chess
is studying his games and trying to
learn
and alejandra take it from there
he very politely finished waited for me
to finish my game and then he proceeded
to yell at me
instead of congratulations young man
great understanding and great knowledge
of the benko gambit instead you got uh
he hated my hat
he asked me if he i saw anybody else in
the tournament with a hat on
do look around do you see anybody with
that are you idiot
pretty much
oh i loved it loved it love it but yeah
put that hat up for auction we'll get
the whole st louis scholastic scene
sponsored
you'll be a hero oh two dollars yeah
you'll be a hero trust me um
christian back over to you for a second
i found some other ways yeah i was
actually wondering about it i found some
other ways why are we putting the king
on g6 that is a very good question
that is a very good question
probably the much more practical
approach is to actually put the king on
e6 so really with check yes
king to asics
f6 take and now you can actually take
even with the king and keep the rook on
the second rank
no more b2
if you don't play the move rook to f5 i
will cover that square with the move g4
and then you're not going to be able to
catch the pawn anymore so for example if
you go a4 i go g4 not only that you
don't catch the pawn but even if you do
catch the pawn
i get the second one
i go g5 g6 and there's going to be a
race but i'm going to be the one uh i'm
going to be the first one so
i believe this is the big moment right
now king to e6 or king to g6
now is the time to stop and think i
think into e6 from without an engine by
your side obviously it's a much easier
approach because you also have this
extra option of taking with the king on
d7 and keeping connection with the
square b2 very very important um
and this is where we are right now this
is what fabiano is calculating king to
g6 i get it it's the best move but you
have to see that rook d8 move
that's not that's not easy no no no the
whole variation is not easy
you see a queen landing with chuck you
don't see a queen on your board
you feel a bit awkward uncomfortable
right for me the move king e6 is a very
very awkward move i'm always looking for
kind of a shelter for my king and i feel
like i live
left my chin right out there but why
aren't you playing king g7
okay you don't want to get the queen
if you don't want to have the pawn
promoted with well because you lose on
the spot ah
you take uh you take with chuck i take
with check of course check and b1 and b1
so you have to be careful the seventh
rank is mind right now right that makes
perfect you could you could go i
actually wanted to go to e7
let's go to e7 yeah
that that works you're leaving this pawn
on
later on obviously you cannot take it
because of the places
yeah so
if i do well if i take i think with the
rook and i'm up a tempo on a couple of
the variations that we looked at i know
you guys like rook b7 directly right and
i felt that this end game with the queen
should be winning anyway
and here we had this rook d8 once again
rook to d8 idea
and check check very nice that's a
beautiful
seriously that's a nice big hidden
moment it does seem like all of them are
winning king e6 king g6 k7
but the easiest to calculate i think is
either king to e7 or king to e6 going to
g6 is going to be very difficult i agree
i mean seeing that entire line is
baffling
truly allowing the queen with checkout
that's insane
i mean that's a very very complex
wonderful ending and it's almost unfair
that
the number one and number two seeds
there's playing a a nice ending that
we've almost had to ignore
in view of the fact that the other game
is just
outstanding it's not consequential i
mean and it really it also is not very
interesting and worse it looks like it's
pretty favorable pretty drawn uh at that
uh
wow i would have never guessed this not
you know if from the start of the
tournament
i would have looked at this round round
seven and say number one versus number
two
that game
uh could determine who's in first place
after the first half
oh
wow but because of all of the results
that have happened in the first six now
seven rounds let's take a look at the
live ratings and how things have
shuffled this is where we were before
the start of the tournament no this is
the this is the current one this is
including are the current yeah this
includes the win the network just had
wow
that's how fast our production team
works man they are johnny on the spot
but fabi's still clinging to the number
three
c so if he wins today
he will be within very slim margins
but he's not going to surpass no he
gained i think he gets
four and up and four and change for
beating raj above because i think raja
is like 30 points behind and ding is
actually not losing and then anything
should not lose any rating for drawing
alireza that is a good point so
as we expect the games to end if fabio
finds correct continuation
it would be a very tight race for second
and alaresa is not the one we're talking
about there you have it
wow
okay
i'm still coming to grips with this uh
ultra sharp ending it's very easy to sit
here turn on a computer engine and go oh
white has plus three it's a completely
different
it's actually
to sit here and uh calculate it yourself
you you're seeing these pawns you know
trundle up the board unimpeded
and if you're not scared
yeah something's wrong i mean your heart
should be like
unless you're a great calculator and
fabian he really is
if he spots a winning line he will just
go with it with absolute confidence and
he's really good at it he's seeking this
out right there oh yeah right there
going right after a5 on the board we
reckon king e6
pardon me king e7 king e6 and king g6
all
win in different ways too but in very
different ways and one of them
i'm still
mesmerized by this line recall it for me
where i get the queen with check and you
take you take on d7 here okay then you
take king a6 so that you don't get
checked on the b file okay then rook to
the day it was rooked the eight
rook to d8 and then i had to block the b
file you block the b file with the rook
five you go f6 and you threaten the
queen you make a queen yourself the guy
ignores you
not only that you get the rook on b5
covering the b file but also that rook
is no longer having a spot on the
seventh rank
so that after king to g7 there's no rook
to c7 anymore
to block my pawn from promotion and by
the way rook to b7 right now
you're not even going to take because
that allows the queen to drop back into
the game but you're actually going to
give a check first i actually don't see
the issue you take on b7 you take on b7
oh they have queen g2 sorry my bank yes
queen
but this one is
no this is this is fantastic
what a domination it's kind of out of a
study
no that's what i'm saying
if my opponent beats me like this that's
where i say excuse me mr harper could
you bring a wand over here or just a
phone by the way king e6 is on the board
yeah
e6 that's the human factor the most
human approach right heavy
i like that king e6 not to allow uh the
queen with czech and christian back to
you
we figured out this win and just remind
us of uh
the one
we like best no king 36 was the right
move this is what we liked and i think
um after take first of all you can just
simply take with a check right so if you
try to sidestep that by let's say
playing king to a6 first now f6 take and
now king
takes that's
this was the variation that we were
discussing now you have a couple of
options one of them is to go rook to f5
but now comes uh the beautiful uh aspect
of this position and beautiful uh
sequence king to e6 rook to f4 and now
king to e5 no
there's no more squares for the rook on
the file the domination so this is quite
beautiful um you have to take and then
you have to go h
how easy is this
so let's see
is that the only move by the way
just probably not i mean i don't have an
option to to get more than one variation
um
but i would just my guess is that it's
not nevertheless like what if you just
go here and try to catch it like that
probably a382 no rook to d8 makes a lot
of sense right
well yeah and
it kind of blocks both yeah it blocks my
response from a position it kind of
doesn't have a movement freeze yeah
yeah
so
here i think you can go rook bait and
even even
yeah there's there's just no you're not
moving the pawns no they're not going
against they're frozen they're frozen
yeah yeah yeah
but again and he sees this he says to d8
for sure yeah that's one move that he
can see there are those heart
palpitations just to make sure that they
don't get any further king e6 on the
board we're going to wait for teemo
rajabov to make what i expect is a long
thing because he has moves to consider
and he wants to at least try to find a
way out of his problems we know that he
doesn't have it but he doesn't know that
and these are the current standings
everything to play for for fabiano
caruana two games still in play two
games still in play alireza and dingley
wren and fabi against timothy we're
gonna take a short break and we will be
back on the finishing touches of today's
wild wild round
[Music]
and in the early 70s when i started
playing chess two players had an
outsized
influence on my chess career victors
pooples
uncle vic
and james harley mccormick jim
was
really like a street fighter
he was a brawler both on and off at the
chessboard
i believe it was a washington open that
jim had come to and he hadn't yet
entered the tournament
and as he was looking around
he suddenly realized oh my goodness
a lot of the top players were simply
missing
and so he saw an opportunity to take an
easy first place of fifteen hundred
dollar
first place if you will
you waited until the very last moment
and then rushed the organizer and said
i'd like to enter the tournament the
organizer said very reasonably sorry jim
the pairings are closed the registration
is closed
and besides we have an even number of
players
if we let you in the event somebody
would
receive a forfeit and we don't want to
do that
so jim was you know really anxious to
get in the tournament because the the
first prize was a was a gimme
easy
so he needed to find somebody who would
play in the tournament looked around and
he saw a guy random guy sitting down he
said excuse me do you play chess
yes said the fellow would you like to
play in the tournament said jim and he
said well i can't afford it
jim you know thought about this for a
moment and said okay i'll pay your entry
fee
great
so the tournament organizer asked you
know our unknown mystery person
um
were they members of the northwest chess
association no it's an extra 10
membership were they members of the
united states chess federation no that's
an extra thirty dollar membership all of
which of course was being paid by jim
mccormick
so finally they settled down jim had
paid his dues his opponents dues his
entry fee his opponent's entry fee
the man turned out to be a chess master
from canada who defeated jim in the
first round and went on to win the
tournament
stuff of legends
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody it is round seven
of the candidates and what a decisive
round it is for the event as young pogba
has destroyed
richard rapport and with the black
pieces and that means that nepo is
sitting pretty on five and a half out of
seven rounds these uh highlighted rounds
are the ones that are finished we still
have two games pending hikaru nakamura
did draw his game against yangshi of
duda which means that
he remains at 50 and surprisingly that's
good enough for a clear third remarkable
but the big news is that we think that
fabi's going to win
to keep pace
with nepo who's otherwise just simply
running away with the event and in this
position uh it's a race the f pawn is
going
but so is the b-pawn and one of the nice
ways and we've seen this often in the
our analysis
is white's rook
can get behind
the pawns thanks to the maneuver rook d8
with the idea of rook a heck and rook b8
and we think that that is the best way
for um
uh fabi to go about his business of
winning the game but he's already played
the move f6 which is another move that
we considered to be winning while we
were on break we were discussing this
with christian okay so after f6 he was
very convincing
was he yeah he said f6 i know
f6 b2 okay f7 you promote i promote
exactly exactly i was scared like wait a
minute wait wait wait wait a minute yeah
black is promoting first mike king is
kind of in the middle of nowhere there's
checks everywhere checks after check
check but
they're not becoming any actually if you
go queenie one for example just to put
one of the checks that's one king f7 and
that's the end of that story and you
will whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
i don't know why i said king of seven
yeah you know what i meant yes king of
six to stop
right there is no rook c66 there is no
d5 there is no knight e4 right so
you're just dead because that's
threatening queen a8 i'm turning queen
c5 your king will get mated so queenie
one is a lousy check it's a lousy check
but then i saw okay queen g6 what about
this one exactly and that was also easy
to calculate on the worst case scenario
and i'm not sure that i have a better
move but in the worst case scenario i
have queen f6 you simply block this i
simply block the check any other further
checks might allow check check yes
exactly check check and it's mate right
so this also puts the cabochons in that
one and the and finally this one is the
nicest one you just drop your rook in
the way and that's the end of story so
even though black is allowed to queen
first
the resulting position is fantastic for
white
so
and on the board we do have f6 he did
not go for the rook d8 maneuver not and
there's not a lot of choices here for
black
you go f7
if i try to stop you well that makes it
really easy right you just check me yeah
thank you for the rook oh dear you don't
even know not only the rook but yeah
you're probably gonna have rook b7 yeah
yeah it gets worse so christian uh take
us through the lines we do have the
position f6 on the board
are there any tricks that teamwork
could conjure no uh by the way rook d8
apparently was more compelling but now
we get this position
yeah yep
queen to g6 now i was wondering why not
king to e7
yeah king e7 is also winning
queen to f6 we get into this end game
and now at least i have this a pawn
still going down the board
it could get ugly right so i don't want
by the way objectively this is still
winning nevertheless
it just feels that after queen g6 king
to e7 is just more compelling keep the
queens on the board and that's going to
allow me to get closer to your king and
potentially threaten checkmate wow so
how do you do it right now king to b5
seems the seems to be the only way to
try to escape otherwise
queen to
if you go here i think king d8 just
finishes you yeah i agree because ca5 is
hanging yes so king to b5 okay
and the question is how easy i like this
engine's move g2 g4 get out of it
maybe something ridiculous i mean people
are trying to get checkmated and you're
just pushing past pawns perhaps this is
still a game all right let's see wow
let's see queen to f6 i think that's why
i wanted to go
let's try to understand i love this move
rook d8 why don't just get the right
behind up here okay
fine
uh you don't want to exchange the rooks
because your bishop is more or less
dominated by the night right now right
it's like a mutual domination type of
yeah well let me get rid of that night
the night bothers me so you go rook c8
yeah like get rid of that night that
night's on a fabulous square that makes
a lot of sense yeah yeah
i think if you go here do i even have
right yes
is this enough a3
ah king b7 check this move out
that okay
seven rook c one i don't get it yeah
rook to c1 and then knight to d4 my
knight escapes right well i wasn't
trapping trying to trap the knight so
much as i was trying to maneuver push
the knight away to b5 and in this
position right here i was hoping that
well if you go a3 i would assume you
want to take right well well no the
bishop first
yeah right right that has to be winning
sorry with the bishop on f3 uh
can i just take yeah night eight night
knight b5
trade the rooks
sure put the bishop on d5
and uh
doesn't my f pawn
winning also
yeah but i want to do it in the easiest
possible way right yeah yeah no this is
probably the practical approach right
that's what we were thinking
yeah that you trade the question it
seems pretty easy to trade rook straight
everybody and then my bishop will uh
somehow
it will somehow maneuver itself to the
correct diagonal it looks pretty pretty
pretty easy yes and i do think that
we're most likely going to see this uh
uh position after queen to g6 queen f6
and the trade of the queens okay in
which it doesn't seem like black gets
enough counter play gotcha
okay and by the way what's happening in
the other one in between ding okay
nothing is happening
nothing has changed um
it does seem like white has a bit more
space and perhaps a bit more activity of
his species
but the knight stays on e6
locating everything i yeah i don't think
this one is going anywhere right
really
i don't think so yeah i mean i can go
this way it's black to move
that's pretty funny
i remember this was a wonderful game
from the new york open and joel benjamin
was playing a very tough game against
the estonian grand master jan elvis
elvist
and
boy
joel really
burning some clock 15 minutes
thinking thinking thinking and finally
elvis makes a move
and joe like looks at yon and says yan i
think it's mine
oh says yes
my clock is ticking but john decides it
was a good good moment to get in a good
shot
and this is where our afternoon stands
thus far and these are the completed
games as richard rockport finishes the
day with three points janna fomnyacci
finishes the day with five and a half
and wow this is how you win a tournament
this is how you win the first half
for sure look at that destruction and
again plus four for us was a magic
number that said to us i win the
tournament with such a score we just
didn't realize it was going to be such a
high scoring race
between two players and his magic number
i think we can update that magic number
to say yeah my
yeah you might right it really does come
down i mean i don't think we can hype it
more but it really will come down to
round nine that's the date of destiny
there's no question about it that's when
fabi with the white pieces
will get a chance to play against his
rival nepo
and
should there be a winner in that game
almost undoubtedly that will be the
challenger okay guys what is timor
thinking about
what is teamwork thinking about i'm
trying to say they're going to
understand because
b2 seems to be the only move right
after f6 oh you mean well yeah
how else can you play here right yeah
uh yeah
no i was about to make a suggestion for
rook b
well i can play beside b2 yeah the thing
is like
i think you can refute rook b5 in like
five seconds five rook b5 f7 rook ba rig
b7 resigns
is rook c4 an alternative is is is that
it i
got no
no dispute from me
uh pardon me rook c4
will that change anything significant i
guess that's the question he's trying to
answer so ah you mean with in the
positions where we queen the rook will
be better placed on c4 i'm
i'm just maybe guessing at this point
okay maybe let's let's just take a look
b2
has anything significantly changed
so i have
still the check on e1 seems to be kind
of no more checks on g6 no more check on
g6 so king to queen to e1 seems to be
the only er check
and now i actually it feels like i have
a choice
between f six and f seven because that's
four five
choices yeah that finishes the checks
um okay before we go rook c4 doesn't
help before we go even too deep in this
line what is the point of roxy for f7
like
rook c4f7
i wanted to take the pawn yeah but thank
you for getting my rook to d8 i wanted
it there anyway right right
party pooper yeah that's also completely
winning
that's the easier version right truly
yeah i'm not uh i i i i'm always
whenever you have this active role
behind
it's right it freezes upon so then what
what is he thinking about because he's
been thinking for the last 10 minutes
damn i think here 10 minutes
i mean b2 seems like the only legal move
in the position how's the b2
yeah
yeah i
okay
i mean look you you will have to
calculate all those checks but at least
calculated two moves from here yeah
right have the queen's practical yeah
take the practical rally yeah put the
queens on the board
and now start calculating how do i make
the checks for for me that what was
remarkable was that one line you were
showing a christian
uh
this move king b5 was not intuitively
obvious but getting on your sneakers
once you see the move queen a8 check you
start to say okay if i can get on my
sneakers and start running
in advance maybe i can get ahead of the
or the worst and by the way that's not
such an easy position right i wouldn't
guarantee that black white's winning
this
well objectively
i think he wouldn't he is white is
winning like would you 100 say white is
winning this position without an engine
without an engine no
i don't know
[Laughter]
scratch scratch
i've got a feeling the apon's not going
anywhere whereas like i can force the
trade of queens right so what's the
point of this g-form check that's the
thing right if i'm going to trade the
queens
i would do the beginning right from the
yeah yeah but i also have rook f5 at the
end so that doesn't actually work
perhaps this is why you play g4 first so
let's show that line
oh you're right let's show the line
after rook to b7
yeah
king to c4 right okay by the way b2 is
on the board queen f7 right and it
doesn't work because you just take and
rook f5 correct
so perhaps this is the hidden idea of g4
oh you take one h22 okay the hidden idea
of g4 that in this position
you don't go checking and forcing the
trade of queens rather you play g4 first
so that you go into that variation
there's no rook f5 check and by the way
b2 f7 on the board and it seems to me
that fabi
is the one playing he's right with the
greater speech it's calculating it all
okay there's not a lot of choices again
again
agreed
wow okay so this is the current position
we've been anticipating for some time
this position
and then we think this is the best check
and
the practical player in me his
queen f6 christian has pointed out that
king e7 keeping the queens on the board
is also winning is also winning
i must admit that i see this
and i go oh i i got this i got this
right i think that's the practical
choice yeah yeah absolutely
and
um yeah the a pawn is just not strong
enough by the way i mean
again
prematurely imagining that fabi was to
win this game
to be cruel at timor
will have lost yet again
in a position if a really good game i
mean give fabby credit i mean fabi
i mean hikaru beat timor by grinding him
down and it was unbelievable game yeah
that was very good right that was really
really really bad i mean timor fails to
see bishop h2 again richard
i mean
there's
there's good luck
hello nepo
and there's terrible luck
i mean you know is timor getting all the
sins
helped himself right right even in
today's game when you really think about
it
he never equalized
he was like on the verge he was on the
he was on the verge
but yeah from the opening which was his
proposal to play an a6 sicilian uh
though kelly he was always suffering
true we were talking about a two result
game
from how early in the in the game and
but yet even having said that this is
the moment where i think he could have
really uh made
bobby's life very very difficult with
the mover of c5 or even knight g4 check
oh also king g3 knight f6 followed by
rook c5 it was his move uh
right here it was the move f7 f6 that
opened up the gateway for white's king
uh in in in very short order i mean
fabby jumped at his chance of just
driving his king all the way to g6 not
afraid of the complications that ended
up happening because we did get a raise
exactly but here it goes
had it under control yeah it
captured all of the king side pawns and
the players have essentially raced to
oops that's going too far ever raced to
this position with b2 f7
currently on the board
so it was that move f6 guys
what is team we're thinking about this
this one in particular is kind of funny
right like i don't know
i don't actually what is he thinking
about another there's only one movie in
the position rook to ca doesn't work
regular f5
i don't think it works no no rook defy
doesn't work for
like rook f5 i think you a bazillion
reasons right a bazillion five viewed
i think the answer is rook d8
i still don't see what happens to d8
yeah that's the easiest
that's that's by far that's that's we
keep going back to the same tactic right
yeah rook f5 you go here and then any
queens
is going to be met by check followed by
check and captures
that's a very nice skier of the newly
minted queen in this game wow and that
is game
so you have to put a queen on the board
right now just play b1 yeah and this is
uh what we're expecting
you don't want to promote in to anything
else but the queen
i think we kind of gave it a little
short shift but we did get the question
from our social media
that um should nepa win the event uh
would this really reduce the odds of
magnus accepting and playing
and i think we both said yes just simply
yes
but on the other hand uh
nepo is playing just really really well
and we've always admired magnus from
from the point of view that he accepts
challenges whether it be fischer random
blitz
rapid chess
and uh
a decisive victory by nepo
might
induce magnus to think you know what
i should play that guy
i hear you
the thing is that i don't think that
magnus sees this as backing out of a
challenge
i'm sure that he is precisely backing
out because it is a challenge and in
this case it's a challenge that's taking
too much from him
and if he had to prove
that he's better than nepo then i'd say
yeah
that he'll take that he'll make the
sacrifice for it but he already did that
and
it's very likely and i hope that he
changes his mind because of course i
would like i would like absolutely i
would like to see magnus defend his
title as many times as it takes until
somebody actually
takes it from him correct but
it is it is a big asking considering the
entire field
which and the words that he said
which one of these players could he be
referring to i think the number one
candidate is
nepo yeah
uh jump in uh christian do you see a
nepo victory in this tournament as
making it more likely
that magnus would not
defend his title yes yes i think if
fabiano wins
uh there is a very there's a big
likelihood that we're going to see the
match between himself and magnus if
nepal wins i don't know i just don't
feel it and i don't think magnus feels
it either i think he just wants a new
challenge uh he sees fabiano at least my
eyes as a challenge
i don't think after the last match that
he sees nepo as such
well just one other thought i mean
obviously nepo is russian
because of the situation these days
would there be nations that the match
couldn't be held in because of
sanctioned reasons
uh there are
issues it's it's a little confusing
yeah yeah i mean we want to be we won't
be seeing uh nepo or the russian team in
the olympia
for example it's kind of a big deal well
i mean in my ex
whole chess career
the russian slash soviet teams were
always
pre-tournament favorites they were the
number one seeds i want to say that the
russian team
this i believe is going to be the first
olympiad in
olympic history
stretching back for decades that the
american team is the number one seed
many decades
many decades we do have queen g6 check
on the board we think king e7 is a
computer engine driven win we think
queen f6
is a more kind of a human approach
but both
will be winning uh and one probably has
a plus three or plus four when the other
probably has something higher
and i was just looking through the
variations and actually there's quite
some funny ones
so queen to f6 take take
take and we go to a4 rook to d8 is what
we were looking at but also there's this
move king to g6 okay a3 rook to d2 a2
and actually give up the rook it's
different this is still completely
winning
after f5 there's no way you can stop
that point
wow the knight on a2 is a long
it's a long way from home especially
because d3 is a mine square once you get
the knight to d3 i go bishop p2 right
and and that kills it so for example if
you try to do go like this f7 95 and
black is fine right right but bishop p2
just finishes the game ouch
very nice um
is black fine after f7 i guess so right
it should be black should probably be
fine afternoon night check
suddenly yeah yeah probably yeah yeah
problematic run out of pawns i think
yeah really g5 or something could make
it difficult even even h5 not only that
h4
not to go there not to allow the knight
to sacrifice so let's see this is
probably one of the last few critical
moments if white decides to go queen to
f6
if the queens stay on the board then the
position becomes quite complicated i
have to say the more i look at it and
the more you have to find these ideas of
g4 it's not easy right it's not easy
with a ticking clock um queen to f6 does
seem to be the practical choice that
fabiano needs to make right now
calculate all of those lines perhaps
even calculate the line that i just
showed you
and uh and go for it exactly simplify
the position get into a technically
winning position and this is exactly
what he's seeking
right now and i think he will find it
yeah no queen f
queen f6 to my eyes
i don't know about you alejandro that
seems just such a practical decision it
would be difficult for me to really
consider the move king e7 but hey good
news for fabi fans both legal moves
are winning are winning indeed
now to uh well i have to share something
with our audience i mean we're at the
first half
after today i mean we'll go into the
second half but
well our dear friend christian is going
to go attend a wedding not his own not
his own but he's going to attend a
wedding and we're going to have a new
member on staff uh christian we're gonna
miss you my friend i'm gonna miss you
too uh guys but uh you know i'll see you
soon enough uh we're going to rekindle
our uh bromance
again at the beginning of july for the
juniors seniors uh and the junior girls
tournament so many so many events coming
up this summer here in st louis and
those three events always a great deal
of fun nice to call the action and then
you've got zagreb and
take a look at this list of events and
christian will be coming back
for the u.s juniors and seniors and
juniors girls july 7th to the 16th here
in st louis missouri and uh he will also
be joining us in the gct commentary
we're back with the grand chester super
united in rapid and blitz in zagreb and
who's going to sacrifice i'm going to
zagreb are you going to destroy i'm
going to zagreb this time christian will
be with you in the studio and
assertiveness you're on your way to
india i am on my way to india just kind
of helping the uh olympic teams yeah i'm
i'm specifically with the women i'll be
the coach for the women's team
but i think they were talking about
magnus carlsen will be playing in zagreb
that's the one that matters
and he will also be here for the sink
field cup he won't be playing our saint
louis rapid and blitz but he will be
playing in the same field cup which we
moved to september this year because of
the olympia
right to accommodate accommodate the um
the organizers in chennai india
yeah we start with christian
and finish up with magnus sounds like a
good day
i i want to keep christian
don't want to trade
are you gonna do the dance yes sir
no no no no no i i mean uh we will
definitely be missing you uh christian
but you guys will be getting dorsal so
that should be yes interesting exactly
that that will be your
uh dorsal will be replacing and doris is
your student
not anymore she actually graduated from
st louis university
it's his student now
she's coming to mizzou
there she is and she will be joining us
in studio tomorrow that's right and she
will be here
uh replacing christian three-time gold
medalist
that was why she got her scholarship to
the st louis university yeah you're
definitely
gay for contribution
fantastico well uh welcome welcome
welcome dorsa of course and uh
again uh we'll be missing you christian
but the first half
christian i gotta tell you i mean it's
just so
it's been such a strange tournament
so many of my predictions forget about
hikaru for just a moment but i mean
seriously so many of my predictions
were just dead wrong i just thought that
ding lehren
a a wonderful choice you actually chose
him i mean a wonderful time i didn't see
i think that anything that every guest
that we've had sam shankland linear
today they were they said it pretty
explicitly
i thought this was sting's tournament i
thought this was the candidate where
ding finally would show his stuff
exactly but yet again it it almost feels
like it's a live on type of curse that
when you get to the uh candidate
levon doesn't perform right and thing
three candidates three candidates where
he's not part of the conversation right
shocking shocking and uh again how
difficult it is to win a game in
the candidates five players have failed
to win a single game in the first half
and then you have nepo who's winning
games like
left right easy making it easy
spending less than an hour spending less
than an hour winning with black spending
less than an hour thank you very much
thank you for your contribution winning
in an open tournament or something right
so it it is a confusing uh tournament
for us and uh
and how are we doing on predictions guys
actually let's uh maybe have really i i
nobody picked nepo
nobody picking that book that's all i
remember nothing else
you're doing well i have to say yasser
you're keeping close
alejandro not so
one
sorry so sorry
all right oh boy
guys we're still after g6
nothing has happened okay and what's the
clock times 23 minutes actually for
fabiano 27 for timur
so despite the fact that he burned all
that time with b2 and b1
it seemed
useless time spanisher right now he's
still ahead on time
fabiano will need to be very precise and
the clock is sticking down
we do get another additional 15 minutes
after 60 moves and that's 13 moves away
from here nevertheless it's going to
come down to the last few seconds i have
a feeling
the last few seconds
wait a minute i think we're all kind of
uh put this one as done and dusted and
you're kind of making a suggestion that
they're still not that easy guys
i mean look with the engine is very easy
right you see queen f6 you see that you
actually sacrifice the rook and that's
easy right well but if you don't have
the engine by your side
what are the lines that you that you're
shuffling around with well no
i thought we settled on takes takes a4
rook d8 as being the human exactly
and i wanted to trade a5 is that
such an easy approach
i understand but and then i wanted to
kick the knight and then i wanted to
trade the rooks that was oh and by the
way if i go
a three one yeah this is this is easy
right this is just deadlock thank
goodness
this i get three connected pass pawns
it's not even a question right right
yeah and the f pawn goes out
right yeah this is easy i i agree with
you all right so queen f6 takes stakes
i mean by the way taking is not the only
move right i can also give a check here
he has but i thought you can go uh
either rookie seven
or king d67 i don't have room to c6
again
wait a minute
so take take take
we exchange the queens actually
this is funny
a4 f5 oh we got two queens again no no
don't do this no this is draw more
queens on the board no this is drawn i
can't even pick up h2 in a minute
this is a draw right yeah i check on e5
and take on h2 this is a draw that's
right so we messed this up already
bravo bravo uh-huh so rook to e7 is
already a bad move
oh really yes queen 28 king to d6 seems
to be the only yeah no we had this you
said said king d6 i pick up a tempo that
was like an hour ago i already forgot it
and now you can actually force
yeah
okay uh by the way let's just let's just
refresh the board by the way we invite
everybody uh watching and thank you very
much for for for watching and sharing
your thoughts but you're invited to join
the conversation
by asking us any uh questions you might
have about the players we've been
discussing
magnus's comments about maybe
not defending his title in 2023 and as
we understand it should that happen the
top two finishers
of the candidates would be invited to
play for the vacant crowd
that is how the regulations do work
i mean there is some talk about it
the moment that magnus put it out there
and the moment yesterday that it became
clear that it's a two-horse race people
are starting to wonder does it you know
how is the candidates going to end and
does it really matter if they finish
one second or first because if they're
going to play each other anyway right
that's what the world championship match
would be
if magnus declines to play
it'll be these two
and uh we have some questions from the
social media let's uh let's have a
looksie uh from introducer parth uh who
are nepo's seconds all of his prep is
coming to exactly whoever seconds are i
mean you know like let's hire those guys
those guys have been amazing uh do we
know nepo seconds i don't think that we
know from dubai we do yes
do we oh yeah yeah i mean
i was there so i know a couple of
seconds that he has for this tournament
one of them is vithukov
i've seen a photo of
alongside nepal and the other one is
kairulin ildar so at least two seconds
with him right now at the candidates but
i think the prep that he's using mostly
is the one that he already has from the
world church championship before
yes especially with the petrov what
we've seen today was a residual
preparation from the world church
championship
because the european champion paul
polotkin
[Music]
he was definitely there for the world
championship the world championship was
popkin we had lekko was also there
under aleco and then tomaszewski
yeah and i think i'm missing one i think
janowski
long time long time coach of nepal um
okay i think afghanistan
four coaches plus a competitor bus plus
a computer specialist
quite impressive yeah it was a very bad
that's that's a team
and then once in a while sergey kayaking
went to say hi in dubai i don't know i
don't actually know if they were working
together
but he was like at least moral support
wow okay pretty impressive uh
team that who put together but those are
the seconds we think have been working
with nepo
and absolutely right
that
it has gone
swimmingly well i once had a u.s
championship a big shout out to a
longtime second
friend of mine john donaldson starting
to interrupt queen f6 uh played by uh
by fabi once had a u.s championship
where it was just one of those
tournaments where everything went
swimmingly well and i remember doing
some nice preparation work with john
for dimitri gervich
and it was like normally i'm
normally i'm like the last person to
catch somebody in some prep and dmitry
walked right down the fairway and there
was just no recovering and it was like
the shortest easiest victory game i've
had in my career
and it just
burst the sales like once that happened
everything happened and i won a u.s
championship in the swimming way as
we're seeing that boat today queen f6
sorry queen f6 but we do have a result
i'm being told that ali reza and
dingleren have drawn their game it was a
game in which
nothing had happened for a very long
time and nothing ended up happening
two players
desperate need for a win honestly even
with the win
marginally helps marginally helps at
this situation when the leaders are just
winning every game
what a disappointment yeah what a
disappointment drawing themselves
completely out of the event wow i mean
if they have a one percent chance i'd be
shocked
at this point well reza is three points
behind nebo and several months to go i
think two and a half so that's just i
mean i don't know insurmountable
i mean
i thought it was remarkable in round six
when
napo won and fabi won and nobody else
did it like it was two and two and it
was sort of like all of that they're
collecting all the riches you know all
the easter eggs they're they're getting
every one and i thought wow in round six
that was
that was really good i had no idea
they're going to repeat it repeat it day
after day
like a groundhog day but it's it's true
uh nepo has won his game already
with the one remaining game we do
believe that after the move queen f6 um
fabi's going to get another win as well
that's what we think and it's just
it's not what anybody expected really
everybody thought this was going to be a
tight tournament that all the candidates
were working really close there were a
couple of people that you could say
they weren't crowd favorites nobody was
giving team or rajab of a lot we can see
why a lot of chances in the event
uh but everybody else you think they
haven't i mean richie wasn't the big big
big of world but
people could have said a dark horse
right
but
this but this is not this is strange
this is really this is very strange
[Laughter]
it's shocking surprising i don't know we
run out of words
and here is where we stand with one game
remaining we do expect fabi to
score
and
get to five out of seven and if you had
said to fabiano
bobby first half you get five out of
seven he said how far in first place am
i
i mean
everybody else
it's
trailing at 50 and you're yeah you have
some of those tournaments once in a
while right where you play really well
yeah but there's somebody else that just
this is killing it i remember i was
working as a second to
tata tata of abraham
here at the saint louis chess club we
had the u.s women's championship in
2019.
we had a great tournament eight and a
half out of 11. just a second let's
figure that out eight and a half out of
11 so it's eight and a half three and a
half plus five baby
that's an easy first it's an easy first
jennifer you ends up the tournament 10
out of 11 plus
nine
what can you do there is ignorance
and he hates you
i mean
wow 10 out of 11. i remember that
tournament jennifer just
everything broke
perfect
wow even a game she was losing was it
annie against annie she somehow she
turned around
and wow and i think she lost the last
one didn't she no no no she ended with
two draws she actually ended up winning
the last game against that nasa tonski i
want to say dang black pieces dang
that's a that's a huge huge huge first i
remember i had i played in tata steel
at the time it was called hoghovens
and i scored 10 and a half out of 13.
what
10 and a half out of 13.
yeah really beat coach noy beat tim on
beat everybody this is great pretty good
walter brown scored 10 and a half out of
13.
it's unbelievable
it's like what
it was like what i i mean i thought i
won first you know
galloping away
i mean we both crossed the finish line
with the same score it was
it was it was a crazy crazy event and
somehow we brought out the best and won
another
great rival
walter sean brown
six time the u.s champion
we miss him
queen f6 and
what's the clock time 22 minutes for
teamwork so he still has
plenty of time to think so i would
assume queen to e8 definitely has to be
considered right queen to e8 right now
king to d6 but then well there's not
that much else right it's queen f6 you
see rook to e7 and you can calculate
that easily and you understand that
you're probably going to be okay with
black but then king to d6 and there's a
big question to answer how do you defend
this rook exactly if you move it
anywhere around i have a feeling you
give me another move i'll check mate
right exactly if you go for example here
perhaps even king to c7 just that's
nasty discovered check that's a nice
discovery check and if you go here
actually i have queen to d4 another
diagonal check
and i just inch closer to you rook to d6
that's game over so you cannot do that
the attacking king
exactly the attacking king so what do
you do you go king to b5 right defending
the rook but this just allows me to
simplify the position and simplify it by
force it's not very difficult to
calculate this rook to b7 king a4 cannot
be played because of king takes c5 so
you have to go to c4 but after queen to
e6 you can see that this is a position
without the queens but a much worse
version because my rook gets behind the
ball all right already you're already
behind the pawn and you're i'm already
controlling f5 so at this point it does
seem like
the only move that you can play
with a clear conscious is
queen takes f6 and then a4 and start
pushing the pawn and hope for the best
right
it's the only thing you can do at this
point exactly now rook to d8 this was
the move that we mentioned how about
king to a5
how is this race going to proceed so f5
i go a3 you give me a check do you give
me a check yeah i'll give you a check
sure one you'll give me a check i go
king actually maybe that check wasn't
that
precise
because this allows me to get the rook
to
a5 quickly so if you go king to g6 rook
to a5 or knight to a4
yeah i'm not going to do this i'm not
going to do this it's a race i i know
it's a race
i feel like i i let you i let it slip
yeah yeah we were looking at k5
okay i liked your yeah
and i like king g6
so i keep pushing yeah but this one i
feel i'm up a tempo in a variation you
already showed oh and you can just like
just take it on yeah
this is a much better version yeah this
is a lot easier simpler much simpler so
this one was easy but how easy is it to
go all the way from here instead of rook
to d8
rook to d2
so a3 f5
and this variation how easy is this
the other one is a lot easier right yeah
this is the one where you showed us
knight c1 knight six the knight cannot
get back right it can't get time because
this d3 square is mined correct and
that's kind of the only way you can get
to e5 from which you can protect against
the promotion
knight to b4 knight d5 this diagonal you
cannot place the knight anywhere on this
diagonal
so unfortunately knight c1 knight d3
doesn't work because of russia
we know that what you have shown us yes
so how can you
the the funny lines it's it's not easy
so you h4f7
but then i can go here in fact why
just go kenji's own
i don't think you need fancy play
are you in time though so remember what
you you're looking at you're gaming
you're gaining some uh some time like
this right because yes bishop to g guys
doesn't matter queen eight played queen
e8 is on the board wow
well to d6 i i think i think about it
from timor's point of view please
perhaps he sees queen f6 as hopeless
if fair enough i would think i would
think
but he says let me throw in one last
trick okay
that if you blunder the move rookie
seven i escape i escape to a drawn
queen ending after i trade everything
and i
i promote upon and you promote upon
something that we saw
from afar but this is fabiano caruana
you're talking exactly
everybody queens and black is happy yeah
try something so
both queens it's kind of one of those
things where
you've got two choices you can block
with your queen but then i've got a a
perpetual
you could block with the rook yeah you
can block with the rook
and then i'll make a draw or my opponent
finds the move king b6 and i'm lost and
then i resign and then i lost and then i
resign
and that's the question do we have any
better moves as black after king to d6
yeah that's a question outside of king
b5 which allows the queen trade
well i have to defend the rook somehow
so what about rook c4 how is ah rook c4
just king deep no
it's illegal illegal
so what did we do
there was something like that that
happened and i still don't know the
whole
thing it was a blitz tournament blitz
world championship
where magnus
the magnus's opponent hung is king
uh it was something that magnus made
another move and the opponent said
that's illegal because my king's in
check
magnus like what
the guy is trying to win a game
because he made an illegal move and said
that magnus can't make that move because
it was illegal too well let's say that
funny let's say that it led to fear
changing some regulations that was
pretty ridiculous but i i'm with you 100
christian i like your idea king d5
discover check to black's king but i
think this one is easy right you go rk7
there's no way you take that because
it's mate
queen g7 queen bison is just made right
let's just show it but you're absolutely
right of course
queen b7 mate thanks to the so let's go
to b5 but then i go queen e5 i don't
have to calculate anything
then you go queen e5
yeah and that makes it really easy right
suddenly my pawn is even one square so
let's go to b6 then
what
what uh rook check kingdom
b6
i forgot this was legal
good morning st louis
it's still legal don't forget we can
give you another check and i go back to
e6
uh this is getting confused uh maybe i
like i like rook b7 like somehow i like
the fact that the moment i can move my
king let's keep going
oh you mean something like this that and
now i'm with you okay oh that's illegal
that's the thing i don't have a legal
note with the kids
good morning
[Applause]
that's great what hour of commentaries
wow so i was trying to make the illegal
move king c7 um
any move with the king would be most
excellent the problem is that the king
doesn't have the legal wait wait wait
guys guys guys guys at the end keep
going yeah rook b7 king a6 yes
yes
yes and now we have queen e6
exactly
we lose the f4 pawn no no i don't want
that never mind
queen to e6 you just trade and then take
on f4
that's
crazy just a second this is so hard
uh
this is funny
um you know can i make
room for my king somehow
let's say i go here
so that i i can make a discover check
i i must be missing something what is
your answer
to
queen rook d4 i had this are you ready
for this one check
with king c5
check
yeah
you could take the rook and then go rook
d4 check though you're not going to my
question was going to be um jeez how to
go why why'd you say i the problem the
problem with my desired rook d8 so that
i could go king's c7 check is you could
take the rook and how do we feel about
that end game the bishop's pretty
dominated then then the bishop uh
i don't want to do this the game kind of
flares anew i'm scared yeah i don't want
to do that maybe you don't want to do
this
suddenly because the pawn is pretty fast
i mean i go f5 also
right but then that's another race yeah
but that's a
should be winning at the end but it's
not going to be honest okay bale is out
bale is out come on christian
11 moves 12 minutes
christian so rough 27 is a good start
king to b6 rook to b7 is a good
follow-up
and now rook to b3
get out really so any checks will be
answered by check check check check
check
check yes
so if you check me here king d5 just
wins check check
ah
it doesn't even finish the line yeah
there's so much geometry in the position
you have a knight d4 at the end but this
one is pretty easy right well this one
yeah i would have never gone to d7 but
whatever
i'll get to give up the bishop in this
case i gotta give up the bishop for the
a pawn
so the move right now would be rook
takes f4 obviously
what
and that is not hanging because
it is hanging
it is hanging oh and you have to go
knight b5 and
85 the game is hard um yeah the game is
over
so up to b3 in fact just finishes the
game
well it's an awkward move it's not right
it's not being awkward right the slam
we by the way king's e6
played
king d6 played bobby on his way
but how long did it take him to find
that awkward move it took him seven
minutes he's down to 11 minutes with 20
seconds but remember that he does get
more time and move 60 he is 11 moves
away
that's one minute per move
with no increments that's not comfy and
what about uh teamwork timur is down to
18.
for also 11 moves 18. well for him but
yes 12 for him
king b6 rook c4 and you're telling me
the best move after rook c4 are
and i guess this is why he spends so
much time on this move king to d6
because it's not as obvious can i if i
play rook c4 right let me try this again
please i know we're tired i know the
engine wants to play rook k7 rook b7 rp3
and nobody's gonna ever play that right
can i go for something a little more
direct can i just go rookie seven and
say where's your queen going
rook c5 rook c4 right now with the
checks or without the checks without
i guess it doesn't matter
it's the same position okay no no no it
matters a lot
because i have rook c6 without with the
check
no no i don't want to drag your queen
king to v6 it doesn't exactly make sense
go to p7 right away instantly right now
well if you go rk7 followed by rookie 7
then i have rook c6 at the end and that
allows me to equalize right well i
understand that
and that is why alejandro would like to
play the move rook e7
immediately immediately
you've got to build yourself up to
really get that immediately i'll try
i feel like i have a chuck next move
okay so i'll give you a check
on
no but checking on b8 king d7
that has to be lights out no wait never
mind i have king b5 queen e5
yes what i just want to trade the queens
man
oh i mean in the analysis i thought he
made the movie no no no no no but how
easy is that how he is what let's keep
going let's keep going
this is queen b8
queen b8 that's okay you can exchange
the queens but my king is on b4 now
okay go king d7 i do
king to b5 okay first of all let's make
sure we're not blundering like checkmate
or anything here right no looks like
rookie five is kind of messy
okay let's trade the queens trade the
queens
take on e5 yeah
with the queen hopefully
yesterday with the queen oh sorry
i'm trying
i i was trying to drag the king
why why am i thinking of the rook that
was the point take with the pawn i
apologize
uh with the rook on e7 you want to take
with you yeah actually no it's a little
awkward right right right yeah yeah i
see what you mean let's just uh let's
get this guy okay let's get this guy
going
you get that guy going i'll get
my guy going a4 yes you do
uh f6 or rookie one i just kind of want
to
get my rook over here yeah i don't think
that the the knights dominated i don't
think it matters for this okay for this
one tempo f6 f7 that's fine f6 okay a3
now now
let's go we're you go a2 i'll go row k1
right i'm not going to allow you to play
knight a2 and knight b1
so
i'll just put that down just pre-move
for your move
that's a good point
and i do believe that f7
and either king e8
or king e7 is going to escort the pawn
home and of course the resulting game is
hard yes dead lost this looks good guys
yeah all right this looks good
and
again it's simple
that's what we're trying to find for
fabi right right the ideas of rook a7
rook b7 rook b5 by the way timor and by
the way
for the most uh annoying
honorary move there is in the position
for white to face he found it by the way
guys um
we did go
through with that variation with queen
to e5 and it was actually extremely
precise
really so rook to e7 by the engine
that end game is as winning as we made
it look like
oh good yeah we
we're not completely yeah
our fingers may be bleeding
i mean you did try to take on e5 with
the kings
can we get rid of this guy
possibly he's not welcome tomorrow
out the door
we have a social media question thank
you everybody that's helping out here on
our broadcast we uh it's late from
twitch user blitz just kidding are there
any plans for a yasser biography nope
good next question
uh we're done i i i did have um the
chest tools and i really enjoyed it
enjoyed that one that was a book about
all my games with the world champions
and then i was uh thinking of a
compendium volume chest duels with
challengers and champions because i have
played
from all over the world the national
champions of the world and the
challengers
and some great stories but no i mean
these days
books
they're out the door everybody's doing
videos
and um
software trainings and
i can't even
puzzle russia's uh books
folks don't read books what is this book
thing
what is this book thing as a coach you
know what exactly what i'm talking about
uh podcast by the way guys we have
another move that we did not consider at
all play to buy fabi so let's take a
look whoa and he played it rather
quickly he kind of has to right nine
minutes for the remaining moves uh rook
c7 played great move one of those looks
extremely logical i am ready to tr oh
that's so nice because you can't
try it you can't go backwards i've got
mate and if you try to step up
we don't trade queens anymore i just
pick up the queen now in the meanwhile
the move rook c7 is an invitation to
you check me somehow
and let me make a check check for
example not that this is a good move but
just as an example of what fabby is
hoping for any time he can move his king
he gets to do so with check so rook c7
good move you say christian great move
yeah great move from a practical
perspective i think this is a great move
what is the answer to uh knight e4
do i just take the knight
um
i have to have to do it right because
you have to take the knot this works
right that's true
check
this is uh that will hurt you
so you have to take it i have to take it
and i think with the queen but then
chuck
king d7
chago
i think even trading queens is is
winning i think winnie five is winning
because at the end of it e8 is with a
check so if you take on c7
and take on c7 and a4 e8 comes with a
check oh that is nasty
yes um
the table bases agree with you
wholeheartedly
that that would uh indeed be the game so
c7
game after um rook c7 king b5
rook c7 no knight e4 big king to be five
this is trivial like a queen e5 queen e5
you take that's the same thing i'm
promoting with chuck and then i go no
yes it was the queen thank god if i was
a queen
i'm trying to get him off
rook to d4
oh
i forgot about this rook to david for
check right okay gotcha king somewhere
so king has to at least go in front of
the pawn momentarily yeah but the other
bad news you win a tempo
that's the tempo yeah yeah that's an
important tempo actually
i don't know how important it is but so
king to b4 let's continue yeah
what if i give you a
just one check to see where you go
just one look to c5 right it feels now
king 25 that knight is so dominated by
the bishop that's that's very
unfortunate for uh for black uh yeah
this looks winning this actually looks
quite easy okay
so the more we looking at it uh with all
due respects to rookie seven which is a
fine move rook c7
it's it's a good practical move yeah i
agree with that it is very practical i
like drug c7 not that much to calculate
no in fact at this stage in the game the
less you have to calculate you know like
the better it is because as the game
you know you're worn out of energy
and the more
prone you are to making mistakes so if
you can see a simple any way
to get out of this trade for black
yeah again i was looking at this rook d4
check trying to delay
takes knight b5 but you just go king c5
check and that's that's a killer
yeah and by the way even
taking on d4 yeah it almost wins right
rook d4 queen takes d4 knight b5 king c5
no it wins bloody how you have queen f8
say what say that again rook d4 yeah
yeah queen d4 knight b5 knight beats
a5 this is what we call a family fork by
the way yeah but you can only take one
at a time and i
rip and then bishop should be seven
bishops he says when i pick up your
queen
for
not for free not for free but you pick
up the queen and i think that should be
winning yeah because i pick up the night
at the end yeah no it's not you have 96.
you have 96 at the end of it oh this is
crazy but you could start with rook to
b7 in that case
what just start with no no no
after king to b8 you can go rook b7
first get the rook off the c7 square and
96 idea and then pick up the queen and
then you pick up the knight very nice
the problem is this line is queen of fa
don't know where we're spending so much
time but the problem with this line i
thought was uh queen takes d4
oh sorry knight b5 yes and then kind of
unfortunately after king c5 i think
black has queen fate and i think it
actually wins because it controls uh
that's uh oh
aldo that's nasty because the knight on
d4 controls e2
and you would love to yes yes
your king c66 followed by bishop e2 but
unfortunately it's just a check oh my
goodness
okay we're feeling a little uh loopy
over here i wonder how uh fabi is
feeling because these guys
i i mean we've seen their um
kind of a reception room where they do
have snacks they can look at their games
on the map
the monitors but energy levels man
you've got to be in great uh physical
stamina as you go into what six hours of
play already what are we at even longer
aren't we what time is it 142. no we're
approaching six wow
uh you feel it and
oops
for some reason we
don't have the
let me refresh my board i apologize
c7 got it
and still 10 moves to go with only eight
minutes for timur and nine minutes and
30 seconds for fabiano
after this move rook to c7 though it
does seem like fabiano's moves are quite
straightforward if you go king b5 i
exchange the queens
queen b5 any any queen trade and that's
devastating extremely happy
uh makes it very easy for us uh to
calculate that our pawn
is uh making a queen and you move the
knight you give me the d5 square check
check
you move the rooks anywhere else you
give me the c5 square that's a check
devastating as well you move the queen
anywhere else king to d7 or king to e7
that's another check devastating so
there's just simply no options at this
point right for black you have to accept
the trade of uh not only the rooks but
the queens as well yeah and that's just
going to be game over
you ran out of road
there's no more road ahead yeah
that's it uh rook c7
wow and for fabi you know
fabby also has this i want to say
practicality
when he's doing very very well it's not
like things go completely to his head
and he thinks oh i can take all kinds of
risks he's a very level-headed player
isn't he when he
even when the successes
are mounting as we're seeing right now
he wins this game he really is he has a
cool headed player um
when things are going well it doesn't
get to he said when things go badly it
kind of does and you see that but you
see that in blitz tournaments where he's
prone frustrating in a row yeah but a
classical chess he usually recovers
quite well
and very importantly you don't have this
you don't suffer from wins i think a lot
of people do
that you suffer from a win where you get
too much confidence you believe a little
bit too much on yourself you're willing
to take risks that you normally wouldn't
right but that's not favi no
let me just uh adjust my board for a
second
as we uh again we're reaching the end of
the second time control down to his last
five minutes with ten moves to go timor
needs to hurry as soon as the players
reach move 60 they will get that
additional 15 minutes with the 30 second
increments but until they reach move 60
there is no increments the only
time on their clocks that they have is
what they have currently no no
increments coming up until move 60 plus
rook c7 and we love this move
we haven't found a solution
full stop oh there probably isn't one
because there isn't one it's a good
reason not to find something
that's always been my problem
so let's keep going king to b5
king to b5 get queen e5 right that's
been our
go-to game move we trade
we sure do by the way king b5 is on the
board okay okay
so you take with the pawn
and a moment ago
the problem is that gives you another
temple
because of the knight on c3 hanging
i don't like that okay
if i take on c7 you just simply cannot
stop my pawn
the knight is dominated and also the
pawn
promotes with check right
so that's a big problem that's a very
big problem
yeah i just simply don't see
i don't see it and if you take with the
king on e5
what huh no rook takes
[Laughter]
out the security security
security queen
he hasn't played queen e5 sorry once
again how much time does this file be
fabi has eight minutes i wanna say
that's 8 minutes and 17 seconds right
now but queen to e5 should come up that
really reduces the material on the board
makes it uh
even though there's nine moves uh once
the queens are off the board the ability
of these players to calculate
it will be instantly
yeah it's it can't be overstated that
would be easy so the fact that he's
taking a moment
could it mean that uh there are other
ways of maybe skinning the cat not that
i would be looking for them but
especially in this position i just
wouldn't look at anything else
right so let's take it
one more one more step at a time right
queen to e5 we exchange you take on e5
rook to d4
let's keep going into that same
variation
okay okay so king e6
queenie no no queen fight
stop
okay stop it
this is terrible that rook to default
thomas is about to take her places i can
make illegal moves too you know i i have
a threshold six illegal moves or more
than i'm out who do you find he's on the
board guys queenie if i'm on the yeah
board thank you pappy thanks dave wow
and take stakes we're actually going
straight into that one so d4 king
to e6 i would assume yes yeah and i
think you have to because if you don't
play rook d4 you have the problems of e6
as well but at some point you can also
consider just going bishop c6 and
disrupting your coordination on the
queen side i'll get my rook behind the
pawn you're not going to get anything
behind my pawn no it's so if i start
with a4 what do you play i play bishop c
do you go e6 no i play bishop c6 there
bishop c6 i think that's the easiest
that's what uh he's suggesting um that's
what the doctor's christian yeah that's
so what if i go um that looks pretty
strange b6 now
i'll give you a
hackasito i'll
and this is what i wanted i got my
behind the pawn yeah
you're not you're not promoting anything
so i go a3
very nice
e6
a2 i give up my work and you don't even
get to give up well just a second uh
you
first of all
that's just over right wait how is it
over check we move
oh it's you take with uh move the bishop
you have to move the bishop
five questions but where do you put the
bishop because now i have rook a4 right
bishop d5 i like
bishop d5 you like
unless i'm blundering before i'm
blundering i'm blundering
[Laughter]
just push the pawn right maybe you're
right maybe you should just
push the pawn a4
push the pawn keep the king on b5 so
that you promote with check and just
push the pawn
i have a really good idea
with the king on b5 we should promote
our pawn with check good job
thank you beautiful okay i've got to
figure it out christian all right
nice we expecting e6
uh no respecting uh f takes e5 on the
board so we're still waiting for
teamwork to play down to his last two
minutes and 45 seconds
with eight moves to go yeah he's not uh
yeah you have to play right d4 right he
doesn't
otherwise e6 is too easy
exactly e6 is just this game will be
over before the next time control i
think he took he took on c7 wait what
not c6 that's not correct
there's no way that's correct no he took
on c7 and rook takes king takes e7
already on the board right because we
saw it was sort of like
sometimes with the dgt boards what
happens is the players played rook on c4
capture c7 chat capture c7 but he moves
through the c6 square and sometimes the
dgt board picks up the move rook c6 it's
kind of like a shadow right as it
continues its journey so the only move
right now is to go to one c7 king c5
right
but where's kx5 they want to go knight
b5 followed by knight d6 do you allow me
to do that yes
absolutely congratulations yeah good job
congratulations
uh i stopped your pawn yes of course i
stop my pawn and then i freeze everybody
and i never you're actually going to put
me in a zoo zone of course yeah i mean i
have the choices i can just promote my
tom will be so excited i know right a
genuine zukes one wow wow we're gonna
get the two's one guys yeah baby
fantastic never happen so excited
yeah yeah but so let's show that
actually so bishop
then the idea is that which by the way
if you are asking that must be winning
totally oh he's completely winning
totally i mean i would probably play g4
myself and then put my pawn on h just
kidding just to make sure you're getting
that when i when i do promote that
you're never going to give me an h pawn
and i i'll have the wrong color h pawn
this is over guys yes yeah this is over
i think uh resignation is imminent in
this one right
and again i don't want to say anything
bad about timor but it just seems to me
like he
at times he's played really well
and when
you know he's missed those moments he's
never recovered it's like he just
doesn't get
uh a chance magnus carlson gave him a
zero percent chance of winning when the
tournament started and zero that was it
felt harsh right but diemer's not
disproving it unfortunately for uh him
no
that is true and we do have again these
moves are on the board knight b5 check
king d7 and i think once timor gets
to these parts
he's gonna yeah he's gonna recognize
that he even
a successful knight takes e8 will not
work yeah he's actually played um
a4 before first i don't think it makes
any difference
excuse me a4 on the board i apologize
it just makes the zuzwang easier to
achieve i think yeah knight t6 and
bishop d1 followed by bishop b3
here you have knight e4 but i assume
that 94 i can go king is six i think
king is sex right
this is you don't want to let this guy
sacrifice itself
what you were saying about g4 and uh
okay just sacrifice
just just go e8 come on just go ahead
come on
come on
we got you we got you we we we we hear
you uh
uh a few easy ways of winning we do have
e7 currently on the board
yeah and i said 96.
the only thing you can't do is promote
right away just don't go e you're just
gonna go e8
i mean the horror
of
uh
allowing that
that
after a2 you don't even get to stop the
pawn
i mean
like
careers could be ruined that doesn't
happen at the scholastic level has it oh
it's over i think it's over and by the
way i think with the kings on d5 that
means that white it's officially over
fabiano corona has defeated timur
rajabov and keeps the chase alive
thankfully for commentators because
otherwise well we're going to talk for
seven rounds i'm telling you uh
these two players have been
the successes of the tournament
absolutely they're collecting all the
victories take a look at the standings
janupomniechi and fabiano carrana with
five and a half on five points are
heads shoulders torsos legs everything
ahead of the competition as hikaru
nakamura is the only person on third
place with three and a half the rest of
the players are on minus one or worse
yeah and that
that's it for them that says it all
where it's
confirmed coming into the round we
thought 90 chance that one of these two
players will win
the event we're gonna
bump that up
to 95 percent as tomorrow we have these
round eight pairings the second half of
this double round robin will continue
alexandra it's an important game let's
see if we have a spoiler in one of the
with the games richard rapper will be
playing white against yanshi shravu and
firuja will play rajabov but they're not
very relevant games the important ones
will be nepamyachi with the white pieces
against dingley renk and the chinese
player who doesn't have any pressure on
him now
uh could snap back with a victory not
back
with white would like to return the
favor of the first half where ikaru was
ground down by fabi that catapulted
fabby into the lead and finally farouza
versus timor
have a nice game yeah enjoy
sure it'll be great
christian uh bring it home for us
well guys uh what a day of uh chess but
this tournament is a story of two
players that is jan nepam nyashi and
fabiano caruana going head to head into
the second half of the event they're
just uh cannot stop winning i have to
say fabiano really inspires me the way
he plays the way he keeps pays with jan
nepomnyashi yan today let's be honest he
was gifted a point by a young ritchie
rapport but what a way to take it home
that was with the black pieces in a pet
drop it's just incredible these players
are bringing it and the action tomorrow
cannot be more exciting and i will be
watching it from my couch probably i
will join you uh at around nine o'clock
we need a guest we need a guest could
you make it 7 30 a.m no no no
nine o'clock i will skype you guys in
from my couch i will give you my in
insights about the games
we'll take it from there guys all right
all right christian we will miss you we
will definitely miss you yes so we'll
have dorset tomorrow indeed we will and
now once again
prediction as well look at that napo
that's cheating
straight up
i'm on my lawyer
right now right here what is this what
is this
where's our professional chess
association union representative is that
portraying us halfway and look at this
dorsa already
you know but the good news is
who the commentators who get the answers
right
the production team all reaches deep
into their pockets to give the winning
prize
very nice we love our production team
around here we definitely do join us
tomorrow round eight can somebody spoil
the party for the leaders that's gonna
be the question for the rest of the
tournament except for round nine it's
gonna be a fateful one between nepo with
black against favi but we still have to
pass through round a to get there join
us tomorrow sunday it was going to be a
great day of chess good night everyone
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you